BELL -- ALSO
[inaudible]
MURTADA [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
MONNING HERE MORLOCK.
MORRELL [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
INNER STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
UMBERG [inaudible]
BY KASKI.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COMMITTEE
SECRETARY --
NOTICES THE PRESENCE OF A QUORUM.
WE WILL GAL BILLION IN BEGAN OUR
FIRST BUDGET COMMITTEE HEARING
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY HAPPY NEW
YEAR.
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME EVERYONE TO
THE BEGINNING OF THE SENATE
BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW HEARING
PROCESS FOR THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET YEAR.
THE PURPOSE OF TODAY'S HEARING
IS TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
GOVERNOR OF GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
FIRST HIS HIS INAUGURAL --
BUDGET PROPOSAL.
AS IN PRIOR YEARS SUBSEQUENT TO
TODAY'S HEARING WILL CONDUCT
ADDITIONAL FULL COMMITTEE
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS IN THE
COMING WEEKS TO DO DEEP DIVES
INTO SPECIFIC BUDGET PROPOSALS
ON ISSUES THAT WILL BE
DELIBERATED.
THROUGHOUT THE SPRING THE FIRST
WHILE FIRE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
PREPAREDNESS PROPOSALS AND
THAT'S ABOUT BUDGET HEARING IS
SCHEDULED FOR JANUARY THIRTY
FIRST.
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE IS WILL
BEGIN THEIR DELIBERATIONS INTO
FEBRUARY OR EARLY MARCH.
I'M EAGER TO BEGIN THE
DISCUSSION TODAY ON A BUDGET
THAT CONTINUES TO BE MINDFUL OF
THE NEED TO BUILD CALIFORNIA'S
FISCAL RESILIENCY IN ORDER TO
PROTECT HE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
RESIDENTS RELY UPON.
WHILE TARGETING IMPORT
INVESTMENT IN MANY AREAS THAT
MEMBERS OF THIS BODY HAVE BEEN
FIGHTING.
FOR SUCH AS EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION EXPANDING PAID FAMILY
LEAVE.
INCREASING PRESCHOOL ACCESS TO
CHILDCARE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
ADDRESSING HEALTH DISPARITIES
AND CAL WORKS INCREASES.
HIGHER EDUCATION IT INCLUDES
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES YOU SEE AND
SEE ISSUE [inaudible]
AFFORDABILITY SIGNIFICANTLY
EXPANDING THE EITC EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDIT.
MAKING INVESTMENT IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND EXPANDING ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE.
ISSUES AROUND JUSTICE AND
DIGNITY THE DIGITAL FUNDING FOR
IMMIGRATION SERVICES MOVING THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE TO
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY.
AND PROVIDING FUNDING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO BUILD EMERGENCY
SHELTERS AND NAVIGATION SYSTEM
CENTERS.
AND THIS PREVIOUSLY REFERENCE
MAKING SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
TO ENHANCE OUR STATE EMERGENCY
READINESS RESPONSE AND OUR
RECOVERY CAPABILITIES.
THROUGHOUT THE SPRING THE
LEGISLATURE WILL REVIEW THESE
PROPOSALS I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION.
OTHER KEY STAKEHOLDERS MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE AND NOT ONLY
VETTING THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
BUT ALSO ESTABLISHING THE
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES FOR THE
NINETEEN TWENTY FISCAL YEAR.
WITH THAT SAID LET ME FIRST
ACKNOWLEDGE THE ABSENCE OF MY
COMMITTEE VICE CHAIR SENATOR
NIELSEN YOU CAN JOIN US TODAY.
BECAUSE HE'S TEN ATTENDING THE
TWO ARE RELATED TO THE RECENT
WILDFIRES AND I THINK THERE ARE
A FEW OTHER MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMITTEES WHO --
OF OUR COMMITTEE THAT ARE ARE ON
THAT TOO AS WELL I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME THE TWO NEW FACES TO THE
TOP TABLE BEFORE US THIS IS LIKE.
WE MADE THE TRANSITION FROM
MIDDLE SCHOOL TO HIGH SCHOOL
SOME OF YOUR CLASSMATES GO THE
SAME HIGH SCHOOL SO WE SEE SOME.
OLD FACES WE HAVE SOME NEW FACES.
HERE ON THE DAY OF THE LIKE TO
WELCOME THE NEW MEMBERS --
WHO NEWLY ELECTED AND AT NEW TO
THE SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE I AM
A GREAT BUDGET HERE YOU CAN HAVE
A BLAST?
SO WE KNOW YEAH YES OF THE WHOLE
AUDIENCE WHO WILL CONFIRM THAT
BY DOING THAT YES THEY WELL YEAH
SEE THE AGREE.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO WELCOME.
ON THE TWO NEW FACES AT THE
TABLE -- WE
HAVE CAROLINE CHU WHO IS ARE
ACTING LED TO ANALYSTS THANK YOU
CAROLYN.
HAND WE HAVE REPRESENTING THE
ADMINISTRATION TODAY OUR NEW
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE THAT.
THIS ONE OF THE ON I'VE BEEN
PRACTICING THAT ALL MORNING.
THE THE THE BACK THIS WANT ON AM
I CLOSE.
OKAY.
YOU SAY IT SO EVERYONE CAN HEAR
ONE TIME IT'S VAGUE THIS ONE
OFTEN.
THE ONE I GOT IT THE THINK THIS
ONE OFTEN WRECKED YES.
THEY THIS ONE OFTEN.
IT THE STATE TO SELL THREE TIMES
THE BANK THIS WILL NOT THEN.
WE'RE GOING TO HONOR YOU BY
MAKING SURE WE KNOW THE CORRECT
WAY TO PRONOUNCE YOUR NAME --
MEMBERS AGAIN [inaudible]
WELCOME.
ALL AND READY TO GO AHEAD AND
GET STARTED MISTER THIS ONE
OFTEN WILL LEAD A SOFT BY
PRESENTING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
JOINING US.
GREAT THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM
CHAIR FOR HAVING ME AND THANK
YOU TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS VEGAS FOR NOTHING I
SERVICE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR BUDGET AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
I WANT TO BEGIN BY MAKING THREE
POINTS ABOUT THE BUDGET TODAY.
THE FIRST IS EXACTLY WHAT MADAM
CHAIR MENTIONED AT THE START
WHICH IS THAT THIS IS A BUDGET
THAT IS BASED ON PHYSICAL%
STRENGTH AND FISCAL RESILIENCY.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT BUILDING THE
SPACE OF FISCAL STRENGTH AS A
PREDICATE FOR EXPANDING PROGRAMS
AND MAKING THE INVESTMENT THAT
WE WANT TO MAKE.
IN THE GOVERNOR'S INAUGURAL
ADDRESS HE TALKED ABOUT
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL AND BUILDING
A HOME THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS CAN
WEAPONS.
AND AS WE ALL KNOW A GOOD HOME
BEGINS WITH A STRONG FOUNDATION
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE BEGINNING
WITH RESILIENCY AT THE VERY
START.
THE SECOND POINT I WANT TO MAKE
ABOUT THIS BUDGET IS THAT IT IS
A BOLD BUDGET IT'S INTENDED TO
BE AN AMBITIOUS BUDGET.
SOME OF THE POINTS THAT WERE
MAKING SOME THE INVESTMENTS THAT
WE'RE MAKING WILL RESULT
IMMEDIATELY TAKE INCREASES TO
YOU SEE CSU.
CAL WORKS FOR EXAMPLE.
SOME OF THE OTHER INVESTMENTS
WERE MAKING ARE DESIGNED TO FACE
AND OVER A PERIOD OF TIME AS WE
BUILD CAPACITY AND MAKE THE FIND
THE REVENUES TO MAKE THOSE
INVESTMENTS OVER A PERIOD OF
YEARS.
THESE ARE IN AREAS SUCH AS A
PRESCHOOL CHILD CARE PAID FAMILY
LEAVE AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON BUILDING UP
THE PATHWAY TO CHIEF SOME THESE
PRIORITIES.
BUT EVEN IN THOSE PLACES WHERE
WE'RE FACING AND THE PROGRAMS
OVER A PERIOD OF YEARS.
AND WE UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR
PATIENCE WE BELIEVE THAT LAYING
DOWN THAT MARKER RIGHT NOW AND
SAYING THIS IS WHAT WE WANT TO
DO THIS IS WHAT WE'RE COMMITTED
TO AND THIS IS HOW WE HOPE TO
ACHIEVE IT.
IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
IT'S OFTEN SAID THAT WE
OVERESTIMATE WHAT WE CAN
ACCOMPLISH IN ONE YEAR OR TWO
YEARS AND UNDERESTIMATE WHAT WE
CAN ACCOMPLISH IN FIVE YEARS OR
TEN YEARS.
AND WE HOPE BY LAYING DOWN THESE
MARKERS THE BUDGET COULD MOVE US
IN THAT DIRECTION.
THE LAST POINT I WANT TO MAKE IS
THAT THIS IS THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL IT REFLECTS HIS
PRIORITIES.
BUT I HOPE YOU'LL ALSO FIND AT
THE INITIAL PROPOSAL THAT IT
REFLECTS SOME OF YOUR PRIORITIES
AS WELL.
AS SOME OF YOU KNOW --
THE GOVERNOR HAS BEEN IN TOUCH.
AT HIS PRESS CONFERENCE HE
CALLED OUT SEVERAL YOU BY NAME
IN TALKING ABOUT SOME HIS
PROPOSALS.
SO THAT'S A CONVERSATION THAT HE
WANTS TO CONTINUE THAT ALL OF US
IN THE ADMINISTRATION HOPE TO
CONTINUE.
AND AS YOU DISCUSS THIS BUDGET
AS YOU DELIBERATE ON IT AS YOU
SHAPE IT AS YOU AMENDED.
WE HOPE THAT WE'LL BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS BUDGET
REFLECTS BOTH HIS PRIORITIES AND
YOURS.
AND SO BEGINNING WITH AN
OVERVIEW OF THE BUDGET WE'VE GOT
ONE HUNDRED FORTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS IN SPENDING IN OUR
GENERAL FIND.
OUT WHEN YOU ADD IN SPECIAL
FUNDS AND BOND FUNDS THE TOTAL
COMES TO TWO HUNDRED NINE
BILLION DOLLARS WE HAVE WHAT THE
GOVERNOR CALLED AN INTERESTING
SURPLUS OF TWENTY ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS PROJECTED AT THE
END OF THE COMING BUDGET YEAR.
THAT'S A BIG SURPLUS WE ALSO
KNOW FROM RECENT CALIFORNIA
HISTORY THAT THE SURPLUS IS CAN
BE EVANESCENT.
THAT'S WHY IN THIS BUDGET WE
HAVE A LARGE RATIO OF ONE TIME
SPENDING COMPARED TO ONGOING
SPENDING OVER 86% OF THE BUDGET
FROM THE SURPLUS IS ONE TIME
SPENDING.
LESS THAN 14% IS ON GOING
SPENDING THAT MEANS FOR EVERY
SIX DOLLARS IN ONE TIME SPENDING
COMMITTED OUT OF THE SURPLUS WE
SPEND JUST A DOLLAR FOR ON GOING
SPENDING.
AND THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS BUDGET IS NOT JUST
BALANCE THIS YEAR AND AS WE ALL
KNOW.
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION WE HAVE TO SUBMIT A
BALANCED BUDGET AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAS TO ENACT.
ONE BUT WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE BUDGET IS BALANCED
OVER THE FORECAST PERIOD WHICH
UNDER PROPOSITION TWO IS THE
THREE YEARS FOLLOWING THE BUDGET
YEAR.
SO IN OUR PROJECTIONS THE BUDGET
WE PROPOSED SHOWS A POSITIVE
OPERATING SURPLUS THAT MEANS
REVENUES IN THAT YEAR AND
EXPENDITURES IN THAT YEAR.
NOT JUST FOR TWENTY NINETEEN AND
TWENTY AND THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THIS IS A
BUDGET ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH WE
FACE GROWING RISKS.
AS GOVERNOR BROWN OFTEN
MENTIONED WE'RE APPROACHING THE
LONGEST ECONOMIC EXPANSION SINCE
WORLD WAR.
TWO THE STOCK MARKET BOTTOMED
OUT IN THE SPRING OF TWO
THOUSAND NINE SO TEN YEARS.
FROM NOW WILL BE THIS SUMMER AND
THAT MATCH THE EXPANSION THAT WE
SAW BETWEEN NINETEEN NINETY ONE
AND TWO THOUSAND ONE WHEN THE
DOT COM CRASH HAPPENED.
AND SO WE DON'T KNOW WHEN THIS
EXPANSION IS GOING TO AND
THERE'S A FAMOUS SAYING AMONG
ECONOMISTS THAT.
THEY PREDICT NINE OUT OF THE
LAST FIVE RECESSIONS.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT --
WHAT CANNOT GO ON INDEFINITELY
AT SOME POINT WILL COME TO A
STOP AND WE HAVE TO BE PREPARED
FOR THAT?
WE SING DIZZYING VOLATILITY IN
THE STOCK MARKET BUT THE S. AND
P. FIVE HUNDRED WITHIN THE
BEGINNINGS OF A POSSIBLE TRADE
WAR WITH CHINA --
WE HAVE A SHUTDOWN OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT --
AND WE'VE A WHITE HOUSE THAT CAN
OFTEN BE UNPREDICTABLE.
AND SO WHEN YOU PUT ALL THESE
THINGS TOGETHER THERE'S A LOT TO
WATCH OUT FOR AND OUR DEPARTMENT
HAS MODELED A RECESSION SCENARIO
TO SEE HOW OUR BUDGET WOULD
WHETHER RECESSION.
THERE A RECESSION SOONER THAT
THEY MODELS --
HAS A RECESSION THAT IS LESS
SEVERE THAN THE RECESSION THAT
HAPPENED IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWO
THOUSAND NINE THE GREAT
RECESSION BUT MORE SEVERE THAN
THE RECESSION THAT HAPPENED AT
TWO THOUSAND ONE AT THE END OF
THE DOT COM CRASH.
AND UNDER THAT MODEL WE FOUND
THAT THE FIVE BILLION DOLLARS --
BEFORE ANY PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT EIGHT ADJUSTMENT AFTER ONE
YEAR.
AND SIXTY SIX BILLION DOLLARS
AFTER THREE YEARS --
SO THAT'S A BIG GAP THAT WE HAVE
TO BE MINDFUL LOGIC THAT
RECESSION COMES OUR WAY.
AND EVEN WITHOUT A RECESSION
WE'RE FORECASTING SLOWING
REVENUE GROWTH ABOUT THREE POINT
2% ANNUALIZED OVER THE FORECAST
PERIOD.
SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE WANT
TO BE READY FOR AS WELL.
AND THAT'S WHY AS THE CHAIR
MENTIONED WE'RE STARTING WIH
RESILIENCY THIS BUDGET INCLUDES
TEN BILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
SURPLUS AND RESILIENCY
INVESTMENTS.
IN DIGITAL THREE POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS FROM PROPOSITION
TWO PAYMENTS TO FURTHER BUILD
RESILIENCY.
AND LET ME GO TO REACH THOSE IN
TURN.
THE FIRST FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
IS TO PAY OFF BUDGETARY JACKSON
DEFERRALS AS MANY OF YOU
REMEMBER WHEN GOVERNOR BROWN
CAME INTO OFFICE HE POINTED TO
WHAT HE FAMOUSLY CALLED THE WALL
OF TAX.
MORE THAN THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS
IN BUDGETARY AND RELATED DEBTS.
THEY'RE STILL OVER TWO BILLION
DOLLARS OF THAT JACK REMAINING
AT THE START THIS BUDGET PERIOD.
THIS BUDGET --
PROPOSES TO PAY THOSE BUDGETARY
DEBTS ARE --
WHEN AND GOVERNOR'S WERE TRYING
TO DO --
THEY USE.
WHAT SOME CALL SOME KLAY PUSH A
PAYMENT INTO THE FOLLOWING
FISCAL YEAR FOR THAT PAYMENT IS
STILL THE STATE HAS TO MAKE IT
BUT IT WASN'T REFLECTED IN THAT
YEAR?
THIS BUDGET PROPOSES TO REVERSE
AND DOES ONE PAYMENT TO CALPERS
OF SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
AND ANOTHER A PAYROLL TO FOR ALL
OF ONE BILLION DOLLARS AND WE'RE
HOPING BY MAKING THOSE PAYMENTS
WHEN THEIR SCHEDULE WHEN WE'RE
SCHEDULE TO MAKE THEM.
WE CAN FURTHER BUILD RESILIENCY
AND GET OUR BUDGET ON TRACK.
THE SECOND THING THIS BUDGET
DOES IN THE RESILIENCY
DEPARTMENT IS BILLS RESERVES.
IT PUTS TWO POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS SINCE THE SPECIAL FINE
FOR ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTIES AND
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THAT'S THE FUN THAT THE DIRECTOR
OF FINANCE AND THE GOVERNOR
ACCESS IN EMERGENCIES.
INCLUDING THE RECENT WILDFIRES
THAT WE SAW IN CALIFORNIA IN
NOVEMBER.
IT ALSO PUT SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS INTO THE SAFETY
NET RESERVE WHICH I KNOW THE
CHAIR PLAYED A KEY ROLE IN
THINKING ABOUT CREATING.
THIS IS A FINE THAT MAKES SURE
THAT IN A DOWNTURN WE CAN
PROTECT OUR MEDI CAL AND CAL
WORKS PROGRAMS WHICH HELP OUR
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE THAT FUND
CURRENTLY HAS A BALANCE OF TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS WE'RE
PROPOSING TO MORE THAN QUADRUPLE
EIGHT TO NINE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS.
THE LAST THING WE DO FOR ON THE
RESERVE FRONT IS MAKE AN
ADDITIONAL ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLAR DEPOSIT INTO THE
BUDGET STABILIZATION ACCOUNT.
OFTEN KNOWN AS THE RAINY DAY
FUND AND ONE NOTE THAT I WANT TO
MAKE HERE IS THAT INITIALLY
UNDER GOVERNOR BROWN'S LAST
BUDGET.
THIS WAS FORECASTED TO REACH ITS
10% CONSTITUTIONAL CAP UNDER
PROPOSITION.
TWO HOWEVER --
WE RECEIVED OF LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL OPINION WHICH THE
ADMINISTRATION CONCURS WITH
WHICH BELIEVES THAT THE ONLY
PAYMENTS THAT APPLY TO THAT 10%
CAP OR MANDATORY DEPOSITS UNDER
PROPOSITION.
TWO BECAUSE ONLY PAYMENTS ARE
PER SHOULD BE GOVERNED BY ITS
RESTRICTIONS SO EVEN THOUGH --
THAT BALANCE OF THE FUND ILL BE
MORE THAN 10% OF GENERAL FUND
REVENUES AT THE END OF THIS
BUDGET YEAR WE BELIEVE THAT
UNDER LAW WE ARE OBLIGATED TO
CONTINUE PUTTING MONEY INTO THE
RAINY DAY FUND.
SO THAT IT WILL REACH FIFTEEN
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS AT
THE END OF THIS YEAR UP FROM
THIRTEEN POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS.
AND BY THE END OF THE FORECAST
PERIOD IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE IT WILL APPROACH TWENTY
BILLION DOLLARS AND THAT WILL BE
A REAL IMPORTANT BUFFER IN THE
YEARS AHEAD.
THE FINAL THING THAT THIS BUDGET
DOES ON THE WERE ON THE PHYSICAL
RESILIENCY FRONT IS MAKE IT BIG
PAY DOWN.
OUR RETIREE LIABILITIES AS ALL
OF YOU KNOW WE HAVE A LARGE
UNFUNDED LIABILITY.
AND THE GOVERNOR WANTS TO MAKE A
PRIORITY TO ADDRESS THAT NOT
SIMPLY BECAUSE IT'S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO --
NOT SIMPLY BECAUSE IT HELPS US
MEET OUR PROMISES TO OUR
RETIREES BUT ALSO BECAUSE OF
RESULTS IN BIG SAVINGS DOWN THE
ROAD.
THE THREE BILLION DOLLARS
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT TO THE
CALPERS SYSTEM THAT WE ARE
PROPOSING WILL RESULT IN SEVEN
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
SAVINGS OVER THE NEXT THIRTY
YEARS.
THE ONE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS AND CAL STAR IS PAYMENTS
THAT WE'RE PROPOSING ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE.
COMBINED WITH THE PROJECTED ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS OVER
THE FORECAST PERIOD WILL RESULT
IN SEVEN POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS IN SAVINGS OVER THE NEXT
THIRTY YEARS.
WE ALSO PROPOSE CONTINUING WITH
PROPOSITION TWO PAYMENTS TO PRE
FUND A RETIREE HEALTH CARE
LIABILITY AND TO MAKE PAYMENTS
ON THE LOAN FROM OUR SPECIAL
FUNDS THAT WAS USED TO MAKE A
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT TO CALPERS.
TWO YEARS AGO.
IN ALL OF THESE AS WE WERE AS WE
KNOW WE'RE RELYING ON
PROJECTIONS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
UPDATE THESE NUMBERS THROUGH MAY
AND JUNE AND IN THE MONTHS TO
COME.
WHEN WE GET TO THE IMPORTANT
BOARD SPENDING PRIORITIES THAT
THE CHAIR TALKED ABOUT --
I WANT TO BEGIN AT THE BEGINNING
WITH EARLY CHILDHOOD WHICH IS
SUCH A PRIORITY FOR THE GOVERNOR
AND I KNOW FOR SO MANY OF YOU.
THIS BUDGET BEGINS WITH A
LOOKING FOR UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL
FOR ALL ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIA --
FOUR YEAR OLDS ON AN ELIGIBLE
MEANS FAMILIES THAT ARE FROM 85%
OR BELOW A MEDIAN INCOME.
THIS BUDGET PROPOSES A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE IN GENERAL FUND
FUNDING THAT'S OUTSIDE OF
PROPOSITION. NINETY EIGHT TO ADD
ADDITIONAL SLOTS.
AND WE HOPE TO GET OUT OVER THE
NEXT THREE YEARS TO TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND SLOTS SO THAT WE CAN
ACHIEVE THAT TARGET AND
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL. FOR ALL
ELIGIBLE FOUR YEAR OLDS WERE
ALSO WE ALSO PROPOSED
ELIMINATING THE REQUIREMENT THAT
APPEAR IN IS WORKING OR IN
SCHOOL IN ORDER FOR THEIR
OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE CHILD. TO BE
ABLE TO ACCESS THIS PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT MORE THAN 20%
OF DISTRICTS DO NOT OFFER FULLY
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN AND WE
KNOW THAT'S A SPENDING ISSUE BUT
THAT'S ALSO A CAPACITY AND
FACILITY ISSUE.
SO THIS BUDGET PROPOSES AGAIN
ONE TIME SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
NINE DOLLARS TO INCREASE
CAPACITY AND RETROFIT SOME OF
OUR CLASSROOMS IN OUR SCHOOL SO
THAT THEIR ADOPTABLE FOR FULL
DAY KINDERGARTEN.
AND MORE FAMILIES CAN SEND THEIR
KIDS.
HE ALSO PROPOSED A SIMILAR
INVESTMENT FOR FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN CHILD CARE
FACILITIES AND THAT ALSO
IMPROVES TRAINING UP THE CHILD
CARE WORK FORCE BECAUSE WITHOUT
CHILD CARE IS A BIG REASON WHY
FAMILIES ARE FEELING SUCH A
SQUEEZE IN THIS ECONOMY.
AND WE WANT TO GET STARTED ON
THE PATH TO ADDRESS THAT WE ALSO
INCLUDE --
FOR THIS CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY WHERE MANY STUDENTS
WHO ARE ALSO PERRANCE ATTENDS UP
TO TWO HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS WHICH GOES FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BUT A LOT
OF THAT MONEY CAN ALSO GO TO
CHILD CARE --
FOR FACILITIES AND OTHER CHILD
CARE PROGRAMS.
AND FINALLY WITH ALL OF THESE
THE GUYS MENTION THE GOVERNOR
HAS LAID OUT A BOLD AGENDA BUT
WE KNOW THAT IT CAN ONLY BE
ACHIEVED AND STOPS.
SO WE'RE PROPOSING TEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO REALLY GET UNDER THE
HOOD AND SEE WHAT IT WOULD TAKE
TO ACHIEVE UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL
FOR ALL FAMILIES NOT JUST
ELIGIBLE.
UNIVERSAL CHILD CARE --
FULL DAY TO ACHIEVE THOSE SO WE
HOPE THAT THAT TEN MILLION
DOLLAR STUDY WILL RESULT IN
ROBUST REVENUE OPTIONS --
PROGRAM OPTIONS AND THINGS THAT
WE CAN PURSUE.
IN THE MONTHS AND YEARS DOWN THE
ROAD.
I ALSO WANT TO TALK ABOUT CAL
WORKS BECAUSE THIS IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST ONGOING SPENDING
COMMITMENTS AND THIS BUDGET --
WE PROPOSE INCREASING UP 250% OF
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL THE
MAXIMUM GRANT THAT MEANS FOR A
FAMILY OF THREE IN WHICH ALL
THREE INDIVIDUALS ARE RECEIVING
ASSISTANCE.
THAT GRANT WOULD GO TO EIGHT
HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT DOLLARS --
AND THAT'S A BIG COMMITMENT AS I
MENTIONED IN THIS BUDGET YEAR
WERE FORECASTING THREE HUNDRED
FORTY SEVEN POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND.
THAT WILL GROW TO NEARLY HALF A
BILLION DOLLARS IN YEARS TO COME.
BUT WE THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT AND THE GOVERNOR
POINTED TO DIE IN HIS PRESS
CONFERENCE HOW THIS IS A CORE
COMMITMENT OF HIS ADMINISTRATION
AND A CORE RESPONSIBILITY OF
GOVERNMENT.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT WE'RE
INCREASING IT 250% OF FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL IN OUR PROPOSAL
BUT WE ALSO ANTICIPATE FURTHER
GROWTH THROUGH THE STRUCTURE OF
REALIGNMENT AND THE CHILD
POVERTY SUB ACCOUNT.
SO THAT GRANT WILL CONTINUE TO
GROW IN THE YEARS TO COME.
WE ALSO PROPOSE MORE MONEY FOR
LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES
NINETEEN POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUNDS.
AND THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE COUNTIES
THAT ARE LOWER INCOME --
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY CAN
ENFORCE CHILD SUPPORT LAWS AND
REGULATIONS AND THAT SHOULD
RESULT IN HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL
PAYMENTS.
THAT WILL GO DIRECTLY TO CARE
IT'S OFTEN OUR MOST LOW INCOME
NEEDIEST KIDS --
AND THEN FINALLY I MADE A POINT
ABOUT STUDENT PARENTS --
THIS A BIG PRIORITY OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION SCHOOL WORK WITH
CHILD CARE AND IF WE ALLOW THE
STUDENT PARENTS TO ACCESS
EDUCATION IT'S GOOD FOR THEM
IT'S GOOD FOR THEIR FUTURE
EARNING POTENTIAL IT'S GOOD FOR
THEIR KIDS THEIR ROLE MODELS FOR
THEIR KIDS AND IT'S GOOD FOR ALL
OF US. TO THIS BUDGET PROPOSES A
BIG ON GOING COMMITMENT OF A
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS TO INCREASE THE
CAL GRANT A AND B. LEVEL UP TO
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS AND CAL
GRANT SEA LEVEL UP TO FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS. TO MAKE SURE
THAT STUDENT PARENTS CAN ACCESS
THIS FUNDING SO THIS INCREASES%
ARE SPECIFICALLY FOR THAT
POPULATION IT ALSO INCREASES BY
NINE POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
THE COMPETITIVE AWARDS UNDER THE
CAL GRANT PROGRAM BECAUSE AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW --
FOR A NUMBER OF HISTORICAL
REASONS CAL GRANTS ARE OFTEN --
ELIGIBLE CERTAIN CATEGORIES ONLY
FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE RECENTLY
GRADUATED FROM HIGH SCHOOL AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN TAUGHT IN THE WORK
FORCE.
RAISING THEIR KIDS HAVE MORE OF
A CHANCE TO GET BACK INTO SCHOOL
AND GET THE HELP THAT THEY NEED.
ONE OTHER PRIORITYON THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD SIDE IS FOR SCREENINGS
AND HOME BASE AT THIS BUDGET
INCLUDES --
SEVERAL HUNDRED MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WHEN YOU TAKE BUT
GENERAL FUND AND FEDERAL FUNDS
TO INCLUDE AT INCLUDE ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCE IN OTHER
TRAUMA SCREENINGS --
FOR BOTH CHILDREN AND ADULTS IN
THE MEDICAL PROGRAMS AS WELL AS
DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENINGS AT NINE
EIGHTEEN AND THIRTY MONTHS SOME
OF THE SCREENS ARE ALREADY
COVERED BUT THEY'RE NOT
HAPPENING AT THE RATES THAT WE
WOULD ONCE WERE HOPING BY
PUTTING MORE MONEY AND WE CAN
MAKE SURE THAT MORE.
PEOPLE GET THE SCREENINGS THEY
NEED AND THEN WHEN THEY ARE
GETTING SCREENING THEY CAN GET
REFER TO THE SERVICES THAT
THEY'RE ALREADY ENTITLED TO
UNDER THE MEDI CAL PROGRAM.
WE ALSO IMPROVE MONEY FOR HOME
VISITING WHICH IS A PROVEN WAY
TO MAKE SURE THAT MOTHERS
ESPECIALLY NEW MOTHERS AND
FATHERS AND FAMILIES.
UNDERSTAND THE BEST PRACTICES IN
TERMS OF RAY START IN LIFE ON
THAT SPOT FOR ELIGIBLE CAL WORKS
FAMILIES AS WELL AS FOR OTHER
FAMILIES.
AND WE ALSO INCLUDE SEVEN AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
BLACK INFANT HEALTH PROGRAM
WHICH IS A CRITICAL PROGRAM TO
REDUCE INEQUITIES IN BIRTH
WEIGHTS AND OTHER METRICS THAT
MAKES SUCH A DIFFERENCE FOR
HEALTH SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT PROGRAM HAS THE FUNDING.
THAT IT MEETS THE CHAIRED
MATCHING PAID FAMILY LEAVE --
WE SET A GOAL OF MAKING SURE
THAT EVERY CHILD BORN HAS UP TO
SIX MONTHS OF CARE FROM PARENTS
AND OR OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE A LOT
OF STEPS THAT WE NEED TO TAKE IN
TERMS OF HOW WE GET FROM HERE TO
THERE AND HOW TO MAKE THAT
PROPOSAL REALITY.
SO WE'RE PUTTING TOGETHER A TASK
FORCE THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER
WITH WITH YOU BUT IT IS A
COMMITMENT OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION. TWO OTHER POINTS
I WANT TO MENTION ON EARLY
CHILDHOOD ONE IS A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR SEAT GRANT TO PARTNER
WITH FIRST FIVE AND OTHER LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS TO ESTABLISH CHILD
SAVINGS ACCOUNTS FOR INCOMING
KINDERGARTNERS.
WE KNOW FROM RESEARCH THAT EVEN
A SMALL DEPOSIT ON BEHALF OF A
CHILD CAN GROW OVER TIME IT
HELPS CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
BUILD ASSETS.
AND IT PUTS FAMILIES IN A
COLLEGE GOING MINDSET SO WE WANT
TO GET THAT PROGRAM STARTED IT'S
SOMETHING WE'VE SEEN IN SAN
FRANCISCO IT'S SOMETHING WE'VE
SEEN IN THE EAST BAY.
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE HOPE
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE ON MORE OF
A STATEWIDE LEVEL WORKING WITH
LOCAL WORK ORGANIZATIONS.
OF CHAIRED ALSO MENTION THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT --
WHICH WERE PROPOSING TO RENAME
THE WORKING FAMILIES TAX CREDIT --
BUT WHATEVER YOU WANT TO CALL IT --
RIGHT NOW IT'S AT FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN SPENDING
WE'RE PROPOSING INCREASING THIS
PROGRAM TO ONE BILLION DOLLARS
IN SPENDING.
AND THIS WOULD INCREASE
ELIGIBILITY FOR FAMILY MMHM WAGE
MAKING SURE THAT WORKING FAMILY
WITH A HEAD OF HOUSEHOLD AT THAT
WAGE LEVEL CAN STILL ACCESS TO
CREDIT.
NOW RIGHT NOW THE CREDIT IS
TARGETED IN THE LOWEST INCOME
FAMILIES WHICH IS GREAT AND
THAT'S HOW THE ADMINISTRATION
DESIGNED IT BUT WE ALSO WANT TO
INCREASE SOME OF THE TAX REFUNDS
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE.
BETWEEN TEN THOUSAND AND TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS ARE UP TO
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS SO WE
ALSO PROVIDE A MORE GENEROUS
CREDIT FOR THOSE FAMILIES AND
FINALLY RECOGNIZING THE SPECIAL
CHALLENGES OF FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN AND THE COST WE'VE GOT
THEIR UNDER.
WE'RE PROPOSING A FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLAR ADDITIONAL TAX CREDIT ON
TOP OF EVERYTHING I'VE DESCRIBED
FOR FAMILIES WITH KIDS UNDER THE
AGE OF SIX SO WE THINK THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT POLICY WERE
POPERY PROPOSING TO PAY FOR IT
TO WRITE TAX CONFORMITY PACKAGE.
OFTEN WHEN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PASSES A TAX REFORM
STATES CHOOSE TO CONFORM FOR
SIMPLICITY REASONS AND FOR
REASONS THAT ARE GOOD POLICY --
AND WAYS ---THAT CHANGE THE TAX CODE FOR
CALIFORNIA STATE TAXPAYERS SO
WE'RE PROPOSING A COUPLE CHANGES --
IN TERMS OF LIMITING LOSSES THAT
BUSINESS OWNERS CAN TAKE AGAINST
OTHER INCOME.
AS WELL SOME CHANGES THAT WILL
ACTUALLY DEPRIVED THE STATE OF
REVENUE BUT WE THINK ARE
IMPORTANT REVENUE CHANGES SUCH
AS SIMPLIFYING ACCOUNTING RULES
FOR SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS.
HIGH AT TWO CONFORMING ON THESE
ACHIEVING A BETTER LIFE
EXPERIENCE ACCOUNTS FOR PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AND THEIR
FAMILIES SO THAT THEY CAN SAY
FOR THEIR EXPENSES.
AND CONFORMING WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ON THESE
OPPORTUNITIES ZONES WHICH I KNOW
MANY OF YOU WOULD HAVE HEARD
ABOUT. TO INCREASE INVESTMENT IN
THOSE AREAS.
I WANT TO MOVE ON NOW TO K. --
TWELVE WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING IN
THIS BUDGET UNDER PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT IS THE HIGHEST EVER
LEVEL OF FUNDING FOR K. TWELVE
OR AYE RATHER I SHOULD SAY K.
FOURTEEN SCHOOLS.
IT'S EIGHTY POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS NINETY SEVEN POINT NINE
BILLION DOLLARS IN THE LAST YEAR%
AND IT'S UP FROM FORTY SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS AT THE START OF
THIS DECADE WHICH WAS THE
RECESSIONARY WELL.
SO WHEN YOU GO FROM THAT FORTY
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS UP TO THE
EIGHTY POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLAR LEVEL THAT WE ARE
PROPOSING THAT'S ABOUT FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLAR ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS ON A PER PUPIL BASIS.
ON AND IN THIS BUDGET COMPARED
TO JUST LAST YEAR THAT TWO POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR INCREASE
INCLUDE INCLUDES TWO BILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA.
ON AND ALSO INCLUDES AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
SPECIAL EDUCATION IS AN AREA
WHERE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
COMMITTED TO COVERING A BIG
SHARE.
AND MOST RECENTLY --
NAY 2240% OF COVERING SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING OR THAT WAS
THE GOAL THAT THE IS THAT
ESTABLISHED THE STILL AT ABOUT
10% SO RIGHT NOW IT'S REALLY
INCUMBENT ON THE STATE.
AS MUCH AS WE MIGHT WISH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WOULD HELP US
OUT. TO MAKE SURE THAT SPECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS ARE GETTING
THE RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED.
I WANT TO MAKE ONE COMMENT IN
ADDITION AND THIS IS OUTSIDE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT BUT N
ADDITION TO THE BUDGET
RESILIENCY PAYMENTS THAT I
DESCRIBED WE ARE ALSO PROPOSING.
AN ENTIRELY SEPARATE THREE
BILLION DOLLAR PAYMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT SYSTEM ON BEHALF OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS --
THAT WE PROJECT WILL SAVE
SCHOOLS THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS BUDGET
YEAR. THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE FOLLOWING
BUDGET YEAR AND THEN HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN THE YEARS
AFTER THAT WE THINK THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE KNOW
EVEN WITH THESE BIG INCREASES.
OUR SCHOOLS ARE UNDER A LOT OF
PRESSURE --
THEIR PENSION PAYMENTS HAVE BEEN
RISING FOR THE RETIRED TEETH FOR
THEIR ACTIVE AND RETIRED
TEACHERS TO ABOUT --
NOT THIS YEAR BUT THE YEAR AFTER
THIS BUDGET YEAR IT 1% PAYROLL
WE KNOW THAT'S A LOT AND WE
THINK THIS THREE BILLION DOLLARS
WILL MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE IN
HELPING THEM.
MANAGE THOSE COSTS. THREE OTHER
FINAL POINTS I WANT TO MAKE ON
K. TWELVE FIRST IS THAT THE
GOVERNOR CAN TUNING ON A
PRIORITY THAT HE MENTIONED IN
HIS CAMPAIGN.
IS COMMITTING TEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO A LONGITUDINAL DATA --
PROGRAM AND THIS AGAIN IS THE
FIRST STEP IT WILL TAKE A COUPLE
OF YEARS TO IMPLEMENT.
BUT IT'S DESIGNED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE KNOW HOW OUR KIDS ARE
DOING FROM CRADLE ALL THE WAY
THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL THROUGH POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION AND CAREER
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
DELIVERING ON WHAT.
WE'RE PROMISING THEM AND ALSO TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHAT THEY'RE
LEARNING IN SCHOOL AND HOW WE'RE
EDUCATING OUR STUDENTS IS
ALIGNED WITH THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA'S WORK FORCE. TO
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE HOPE TO
WORK WITH YOU ON AND DEVELOPING
THAT SYSTEM AND MAKING SURE IT'S
SERVING OUR STUDENTS.
A SECOND POINT IN THIS BUDGET IS
WE'RE PROPOSING TO MAKE SOME
AMENDMENTS TO THE CERTIFICATION
PROCESS FOR PROPOSITION --
NINETY EIGHT AND WE'RE PROPOSING
TO PROVIDE MORE CERTAINTY IN
PRIOR YEARS AND A LITTLE MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN FUTURE YEARS AND
I'M HAPPY TO GO INTO SOME DETAIL
ABOUT THAT IF ANYONE HAS ANY
QUESTIONS.
THE FINAL POINT THAT ONE THING
THAT THE GOVERNOR HEARD A LOT
BOTH IN HIS CAMPAIGN AND DURING
THE TRANSITION PERIOD IS UNDER
PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE IT WAS A
NINE BILLION DOLLAR BOND SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS FOR OUR SCHOOLS.
AND TWO BILLION DOLLARS FOR OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THERE IS
SOME SENSE THAT THAT MONEY IS
NOT GETTING OUT THE DOOR TO
ACTUALLY FIND SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION AS QUICKLY AS IT
SHOULD.
US WE'RE PROPOSING BOND FINDING
WE'RE PROJECTING ONE AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS GOING OUT THE
DOOR THIS YEAR.
THAT'S OVER A 100% INCREASE TO
THE ABOUT SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS.
THAT WENT OUT THE DOOR IN EACH
OF THE LAST TWO YEARS PUBLIC
SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION WHICH HELPS
US EVALUATE THESE PROPOSALS. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE SCHOOL
FACILITY CONSTRUCTION BONDS CAN
GET I CAN GET FUNDED AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE.
I WANT TO MOVE ON TO HIGHER
EDUCATION THIS IS A PRIORITY OF
THE GOVERNOR --
FOR THE LAST EIGHT YEARS HE SAT
BOTH ON THE UC BOARD OF REGIONS
AND THE CAL STATE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES --
AND HE'S PROPOSING BIG --
ONGOING INCREASES WHICH ARE THE
MOST IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT
PROVIDES STABILITY AND
PREDICTABILITY OVERTIME FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND FOR
CSU. FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HE'S PROPOSING A SIX
POINT 9% INCREASE THAT'S WELL
ABOVE THE 3% OR 4% INCREASES
THAT WE'VE SEEN IN RECENT YEARS --
THAT'S TWO HUNDRED FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE INCLUDE THE
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
RESIDENCY SLOTS.
AND IN ADDITION IN ONE TIME
FUNDING HE'S PROPOSING A HUNDRED
FIFTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS THIS
FUNDING WILL G THROUGH TOWARD A
VARIETY OF PURPOSES ABLE
INCREASE ENROLLMENT.
WERE ASKING IS A CONDITION OF
FUNDING THAT THE UC FREEZE
TUITION FOR STUDENTS --
AND WE'RE ALSO ASKING THEM TO
IMPROVE DEGREE COMPLETION THIS
FUNDING ALSO GOES FROM MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS FOR IMMIGRATION
ASSISTANCE AND FOR HUNGER AND
HOUSING INITIATIVES.
IT ALSO INCLUDES ONE MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING FOR THE UC
DAVIS FIREARMS VIOLENCE RESEARCH
CENTER ON AS MANY OF YOU KNOW AT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT --
THERE'S A LOT OF CONTROVERSY
AROUND FUNDING --
RESEARCH INTO VIOLENCE REDUCTION
A NOT INSIGNIFICANT FUNDING CAN
CONTINUE TO FLOW TO THE CENTER
FOR THE IMPORTANT WORK THAT THEY
DO. FOR CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY WILL PROVOKE WE
PROPOSE AN EVEN BIGGER INCREASE
OF 8% AND THAT'S NOT AN ACCIDENT --
WANTED AT LEAST AT THE GOVERNOR
HAS IS THIS IS A SYSTEM THAT
SERVES YOU KNOW OVER FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE IT'S THE
BACKBONE IN TERMS OF OUR
TEACHERS AND OUR NURSES AND SO
MANY OF OUR OTHER PROFESSIONALS.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
GETS THE SUPPORT THAT IT NEEDS
TO THAT INCLUDES THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING
FUNDING.
AND IN ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED
FORTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME FUNDING FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE INCLUDING CHILD CARE.
THAT INCLUDES SEVEN THOUSAND NEW
SLOTS THAT'S A 2% GROWTH IN
ENROLLMENT WERE ALSO ASKING THEM
FOR TUITION FREEZE AND THEY HAVE
THIS GRADUATION TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE INITIATIVE TO INCREASE
GRADUATION RATES --
AND MAKING SURE THEY GET WHERE
THEY NEED TO BE AND WE'RE
PROPOSING TO FURTHER FIND THOSE
EFFORTS.
ALSO EFFORTS AS WITH YOU SEE ON
IMMIGRATION HUNGER AND HOUSING
AND ONE OTHER AGAIN SMALLER
COMPARED TO THE OTHER NUMBERS
THAT OF DESCRIBING BUT NOT
INSIGNIFICANT A TWO MILLION
DOLLAR PLANNING GRANT.
OFFER AT CSU POSSIBLE NEW CAMPUS
IN SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND
STOCKTON.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
KNOW WILL TAKE SEVERAL YEARS IN
TERMS OF THINKING WHERE THAT CAN
BE SHOULD BE EXACTLY AND HOW IT
SHOULD BE DESIGNED.
BUT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
IMPORTANT PRIORITY BECAUSE IF WE
ARE HAVING PROJECTING A
SHORTFALL IN THE COLLEGE
GRADUATES COMPARED TO WHAT OUR
ECONOMY NEEDS WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE TO EXPAND CAPACITY BOTH AT
EXISTING CAMPUSES BUT ALSO MAKE
SURE.
THAT STUDENTS AND COMMUNITIES
WHERE THEY MIGHT NOT BE CLOSE TO
UC AND CSU HAVE ADDITIONAL
OPTIONS.
FINALLY IN THE CSU BUDGET WE
INCLUDE A QUARTER MILLION
DOLLARS FOR PROJECT REBOUND
WHICH IS AN INITIATIVE FOR
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS WERE NOW STUDENTS TO
GET THE SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
THAT THEY NEED.
FINALLY ON COMEY CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE PROPOSE
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS TO MAKE
THE SECOND YEAR OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FREE FOR TUITION WISE
FOR FULL YEAR FULL TIME STUDENTS.
WE INCLUDE A BIG COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT UNDER PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT WE PROPOSED TO
REVISE THE STUDENT CENTERED
FUNDING FORMULA AND AGAIN AS
WITH PROP NINETY EIGHT
CERTIFICATION I'M HAPPY TO TALK
ABOUT ANY OF THE DETAILS IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
AND WE ALSO PROPOSE UNDER
PROPOSITION FOR MILLION DOLLARS
IN ADDITIONAL FUND FINDING THAT
WOULD PROJECT WILL GO OUT THE
DOOR AND THAT'S FUNDING TWENTY
SEVEN YOU ARE ON GOING PROJECTS.
WE ALSO INCLUDE INCLUDE A
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY THIS IS
FOR SUMMER MEALS FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS TO INTRODUCE THEM TO
THEIR LOCAL LIBRARY.
AGAIN NOT A SPEC NUMBER COMPARED
TO THE OTHER NUMBERS BUT REALLY
IMPORTANT.
INCLUDE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
STUDENT LOAN AWARENESS BECAUSE
EVEN AS WERE FOCUSED ON
AFFORDABILITY FOR MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO REALLY CARE ARE
STRUGGLING WITH THE DATA THAT
THEY HAVE ALREADY THEY'VE
ALREADY ACCUMULATED IT'S AN
ALBATROSS AROUND THEIR NECK.
AND THEY NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE FULLY AWARE OF ALL THE
REPAYMENT PLANS AND OPTIONS THAT
THEY CAN AVAIL THEMSELVES OF AND
FINALLY WE'RE PROPOSING TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR EDUCATIONAL
INNOVATION.
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN AND INLAND
EMPIRE REGION'S.
SO THAT'S ALL WE'VE GOT AN
EDUCATION LET ME MOVE ON TO
HEALTHCARE.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS THREE
BROAD GOALS WHEN IT COMES TO
HEALTHCARE IT'S IMPROVING ACCESS
REDUCING COSTS AND IMPROVING
QUALITY AND WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING
TO ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS.
IS FINDING A WAY FOR ALL THESE
GOALS TO FIT TOGETHER.
CON IS VERY FIRST DAY IN OFFICE
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED THAT A BIG
EVER SIGNED A BIG EXECUTIVE
ORDER IN TERMS OF PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS HOW MEDI CAL NEGOTIATES
FOR THEM.
ALSO STRENGTHENING THE
CALIFORNIA PHARMACEUTICAL
COLLABORATIVE AND WE EXPECT THAT
IN FUTURE YEARS THIS COULD SAVE
THE STATE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS.
AS THE STATE MOVES TOWARD BULK
PURCHASING AND AS MEDI CAL IN
PARTICULAR TRANSFORMS FROM
MEDICAL MANAGED CARE NEGOTIATION
TO AN OVERALL FEE FOR SERVICE
BENEFIT.
IN OUR BUDGET HOWEVER WE
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU DETAILS OF
THIS ARE BEING WORKED OUT AND
WE'RE NOT PROJECTING ANY SAVINGS
UNTIL THE OUT YEAR IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO THAT'S WHEN WE
BELIEVE.
THAT THE SAVINGS WILL ACTUALLY
KICK IN FOR OUR STATE REINSTATE
THE MANDATE THAT HAS LAPSED AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL --
FOR THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT AND
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THIS IS WHAT KEEPS THE UNINSURED
RATE LOW --
PROJECTIONS HAVE SUGGESTED THAT
IF WE DO NOT TAKE THE STATUS OF
THE NUMBER OF UNINSURED IN THE
STATE CAN INCREASED BY ALMOST A
MILLION PEOPLE --
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE TED THAT
THAT PENALTY CAN KEEP OUR
HISTORICALLY LOW UNINSURED RATE
WHERE IT IS --
AND ANY SO ANY --
PENALTY REVENUE THAT COMES FROM
THAT NEW MANDATE WE WILL USE
THAT TO PUT RIGHT BACK INTO THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM FOR INCREASED
SUBSIDIES FOR FAMILIES BETWEEN
210050%.
AND 4100% OF THE POVERTY LEVEL
AS WELL AS FOR THE FIRST TIME
PROVIDE HEALTHCARE INSURANCE
SUBSIDIES FOR FAMILIES BETWEEN
4100% AND 6100% OF THE POVERTY
LEVEL.
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
FAMILIES THAT ARE PURCHASING.
INSURANCE ON THE EXCHANGES WE
ALSO HAVE OUR MEDI CAL PROGRAM
WHICH IS PROJECTED SERVE OVER
THIRTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
PEOPLE IN THIS YEAR.
IT'S A HUNDRED POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM THAT'S
TWENTY TWO POINT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS IN OUR GENERAL FUND AND
WE MAKE A NUMBER OF ADJUSTMENTS
HERE --
UNDER PROP FIFTY SIX WERE
DEVOTING MORE OF THAT MONEY TO
RATE INCREASES FOR PROVIDERS
THAT MORE FOR MEDI CAL PATIENTS
CAN ACTUALLY GET A CHANCE TO SEE
THE PROVIDERS WHOM THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE TO SEE --
WE'RE FORECASTING SOME
MODERATION IN THE GROWTH OF
MEDICARE HOW OUR CASE LOAD HAS
MODERATED SOME OF OUR COSTS
DECLINED --
COMPARED TO WHAT WE PROJECTED --
AND ALSO --
THERE WERE SOME RECONCILIATIONS
INTER THE TIMING OF THE HOSPITAL
QUALITY INSURANCE FEE AND THAT
ACCOUNTS GOING BACK TO THE VERY
BEGINNING FOR PART OF THAT
NATURE SURPLUS OF TWENTY ONE AND
A HALF BILLION DOLLARS THAT
WE'RE PROJECTING FOR THIS YEAR.
ONE OTHER MAJOR POINT ABOUT MEDI
CAL WHICH THE GOVERNOR NOW
ANNOUNCED JUST AS HE WAS COMING
INTO OFFICE IS THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING AN EXPANSION OF FULL
SCOPE COVERAGE TO UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS BETWEEN THE AGES OF
NINETEEN ALL THE WAY UP TO AGE --
TWENTY SIX AS YOU ALL KNOW WE
ALREADY HAVE A SIMILAR PROGRAM
FOR ON DOCUMENTING RESIDENTS
BETWEEN BIRTH AND AGE EIGHTEEN
SO THIS WOULD EXTEND THAT
THROUGH AGE.
TWENTY FIVE WERE PROJECTING ONE
HUNDRED NINETY SIX POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
FOR THAT PROGRAM HOWEVER BECAUSE
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOW INSURED UNDER
THAT PROGRAMS WILL NOT NEED TO
ACCESS AS MANY COUNTY MEDICAL
SERVICES NOW THAT THEY HAVE FULL
SCOPE HEALTH COVERAGE.
WERE ACTUALLY PROJECTING SOME
SAVINGS AT THE COUNTY LEVEL THAT
WILL FLOW BACK INTO THE GENERAL
FUND FROM THE COUNTY INDIGENT
HEALTH PROGRAM SOMEONE UNITED
ALL OUT FOR THE FIRST YEAR OF
THIS PROGRAM IT SHOULD BE ABOUT
A HUNDRED THIRTY THREE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS COST. TO
THE GENERAL FUND. FOR ALSO
MAKING A NUMBER OF JAIL
ADJUSTMENTS ON MENTAL HEALTH --
WE'RE PROPOSING FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO INCREASE THE SUPPLY
PROVIDERS BECAUSE WE KNOW
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT COMES TO
MENTAL HEALTH AS WELL AS PRIMARY
CARE THE PROVIDER SHORTAGE IS A
PROBLEM THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO DEAL WITH ON AN
ONGOING BASIS.
AND WE'RE ASKING NONPROFIT AND
OTHER PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS TO
MATCH SOME THIS FUNDING TO
FURTHER ADDRESS THIS ISSUE WE'RE
PROPOSING TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN NEW FNDING FOR EARLY
PSYCHOSIS RESEARCH AND TREATMENT
SO THAT WE CAN INTERVENE.
AS EARLY AS POSSIBLE --
WERE WERE GLAD THAT THAT TO
BILLION DOLLAR FUNDING FOR NO
PLACE LIKE HOME WAS APPROVED
LAST NOVEMBER AND WE'RE HOPING
TO ALSO GET THOSE FUNDS FLOWING
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
AND THAT'S FUNDING FOR SERVICES
PARTICULARLY FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS AND
MAKING SURE THAT THEY CAN GET
THE HOUSING SUPPORT THAT THEY
NEED -- AND
FINALLY THROUGH SOME CHANGES TEN
NINE CHECKING THAT ABOUT SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS WILL BE THEIR
ADDITIONALLY FOR COUNTIES TO PUT
INTO THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS.
AND LET ME TALK ABOUT THOSE AYE
HSS CHANGES RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
LIKE CAL WORKS THIS IS A BIG
ONGOING COMMITMENT FROM OUR
OVERALL SURPLUS THAT WILL BE
THAT WE'RE FORECASTING INTO THE
YEARS TO COME.
I HSS SERVES OVER HALF A MILLION
PEOPLE IN THE STATE AND HELPS
THEM WITH DOMESTIC AND PERSONAL
CARE SERVICES THAT THEY CANNOT
PERFORM ADEQUATELY ON THEIR OWN.
AND WE'RE PROPOSING TO BIG --
CHANGES THE FIRST IS A REVISION
TO THE COUNTY MAINTENANCE OF
EFFORT --
THAT WAS AGREED UPON IN --
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE UNDERSTAND
THAT COUNTIES ARE FACING GROWING
COST COMPARED TO WHAT WAS
INITIALLY PROJECTED INCLUDING
FOR SOME INCREASES IN THE
MINIMUM WAGE AS WELL AS OTHER
POLICY CHANGES AT BOTH THE STATE.
AND THE FEDERAL LEVEL SO WE'RE
PROPOSING TO REDUCE THAT AMMO WE
FOR THE CURRENT YEAR --
AND THEN CHANGE THE INFLATION
FACTOR 24% IN COMING YEARS ON
AND THEN AS A RESULT OF THAT
REDUCED AND WE COUNTIES CAN
REDIRECT SOME THAT FUNDING.
BACK TO COUNTY INDIGENT HEALTH
AND MENTAL HEALTH AS I WAS
DISCUSSING --
SAID THIS IS A BIG COST --
WE'RE PROJECTING IN THE CURRENT
YEAR TWO HUNDRED FORTY ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS AND THAT
WILL RISE TO FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS.
IN THE OUT YEARS.
THE SECOND THING THAT WERE DUE
IN PERCENT CUT TO AYE HSS
SERVICE HOURS THAT WAS DESIGNED
TO GOING TO PLACE WITH THE
EXPIRATION OF THE MANAGED CARE
ORGANIZATION TAX ALSO KNOWN AS
THE MCO TAX.
ON THE SET TO TAKE A FACT AND BY
RESTORING THAT FUNDING WE'RE
PROJECTING THREE HUNDRED FORTY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
CURRENT BUDGET YEAR.
RISING TO OVER FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
YEAR SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE OUT
YEARS BOTH THESE PROGRAMS YOU'RE
LOOKING AT MORE THAN FOUR
HUNDRED MILLIONDOLLARS IN EACH
OF THEM.
BUT WE THINK THAT IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE NUMBER ONE
THIS IS A CORE RESPONSIBILITY OF
THE STATE --
WHEN WE'RE REALIGNING
RESPONSIBILITIES WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE FUNDING IS THERE
TO PAY FOR THEM AND SECOND MANY
OF YOU HAVE SERVED AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT YOU UNDERSTAND THE
REVENUE PRESSURES THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS COUNTIES?
SPACE AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HAVE THE FREEDOM AND
THEY HAVE THE FUNDS TO DO ALL
THE OTHER THINGS THAT THEY NEED
TO DO.
SO WE THINK THIS IS A BETTER
AGREEMENT AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THE STATE CAN AND SHOULD PICK
THIS UP FROM THE GENERAL FUND.
SO ON THAT AND CO TAX --
IT'S PROJECTED TO EXPIRE THIS
SUMMER --
AND I KNOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE
QUESTIONS ABOUT IT --
IN THINKING ABOUT DESCRIBING HOW
THIS TAX FUNCTIONS I ALWAYS GO
BACK -- TO
QUOTATION --
THAT GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN --
SAID WHEN YOU.
VERY FEW PEOPLE UNDERSTAND IT SO
I'M NOT GOING TO TRY TO EXPLAIN
IT TO YOU BECAUSE I COULDN'T
EXPLAIN IT TO YOU IF I WANTED --
TO BUT THE TRUTH IS A LONG STORY
SHORT THIS IS A TAX --
NETWORKS WERE NUMBER MECHANISMS
THAT DRAWS DOWN ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL DOLLARS ANSWER THE
QUESTION WE'VE RECEIVED A NOTICE
WILL BE PART OF A DISCUSSION.
ON WHY HAVE WE NOT INCLUDED THIS
IN OUR JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL
AND I THINK THE REASON IS TWO
FOLD FIRST OF ALL WE WERE
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER IN
NOVEMBER AND DECEMBER.
ON IT SO WE WERE THINKING ABOUT
WHAT CAN WE COUNT ON WHEN IT
COMES TO WHAT'S IN OUR BUDGET
AND WHAT THE REVENUES ARE.
AND SECOND WE BELIEVE THAT THERE
WILL BE CONTINUED FEDERAL
UNCERTAINTY IN TERMS OF
OBVIOUSLY THE SHUT DOWN IS GOING
ON BUT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO HAS TWO BIG WAIVERS THAT
ARE COMING UP FOR RENEGOTIATION
THE NEXT YEAR.
THE ELEVEN FIFTEEN WAIVER ON
MEDI CAL FOR A MEDICAID PROGRAM
THE CURRENT VALUE OF THAT IS
OVER SIX BILLION DOLLARS OVER
FIVE YEARS.
AND WE ALSO HAVE IN NINETEEN
FIFTEEN BE WAIVER ON BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND THAT SEVERAL BILLION
DOLLARS AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE YOU KNOW IT'S A TOP
PRIORITY OF OURS. TO GET THOSE
WAIVERS RENEGOTIATED AND MAKE
SURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S AND A
GOOD PLACE SO GIVEN THE
UNCERTAINTY AROUND THOSE WAIVERS --
WE DIDN'T WANT TO PUT SOMETHING
ELSE IN THERE RIGHT NOW. ONE
LAST POINT ON THIS --
IS ON SSI AND S. S. P. PROGRAM --
THE CHANGE --
THAT WAS MADE LAST YEAR TO
ELIMINATE THE CASH OUT POLICY
THAT PREVENT.
CALPERS BENEFITS ON THAT WAS
CHANGED ON A ONE TIME BASIS --
WE PROPOSE CHANGING THAT ON AN
ONGOING BASIS MAKING SURE PEOPLE
CAN ACCESS THEIR BENEFITS AND
ANYBODY WHO UNDER THE FORMULA
MIGHT HAVE RECEIVED REDUCED
ACCESS TO THESE BENEFITS WOULD
BE HELD HARMLESS AND CONTINUE AT
THE SAME LEVEL THAT THEY WERE
ACCESSING.
BEFORE.
FINAL POINT IN THE HEALTHCARE
SIDE -- IS
ON IMMIGRATION WHICH A LOT OF
THE FUNDING FLOWS THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES --
WE HAD SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE LAST BUDGET YEAR
WE'RE PROPOSING TO CONTINUE THAT
ON AN ONGOING BASIS.
BUT WERE ALSO PROPOSING TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR A RAPID
RESPONSE FINE TO RESPOND TO
EMERGENCIES WHEREVER THEY CALM
WEATHER THE COMING FROM TO SEE
WHETHER THEY'RE AT THE BORDER
AND THIS FUNDING IS REALLY
IMPORTANT --
FOR COMMUNITIES THAT ARE DEALING
WITH CRISES AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT FUNDING IS
AVAILABLE FOR THEM.
RIGHT AWAY.
WE'RE ALSO PROPOSING --
FINAL COUPLE HEALTHCARE PROGRAMS
ONE AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE BEST BUDDIES PROGRAMS
TEMPLATE EMPLOYMENT-OPPORTUNITIES --
AND WE'RE ALSO HOPING FOR THAT
FUNDING TO IMPROVE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR PEOPLE IN THE CAPITAL AND
CERTAINLY THAT INCLUDES OUR
OFFICES IF YOU'RE LOOKING TO
HIRE SOMEONE FOR YOUR OFFICE
THROUGH THE BEST BUDDIES PROGRAM
I KNOW THAT SOMETHING THAT'S A
BIG PRIORITY OF THE GOVERNOR AS
WELL.
WERE ALSO PROPOSING NEW MONEY
FOR OUTSIDE HELP ALZHEIMER'S
RESEARCH AND INCLUDING WHY THIS
DISEASE DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTS WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR THIS IS A BIG PRIORITY OF
THE FIRST --
FORMER FIRST LADY OF CALIFORNIA
MARIA SHRIVER SHE WILL BE
INVOLVED IN THIS EFFORT --
AND IT'S SOMETHING WE HOPE TO
WORK WITH YOU INCLUDING AND YOU
GOVERNOR'S TASK FORCE ON ELSE
AMHERST PREVENTION AND
PREPAREDNESS.
AND WE FINALLY INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AS TREATMENT
FOR TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURIES.
I WANT TO MOVE ON NOW TO HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS AND LET ME
START WITH HOMELESSNESS --
WE KNOW THAT IN CALIFORNIA THERE
OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE
WHO ARE HOMELESS IN OUR STATE
RIGHT NOW.
ON AND WE KNOW THAT MORE MONEY
IS REALLY IMPORTANT BUT IT WILL
NEVER BE THE SOLUTION BY ITSELF
SO WE NEED MONEY COMBINED WITH
STRONG APPROACHES THAT CAN HELP
SOLVE THIS ISSUE.
SO WE'RE PROPOSING FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING THESE ARE FOR EMERGENCY
SHELTERS AND NAVIGATION CENTERS
AND ALL THIS FUNDING A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WOULD GO TO THE
THIRTEEN BIGGEST CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
FROM LOS ANGELES ALL THE WAY TO
STOCKTON ON THESE ARE CITIES
WITH THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE AND ABOVE --
WERE ALSO PROPOSING AN
ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THAT ANYBODY INCLUDING
THE CITY'S CAN APPLY FOR THROUGH
THE FORTY THREE CONTINUUM'S OF
CARE THESE ARE AREAS DESIGNATED
BY THE FEDERAL DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING.
AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT --
AND THE KEY THING THAT WE WILL
BE LOOKING FOR IN DESIGNING AND
GIVING OUT THIS FINDING IS THAT
THE SOLUTIONS ARE REGIONAL THEM
AS ALL OF YOU KNOW THE GOVERNOR
BEFORE HE WAS GOVERNOR BEFORE HE
WAS LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR --
SERVED AS MAYOR AND THAT THE
HEAD OF BOTH THE CITY AND ON THE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SO
HE REALLY CATS AND UNDERSTANDS
HOW THE SOLUTIONS HAVE TO BE
REACHED ON NATURE.
SO THAT WILL BE A CORE PRIORITY.
ONE OTHER POINT TO MAKE ABOUT
THIS FUNDING --
YOU SAW THAT IT STARTED FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS MILLION
DOLLARS IS FOR JURISDICTIONS
THAT HIT THESE MILESTONES WILL
BE INCENTIVE PAYMENTS THAT THEY
CAN THEY CAN USE FOR ANY PURPOSE
THAT THE WEST.
AND THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT AT
A TIME WHEN LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE ALWAYS START FOR FUNDS THAT
THEY SEE THAT IF THEY DO THE
RIGHT THING ON HOMELESSNESS AND
IF THEY WORK WITH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
THEY CAN ACESS THIS TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL
FUNDING.
WE ALSO PROPOSE UNDER OUR
HOMELESSNESS AGENDA STREAMLINING
A SEQUEL FOR THESE --
HOMELESS SHELTERS AND NAVIGATION
CENTERS --
WITH THE OPERATING THEORY BEING
IF WE CAN DO IT FOR A SPORTS
STADIUM HOW WE CAN DO IT TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE ON THE STREETS
HAVE A PLACE. FOR SHELTER WE
ALSO PROPOSING MAKING SOME
CHANGES TO CALTRANS AIRSPACE
REGULATIONS ON AND ALSO BECAUSE
MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE HOMELESS ARE
ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR SSI BUT AREN'T
ACTUALLY PARTICIPATING IN THE
PROGRAM WERE INCLUDING TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING
FUNDING FOR SSI ADVOCACY --
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW WE BUILT THE
SINCE THE BUDGET IN PRIOR YEARS
ON A ONE TIME BASIS BUT WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE IT'S THERE.
YEAR AFTER YEAR AND THE LAST
POINT I'LL MAKE ON HOMELESSNESS
IS THAT WE'RE PROPOSING A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN.
FUNDING FOR WHOLE CRITICAL
PERSON CARE PILOTS UNDERSTANDING
THAT ALL THE SERVICES NEED TO BE
INTEGRATED HOUSING HEALTH CARE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SOCIAL
SERVICES ANSWER WE'RE LOOKING TO
PILOT DIFFERENT WAYS ON BETTER
WAYS TO DO THAT.
I ALSO WANT TO TALK ABOUT
HOUSING BECAUSE WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT THE PRIORITIES OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION --
AT THE TOP IS YOU KNOW AS
GOVERNOR YOU SOME SAID MAKING
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM REAL ONCE
MORE AND FOR MANY PEOPLE FOR
WHOM THAT DREAM IS OUT OF REACH.
THE REASON AREAS HOUSING COSTS
AND WE KNOW UNDER THE
SUPPLEMENTAL POVERTY MEASURE
NEARLY ONE IN FIVE FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA FALLS UNDER THAT
POVERTY MEASURE AND A MAJOR
REASON FOR THAT.
IS HOUSING COSTS AND RUN BURDEN
FAMILIES SO WE'RE PROPOSING A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT INITIATIVES --
FIRST WE KNOW THAT OUTSIDE OF
OUR BY THE FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
BONDS THAT WAS APPROVED LAST
YEAR THAT INCLUDES ONE AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS FOR MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING.
AS WELL AS A BILLION DOLLARS FOR
VETERANS AND THEN ALSO THE BOND
THAT I MENTIONED THE NO PLACE
LIKE HOME BOND WILL MAKE A
DIFFERENCE ON THE HOUSING SIDE
AS WELL.
AND THEN FINALLY TWO YEARS AGO
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED IN THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED A BILL PROVIDING
A PERMANENT SOURCE OF FUNDING
FOR HOUSING REVENUES FROM REAL
ESTATE TRANSACTION FEES THAT'S A
COUPLE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR.
SO AND OUR AGENDA WE'RE
PROPOSING A SHORT TERM
INITIATIVE AND A LONGER TERM
INITIATIVE.
ON THE SHORT TERM WE'RE
COMMITTED TO SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
NINE DOLLARS TO FLOW TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS WILL HELP THEM.
PLAN FOR INCREASING THEIR
HOUSING SUPPLY THAT STAFFING
THAT'S PLANNING THAT'S
PERMITTING THAT'S REZONING AND
IF THEY HIT THE MILESTONES THAT
WE WORK WITH THEM TO LAY OUT
THAT'S AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THOSE CITIES AND OTHER LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
AND GENERAL PURPOSE FUNDING SO
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS WILL HELP
PUSH LOCAL JURISDICTIONS IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION BECAUSE WE NEED
THEM TO BE THE STATE'S PARTNERS
IN SOLVING THIS HOUSING CRISIS.
OVER THE LONG TERM PROPOSING TO
REVISE THAT RENO GOALS WHICH IS
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT AND MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE SCHOOLS ACTUALLY REFLECT
LOCAL INPUT.
ARE TIED TO STATE GOALS IN ARE
DEVELOPED THROUGH A PROCESS THAT
IS ROBUST AND THAT MAKES SENSE
SO OUR DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT WILL
DEVELOP.
A NEW PLAN TO MAKE THESE GOALS
MAKE SENSE LOOK AT LOCAL INPUT
FOR THEM AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
OVERTIME WILL ENFORCE THEM AND I
KNOW THE GOVERNOR HAS GOTTEN A
LOT OF COMMENTS.
ABOUT HIS PROPOSAL THAT IN THE
FUTURE.
SOME OF THIS TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING MONEY INCLUDING UNDER SP
ONE MAY BE TIED TO MEETING THESE
GOALS THAT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN IN
YOUR ONE OF THIS BUDGET IT'S NOT
GONNA HAPPEN IN YOUR TO IT'S
PART OF THIS LONGER TERM.
PROCESS WE'RE COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERY JURISDICTION KNOWS
WHAT HE NEEDS TO DO TO SOLVE
WHAT IT'S BECOME A STATE WIDE
CRISIS.
AT THE SAME TIME THE GOVERNOR AS
SEEN THIS PROBLEM UP EVERYONE
NEEDS FOR THOSE THAT DON'T --
THE FUNDING MAY BE WITHHELD DOWN
THE ROAD BUT WE HOPE TO GIVE
THEM TIME SO THAT THEY CAN MEET
THEIR GOALS.
THAT THAT FUNDING CAN BE
RESTORED SO THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT I KNOW WILL BE A
CONVERSATION WITH ALL OF YOU IN
THE YEARS TO COME.
WE ALSO INCLUDE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING FINANCE
AGENCY THIS IS TO EXPAND THEIR
MIXED INCOME LOAN PROGRAM ON TOP
OF THE FORTY TRUCK FORTY THREE
MILLION DOLLAR IN BACKING THAT
THEY CURRENTLY HAVE.
AND WE'RE ALSO HOPING AS PART OF
THAT DAD --
LABEL OUT PARTNER WE ARE THESE
COMMITTEES WILL PARTNER WITH
PRIVATE SECTOR ACTORS INCLUDING
COMPANIES IN SILICON VALLEY THAT
CAN STEP UP AND MAKE INVESTMENTS
OF THEIR OWN TO FURTHER EXPAND
ACCESS TO MIXED INCOME HOUSING.
WE SAW JUST THIS MORNING IN
SEATTLE THAT MICROSOFT --
PUT IN FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS INITIATIVES OVER
THERE -- AND
CERTAINLY THE GOVERNOR'S TEAM
FEELS THERE'S NO REASON WHY
OTHER COMPANIES THAT WE HAVE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA CANNOT MAKE
SIMILAR COMMITMENTS --
AND I SHOULD SAY FOR THAT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION --
I SHOULD SAY THAT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IS GOING TO CALIFORNIA
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCY ONE LAST
PROPOSAL ON THIS FRONT IS AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR EXPANSION.
OF THE HOUSING TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM THAT'S THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR EXISTING
PROGRAMS UNDER THE 4% LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT.
AN ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR A NEW MORE
LOW TO MODERATE INCOME HOUSING
TAX CREDIT PROGRAMS FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE AT 6280% OF THE AREA
MEDIAN INCOME. TWO FINAL POINTS
ALL MAKE ON HOUSING ONE IS THAT
THE GOVERNOR RECENTLY SIGNED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO MAKE AN
INVENTORY OF ACCESS STATE
PROPERTY WE THINK THIS IS A
GREAT WAY TO BEAT THESE
PROPERTIES OUT TO DEVELOPERS ARE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THIS IS LAND.
THAT WE ALWAYS HAVE ALREADY HAD
IT COULD MAYBE IN PLACES WHERE
IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR HOUSING AND
WE CAN SIMPLY BIT OUT OR
TRANSFER THAT PROPERTY OVER.
AND GET THAT HOUSING BILLS AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE THING I'LL
POINT IS AS A SUCCESSOR TO
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES THE
LEGISLATURE HAS CREATED.
THIS ENHANCED INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCE DISTRICTS THE ISD'S ALL
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE ONLY THREE OF
THEM IN THE STATE THERE'S A 55%
THRESHOLD FOR VOTER APPROVAL FOR
THE V. I. AFTER USED TO ISSUE
TAX.
WE PROPOSE REMOVING THAT
THRESHOLD AND COMBINING THIS
PROGRAM I'M SORRY NOT COMBINING
BUT WHEN THIS PROGRAM IS PAIRED
WITH OPPORTUNITIES OWNS THAT I
DISCUSSED EARLIER THAT.
ENHANCES INVESTMENTS IN THESE
AREAS WE THINK THAT CAN BE A
POWERFUL INCENTIVE TO FOR MORE
NBC IRAQIS TO PROMOTE REGIONAL
PLANNING AND THEREFORE DEVELOP
MORE HOUSING CAN THAT WAY AS
WELL.
I WANT TO TALK NOW ABOUT
EMERGENCY RESPONSE --
COMING OUT OF THESE FIRES IN
NOVEMBER WE'RE PROPOSING FIRST
OF ALL BECAUSE THIS IS A CORE
COMPETENCY OF THE GOVERNMENT TO
STEP IN WHEN THESE EMERGENCIES
HAPPEN. THIRTY ONE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN PROPERTY TAX
BACK FILL. THREE YEARS FOR YOU
COUNTY IN LAKE COUNTY AND A FULL
YEAR HAVE PROPERTY TAX BACK FILL
FOR ANY LOSSES INCURRED FOR ALL
THE OTHER COUNTIES THAT HAVE
BEEN SUBJECT TO THESE WILDFIRES
THIS INCLUDES LA COUNTY.
ORANGE COUNTY RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SHASTA COUNTY AND SISKIYOU
COUNTY --
AND AS MANY OF YOU KNOW THE
SCHOOL SHARE OF THAT PROPERTY
TAX LOSS --
WILL ALREADY BE FILLED UNDER THE
MATTRESS AND MECHANISM OF
PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT WERE ALSO PROPOSING
TO EXTEND AN AUTHORITY THAT
EXPIRED AT THE END OF LAST YEAR
FOR THE DIRECTOR OF FINANCE TO
TRANSFER MONEY FROM THE SPECIAL
FUNDS FOR ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTIES.
TO ADDRESS THESE EMERGENCIES
THIS INCIDENT ALREADY THAT THE
DIRECTOR KILLY BOSS WORK HOW TO
USE -- THIS
LAST FALL AND WINTER AND WE WANT
TO MAKE AUTHORITY AND THE NEXT
EMERGENCY --
AND THEN WHEN IT COMES TO THE
ACTUAL COSTS OF OUR RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY AND DEBRIS REMOVAL
WE'RE FORECASTING OVER TWO
BILLION DOLLARS --
WHEN ALL IS SAID AND DONE --
WE'VE PASSED THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR A 100% COST YEAR
FOR THEM TO PICK UP ALL OF THEM.
AFTER THE MOST RECENT PACKAGE
THEY GAVE US --
IT WAS 90% AND THAT WAS ACTUALLY
HARD WIRED INTO FEDERAL
LEGISLATION --
MORE TRADITIONALLY --
SOMETIMES TO COST 75% 225% SO WE
ARE ASSUMING IN OUR BUDGET --
THE MOST CONSERVATIVE OF THOSE
ESTIMATES FOR NOW THAT THE STATE
WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR PICKING
UP 25% OF THE OVERALL COST --
I KNOW ON TWITTER THERE WAS SOME
TALK ABOUT THERE NOT BEING ANY
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE BUT WE
BELIEVE THAT --
THE PRESIDENT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL FOLLOW THE
LAW AND CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE
ACCESS TO THOSE FUNDS.
ALSO WHEN IT COMES THAT STATE
COST SHARE USUALLY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE TO PICK UP
25% OF THAT WE'RE PROPOSING
WAVING THAT REQUIREMENT --
WE KNOW LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
ALREADY DEALING WITH THE FIRE
AND THE STATE WILL PICK UP THE
FULL SHARE AND THIS SHOULD SAVE
THESE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS OVER A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT A COUPLE
ENHANCEMENTS TO THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES OVER A
HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN NEW MONEY THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING IN THIS BUDGET.
THIS INCLUDES AN PGRADED NINE
ONE ONE SYSTEM FINALLY COMPLETED
EARTHQUAKE EARLY WARNING
MONITORING SYSTEM AND AS WE KNOW
IN EARTHQUAKES EVEN A COUPLE OF
SECONDS CAN MAKE SUCH A BIG
DIFFERENCE --
USING OUR MUTUAL AID SYSTEM IN
WHICH HELP EACH OTHER WITH
RESOURCES TO PRE POSITION --
FIRE ENGINES AND OTHER RESOURCES
AND INVESTMENT MERGING SEE AND
THAT CAN COST ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS WERE ALSO
PROPOSING FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN A PUBLIC EDUCATION CAMPAIGN
BOTH SATEWIDE.
AND GRANTS TO BUILD LOCAL
RESILIENCY STEP PEOPLE IN
COMMUNITIES ARE AWARE BEFORE AN
EMERGENCY OR OTHER DISASTER WHAT
THEY CAN DO TO PREPARE FOR IT
AND HOW THEY CAN WORK WITH THEIR
NEIGHBORS.
AND FINALLY WERE PROPOSING
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DISASTER ASSISTANCE
ACT WHICH IS ANOTHER WAY TO HELP
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT HAVE HAD --
PUBLIC PROPERTY DAMAGE MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN HELP THEM RESTORE
REPAIR SOME OF THAT DAMAGE.
AND THEN I WANT TO FOCUS
SPECIFICALLY ON WILD FIRES
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT'S WHAT SO
MANY OF YOU ARE THINKING ABOUT --
THE PACKAGE THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAS OUTLINED --
WHEN ALL'S PUT TOGETHER IS FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE INVEST IN
PREPAREDNESS --
PREVENTION AND RESPONSE ON TO
INCLUDE OVER TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR FUEL REDUCTION IN
OUR FORESTS AND THAT WAS OUT OF
THE BILL THAT I KNOW MANY OF YOU
VOTED ON LAST YEAR MAKING SURE
THAT THAT FUNDING STATES FLOWING
FOR THIS YEAR.
IT ALSO INCLUDES OVER A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR NEW
HELICOPTERS TO REPLACE MANY OF
THE CAR HELICOPTERS THAT WERE
USING THAT DATE BACK TO THE
VIETNAM WAR ALMOST HALF A
CENTURY AGO --
AND THEN ALSO THE U. S. AIR
FORCE IS TRANSFERRING THE C. ONE
THIRTY AIRPLANES TO CALIFORNIA
TO HELP USED TO COMBAT WILDFIRES
NEAR TRANSFERRING THOSE TO US
THEM.
BUT THE OPERATING COSTS FOR
THOSE -- WE
WILL HAVE TO PAY ON OUR OWN AND
WE'RE EXPECTING A TRANSFER OF
ONE TO TWO OF THOSE AIRPLANES.
EVERY YEAR.
WE ALSO INCLUDE IN JUST ADDING
MORE YOUR ADDING MORE CREWS TEN
MILLION NO IN INVESTMENTS IN NEW
CAMERAS TO FIRE SMALL SENSING
TECHNOLOGY.
AND FINALLY SIX POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS LAST BUT
CERTAINLY NOT LEAST TO ENSURE
THAT WE LOOK OUT FOR THE HEALTH
OF OUR FIRST RESPONDERS AS MANY
OF YOU KNOW.
THESE FIRST RESPONDERS ARE
FIGHTING THESE FIRES OFTEN GOING
WITHOUT SLEEP WITHOUT BREAKS --
THEY'RE SAYING TERRIBLE THINGS
UP CLOSE WITH THESE FIRES AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
GETS ACCESS TO THE RESOURCES
THAT THEY NEED --
AND WE ALSO INCLUDE NEW
INVESTMENTS IN THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS IMPLEMENTING
THE FORCED RECORDER AND YOU
INVESTMENTS IN RADIO
INTEROPERABLE IT SO WE KNOW THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE WILL WORK
WITH YOU BUT EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS PREVENTION AND
RESPONSE.
IS A CORE PRIORITY OF OURS AND I
KNOW IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO ALL OF
YOU.
A COUPLE QUICK POINTS ON PUBLIC
SAFETY --
OUR PRISON POPULATION FOR THE
STATE IS JUST A SHADE UNDER A
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
FOR THE CURRENT YEAR AND THAT'S
NOT INCLUDING PAROLEES AS SMALL
AS YOU TWO ARE INCARCERATED.
WE HAVE MADE OVER THE LAST SIX
OR SEVEN YEARS A BIG INVESTMENT
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES IN FACT
THAT BUDGET THE SPENDING ON
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES COMPARED
TO TWENTY TWELVE TWENTY THIRTEEN
LEVEL.
IS A HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ABOUT WHAT IT
WAS BACK THEN WERE ALSO
INCLUDING ADDITIONAL MONEY FOR
LITERACY PROGRAMS INCLUDING
TRAINING INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS AS LITERACY COACHES
TO HELP OTHER PEOPLE.
IN OUR PRISON SYSTEM AND TWO AND
A HALF MILLION DOLLARS FOR
TATTOO REMOVAL. TO HELP PEOPLE I
SHOULD THEY WISH TO REMOVE TACK
TO SO THAT THEY CAN BETTER GET
JOBS ON THE OUTSIDE --
WE ALSO INCLUDE NEW FUNDING FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR OUR PRISONS
WE PROPOSE AS THE CHAIR
MENTIONED MOVING OUR DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE AND TO THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY.
AND FINALLY RE PROPOSED TWO
MILLION DOLLARS FOR CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS PARTNERSHIP FOR
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS WHO WANT TO COME
BACK AS AMERICORPS MEMBERS AND
HELP PEOPLE IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM PUT OUT PEOPLE
WHO HAVE TURN THEIR LIVES AROUND
CAN HELP MENTOR OTHERS WERE
SEEKING TO DO.
THE SAME.
WE ALSO INCLUDE ON THE
COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING THIS IS
THE POST COMMISSION --
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS TO MAKE
PERMANENT ONE TIME FINDING AN
ADDITIONAL FOURTEEN POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLAR RESTORATION FOR
FUNDING FOR DE SCALATION AND
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT AND
THEN THE SPORTY SITUATIONS THAT.
CAN QUICKLY SPIN OUT OF CONTROL
AND WE TO CRISIS WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE WE TRAIN OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL.
IN CRISIS INTERVENTION TRAINING
IN RESPONSE WHEREVER POSSIBLE.
FINALLY WE INCLUDE FOURTEEN
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS ACROSS
TWO SEPARATE STREAMS TO COMBAT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING --
THE FIRST IS TEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR VICTIM ASSISTANCE THIS IS
THROUGH --
YES AND THEN THE SECOND IS FOUR
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS THREE
TWO REGIONAL TASK FORCES FOR DOJ
THIS IS TO GO AFTER PREDATORS --
IN BOTH THE NORTHERN AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE ADDRESSING THIS
ISSUE.
WE ALSO INCLUDE FIVE POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS FOR AN ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT TASK FORCE AND THEN
FINALLY ON THE GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION SIDE OF THINGS WE
INCLUDE SIXTEEN POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS OUT OF THE
GENERAL FUND. FOR THE ARMS
PROHIBITED PERSON SYSTEM A SOME
YOU KNOW A LOT OF THIS FUNDING
INITIALLY CAME OUT OF THE
TRUSTEE THAT'S THE DEALER RECORD
OF SALE ON FIREARMS PURCHASES.
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS PROGRAM WHICH IS SO
IMPORTANT HAS A MORE STABLE
REVENUE SOURCE ON AN ADDITION TO
PUBLIC SAFETY WE ALSO PROPOSE
INCREASES IN INVESTMENTS IN OUR
JUDICIAL SYSTEM.
AND OUR COURTS THAT INCLUDES
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
DEPENDENCY COUNCIL SO THAT KIDS
AND PARENTS GET THE
REPRESENTATION THAT THEY NEED IN
PROCEEDINGS.
OUR OUR MOVING ON FROM PUBLIC
SAFETY TO CAP AND TRADE --
WE HAVE A ONE BILLION DOLLAR
EXPENDITURE PROGRAM AND I KNOW I
WAS TALKING WITH SENATOR MY
KASKI JUST BEFORE THE HEARING --
WE FOR POST SEVERAL I'M GOING
INVESTMENTS AND ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES IN REPLACING DIESEL
BUSES AND CLIMATE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE. TO NEW
INVESTMENTS I WANT TO FLAG THE
SOILS --
WHICH IS EIGHTY NINE DOLLARS AND
SECOND AT TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS BOTH OF
THESE ARE BIG PRIORITIES OF THE
GOVERNOR.
GETTING PEOPLE PATHWAYS TO
CAREERS IN A NEW LOW CARBON
ECONOMY AND I KNOW THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO MANY OF YOU AS WELL.
WE ALSO PROPOSE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE LEAD CLEANUP AT
THE EXITE FACILITY IN VERNON AND
FINALLY A PRIORITY FOR THE
GOVERNOR AS WELL AS FOR MANY OF
YOU IS SAFE DRINKING WATER --
WE NOTE FOR PROPOSITION SIXTY
EIGHT THAT OVER A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN BOND FUNDING
WILL FLOW TO PUBLIC --
WATER SYSTEMS AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES BUT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DO ON TOP OF MORE
ON TOP OF THAT SO WE'RE
PROPOSING --
UP FRONT TWENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
EMERGENCY WATER SUPPLIES THE
GOVERNOR JUST LAST FRIDAY WAS IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
NEAR COMMUNITIES THAT OFTEN
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO SAFE
DRINKING WATER AND HE'S TOLD US
ON HIS STAFF THAT HE GETS VERY
RIGHTEOUS ABOUT THIS AND I KNOW
MANY OF YOU DO TO THIS IS A BIG
PROBLEM IT'S A CORE COMMITMENT.
HE'S VERY INTENTIONAL ABOUT IT
TO TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR THOSE
EMERGENCY WATER SUPPLIES ANOTHER
TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO WATER SYSTEMS TO
MAKING SURE THAT THEY CAN COMPLY
WITH CURRENT STANDARDS.
AN ADDITIONAL TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ON GOING
IMPROVEMENTS.
THE FINAL PROGRAM I'M PROGRAMS
AT A PROGRAMS I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT ARE AND HOW GOVERNMENT IS
WORKING AND HOW WE CAN DO EVEN
BETTER WE'RE PROPOSING NINE
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS ON AN
ONGOING BASIS. FOR A NEW OFFICE
OF DIGITAL INNOVATION THIS WILL
REPORT DIRECTLY TO THE SECRETARY
I'VE.
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS THIS IS
MERRY ABOUT BACHELOR WHO AS ALL
OF YOU KNOW HAS ALSO BEEN
APPOINTED TO LEAD THE DMV'S
STRIKE TEAM AND WE BELIEVE THIS
OFFICE WILL NOT SIMPLY OFFER I.
T. ASSISTANCE THERE OTHER
DEPARTMENTS.
IN THE STATE TO DO THAT TO
REALLY FOCUS ON CUSTOMER FOCUSED
SERVICE TRANSFORMATION
RECRUITING ON TOP OF THIS NINE
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING FUNDING. TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDING
THESE PROGRAMS THAT REALLY NEED
HELP IN MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
BRINGING AND THE BEST TALENT IN
AND OUT OF GOVERNMENT. TO HELP
US DEAL WITH THESE ISSUES WERE
ALL WERE ALSO PROPOSING STARTING
IN INNOVATION ACADEMY BUT SENIOR
LEADERS ACROSS GOVERNMENT AND
ALL DEPARTMENTS CAN GO TO FOR
TRAINING TO MAKE SURE THAT ANY
CHANGES THAT WE PROPOSE.
RIPPLE ACROSS THE ENTIRE
ADMINISTRATION WE ALL KNOW THIS
IS A BIG STATE GOVERNMENT MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES SO WE THINK IT'S GONNA
TAKE OUT TO USE THE WORD THAT
THE GOVERNOR USES A LOT A LOT OF
INTENTIONALITY --
TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE CHANGES
CO ALTER THE ADMINISTRATION --
AND THIS IS IMPORTANT OF THE
GOVERNOR BECAUSE HE'S WRITTEN
ACTUALLY A BOOK ABOUT THIS --
BASED ON HIS TIME AS MAYOR AND
WHERE HE BELIEVES GOVERNMENT CAN
GO IN TERMS OF ACTUALLY BEING
EASY TO WORK WITH AND TO DEAL
WITH CITIZEN BILL HE POINTS OUT
THAT IT'S COMING OUT IN THE NEW
EDITION --
SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I KNOW
WILL BE.
I ALREADY --
GOING FORWARD. THREE LAST POINTS
ON GOVERNMENT WERE INCLUDING
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CENSUS WE KNOW THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF CONTROVERSY AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL ABOUT THE CENSUS.
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS THERE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IN OUR
BUDGET WE DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO GET PEOPLE COUNTED.
AT SOME POINT FOR HOW WE
ALLOCATE STATES SERVICES AND
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL FOR KEEPING THAT
ADDITIONAL CONGRESSIONAL SEAT --
WE'VE HAD TEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL
AN ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
AND FINALLY WE HAVE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE THIS IS
THE STATE AMERICORPS PROGRAM AND
WE PROPOSE.
INCREASING ENROLLMENT IN THIS
PROGRAM FOR NEW AMERICORPS
MEMBERS AND ALSO EXPANDING THE
SIEGEL EDUCATION AWARD THAT
MEMBERS RECEIVE AT THE
CONCLUSION OF THEIR SERVICE
WHICH THEY CAN APPLY TO THEIR
DEBT REPAYMENTS OR FOR ONGOING
EDUCATION.
SO THAT'S THE BUDGET --
ONE OTHER THING I'LL SAY IS THAT
WHEN IT COMES TO EARLY ACTIONS
IN THIS IS SOMETHING I'VE BEEN
IN TOUCH WITH SEVERAL OF YOUR
STAFFERS WITH AND WILL BE WE
WILL BE WORKING WITH YOU IN THE
MONTHS TO COME BUT THERE ARE
SEVERAL ITEMS WERE WE PROPOSE.
ACTUALLY MOVING EARLIER AND
PUTTING SOME OF THESE ITEMS INTO
THE CURRENT BUDGET YEAR AND
PERHAPS EVEN ACTING ON THESE
WITH YOUR CONCURRENCE WITH IN
THE UPCOMING MONTHS.
AND LET ME LIVE IN OUT RIGHT NOW
FIRST ARE UPGRADES TO THE NINE
ONE ONE SYSTEM BECAUSE THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE IS IN A STATE OF UTMOST
RELIABILITY AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
SECOND IS SOME OF THE FUNDING I
OUTLINED FOR THE IMMIGRATION
RAPID RESPONSE FUND BECAUSE WE
KNOW THOSE CHALLENGES ARE ON
GOING.
THIRD IS THE FUNDING FOR SAFE
DRINKING WATER BECAUSE THAT'S
REALLY SOMETHING WHERE WE CANNOT
AFFORD TO WAIT.
FOURTH IS THE FUNDING FOR THAT
PROPERTY TAX BACK FILL BECAUSE
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES NEED TO
KNOW THAT THAT FUNDING WILL BE
THERE AND AVAILABLE FOR THEM.
FIFTIES FORTIES EMERGENCY GRANTS
BECAUSE IF WE WANT TO BUILD --
EMERGENCY COMMUNITY RESILIENCY
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE TO DO THAT AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE BEFORE THE NEXT
EMERGENCY OR DISASTER STRIKES.
SIXTIES THE DISASTER RECOVERY
EMERGENCY OVERSIGHT ACCOUNT
WHICH IS THE NAME --
FOR THE AUTHORITY THAT THE
DIRECTOR OF FINANCE HAS TO DRAW
ON SFU FUNDING AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE IN THE NEXT EMERGENCY
THE DIRECTOR CAN ACCESS THOSE
FUNDS RIGHT AWAY.
AND THAT THERE'S NO DIVIDE.
AND THEN THE SECOND AS THE
GOVERNOR MENTIONED RECENT ON
CHARTER SCHOOL TRANSPARENCY ON
AND THE ADMINISTRATION WILL BE
PROPOSING SOME LANGUAGE TO THAT
KIND AS WELL.
I'LL CONCLUDE TWO FINAL POINTS --
THE FIRST AS I MENTIONED AT THE
BEGINNING IS THIS BUDGET IS WAS
DEVELOPED OVER NOVEMBER AND
DECEMBER IT WAS ISSUED ON
JANUARY TENTH WE UNDERSTAND THAT
OUR REVENUE PROJECTIONS WILL
CHANGE.
THAT ARE CONDITIONS WILL CHANGE
WE HAVE TO MONITOR THE SHUT DOWN
IN WASHINGTON DC --
SO THESE ARE ALL THINGS THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE UPDATING AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO BE
IN TOUCH WITH YOU.
AS OUR NUMBERS ARE JOSH TO OF
COURSE THE ADMINISTRATION WILL
BE BACK IN MAY WITH ITS REVISED
BUDGET --
AND THEN THE SECOND THING I JUST
WANT TO SAY IS THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR HAVING ME HERE TO PRESENT
THE BUDGET I'VE REALLY ENJOYED
WORKING WITH YOUR STAFF JOE
STEFFAN SHOT HAS BEEN WONDERFUL
AND GETTING US ACCLIMATED GIVEN
THAT WERE ON DAY EIGHT OR NINE
OFTHIS ADMINISTRATION --
AND REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE AND LOOK
FORWARD TO PUTTING TOGETHER A
BUDGET THAT ALL OF US CAN BE
PRODUCT SO THANK YOU.
SERVICE ONE OF FINE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
OF THE BUDGET A COLLEAGUE FROM
ASKED WE HOLD QUESTIONS UNTIL WE
HEAR FROM THE LA JOH.
AND THEN --
YOU CAN DIRECT YOUR QUESTION TO
THE PROPER PERSON.
WELCOME MISS CHIU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS YOU
SHOULD HAVE A HAND OUT IN FRONT
OF YOU THAT ALL WALK WALK
THROUGH THAT WE ALSO HAVE OUR
PUBLICATION OVERVIEW OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT THE HAND
OUT LARGELY --
TAKES FROM --
THROUGH THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN
SOME DETAIL SO I'M GONNA FOCUS
TODAY ON OUR HIGH LEVEL
ASSESSMENT --
OF THE DISCRETIONARY RESOURCES
AVAILABLE OUR INITIAL TAKE ON
SOME OF THE GOVERNOR'S MAJOR
PROPOSALS AND THEN PROVIDE SOME
OVER ARCHING COMMENTS ON THE
BRIDGE AT STRUCTURE.
I'LL JUST KNOW THAT THIS IS OUR
INITIAL ASSESSMENT OF SOME OF
THESE MAJOR PROPOSALS AND THAT
WE HAVE MUCH WORK IN THE COMING
WEEKS -- TO
PROVIDE YOU ASSISTANCE AS YOU
REVIEW THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN
ASSESSING WHAT IS BEING PROPOSED
LOOKING AT THE TRAILER BILL
THAT'S STILL IN DEVELOPMENT AND
FALLING UNDER FULLY
UNDERSTANDING THE IMPLICATIONS
OF THESE PROPOSALS.
TURNING TO THE FIRST PAGE THIS
CHURCH SHOWS THE BREAKDOWN OF
THE GOVERNOR'S --
DISTRIBUTION OF DISCRETIONARY
RESOURCES WE DO A BOTTOMS UP
TALLYING OF WHAT WE BELIEVE THE
GOVERNOR HAD AT HIS DISCRETION
TO ALLOCATE IN THE BUDGET.
WITH UNDER OUR ESTIMATES THAT IS
TWENTY POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS
AFTER ACCOUNTING FOR THE
CONSTITUTIONAL SPENDING
REQUIREMENTS CHANGES IN CASELOAD
PROGRAM COSTS AND NEW
LEGISLATION.
YOU'LL NOTE THAT THIS IS ABOUT
SIX BILLION DOLLARS HIGHER THAN
THE DISCRETIONARY --
SURPLUS THAT WE ESTIMATED IN
NOVEMBER AND AS WAS ALREADY
REFERENCE IS LARGELY DUE TO
LOWER THAN ESTIMATED COSTS IN
THE MEDI CAL PROGRAM.
ABOUT HALF.
OF THESE DISCRETIONARY RESOURCES
ARE ALLOCATED TO ONE TIME DOT
RELATED SPENDING A QUARTER TO
ONE TIME FOR DRAMATIC SPENDING
AND THEN THE REMAINDER SPLIT
ABOUT FIFTY FIFTY BETWEEN
DISCRETIONARY RESERVES AN
ONGOING SPENDING.
IF YOU TURN TO THE NEXT PAGE
THIS TABLE SUMMARIZES THE MAJOR
OP PROPOSALS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ON THE NON PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT SAID THE BUDGET SO
EXCLUDING FUNDING FOR K. THROUGH
FOURTEEN SCHOOLS --
JUST TO TOUCH ON THAT QUICKLY
THE LARGEST PROPOSAL I WITHIN
THE PROPOSITION NINETY A
GUARANTEE IS TO PROVIDE THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
A ROUGHLY THREE POINT 5% --
COLA ADJUSTMENT --
AND TO FIND --
THOSE GRADE FUNDING RATES.
SO GOING THROUGH THE CHART FIRST
ON THE DAYTON LIABILITY IS ONE
OF THE KEY QUESTIONS WILL BE
EXACT EXAMINING IN THE COMING
MONTHS -- IN
TERMS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS ON THAT MY ABILITIES
IS WHETHER OR NOT THESE WOULD
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE THE
LARGEST BANG FOR THE BUCK IN
TERMS OF FUTURE SAVINGS.
WE ALSO WOULD KNOW THAT --
IN TERMS OF THE ESTIMATES FOR
THE SAVINGS ON PAYMENTS THE
PENSION PLANS THAT WE WOUD
FOCUS ON THE NET SAVINGS THAT
THESE ADDITIONAL PAYMENTS --
COULD PROVIDE AND THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THE ADMINISTRATION IS
IN THE PROCESS OF GETTING SOME
ADDITIONAL MODELING FROM THE
PENSION SYSTEMS TO UNDERSTAND
THE RANGE OF POSSIBLE SAVINGS.
THAT THESE PAYMENTS COULD MAKE
IT COULD NOT PROVIDE.
SO ANOTHER ITEM ON EARLY
EDUCATION AS A WAS ALREADY
MENTIONED IS THE PRE SCHOOL
EXPANSION THE PRE SCHOOL
EXPANSION AND TURN IT LEAST IN
ITS EARLY PHASES WHAT TARGET
CHILDREN --
WHO THE RESEARCH CLEARLY SHOWS
BENEFITS THE MOST BENEFIT THE
MOST FROM --
THIS TYPE OF EARLY EDUCATION LOW
INCOME CHILDREN.
THE EARLY OTHER EARLY EDUCATION
PROPOSALS KINDERGARTEN FACILITY
IS WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
FACILITIES THESE ARE LARGELY
STILL IN DEVELOPMENT WE HOPE TO
KNOW MORE ONCE THE TRAILER BILL
IS RELEASED.
THE GOVERNOR TAKES A BIT OF A
DIFFERENT APPROACH WHEN IT COMES --
TO THE UNIVERSITIES AND
PROVIDING ONGOING AUGMENTATIONS
IN THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION AS
WAS ALREADY NOTED THE
AUGMENTATIONS --
OUTLINED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET OUR FOR SPECIFIC
ACTIVITIES --
AND PRIORITIES OF THE
ADMINISTRATION WE THINK
TARGETING THESE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO SPECIFIC --
EXPECTATIONS FROM FROM THE LEDGE
WE TOOK A MORE ROBUST
CONVERSATION AND BETTER FISCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY OF THE
UNIVERSITY'S.
IN TERMS OF THE CAL WORKS
AUGMENTATION --
THE CAL WORKS AUGMENTATION TAKES
A BIT OF A DIFFERENT APPROACH
THAN WHAT THE LEGISLATURE LAID
OUT IN ITS INTENT LANGUAGE LAST
YEAR.
AS YOU ALL KNOW THE LEGISLATURE
STATED THAT THAT IT IS IT'S GOAL
OVER A THREE YEAR PERIOD FOR THE
CAL WORKS GRANT LEVELS REACH 50%
OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WOULD
INCREASE THE POWER GRANT LEVELS
250% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL BUT ONLY FOR A FAMILY OF
THREE FOR ALL OTHER FAMILY SIZES
IT WOULD REPRESENT A THREE POINT
1%.
INCREASE THIRTEEN FORTY THREE
THIRTEEN POINT 1% --
GRANT INCREASE --
TO TO THOSE FAMILIES.
AS WAS ALREADY NOTED --
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO
MAINTAIN THE IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES 7% SERVICE --
INCREASE DESPITE NOT --
MAINTAINING THE MCO TAX.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THOSE THOSE
TWO ARE TIED TOGETHER.
AND THE ADMINISTRATION ALSO
MAKES A NUMBER OF CHANGES --
TO THE BOB BUDGET PACKAGE THAT
WAS PASSED TWO YEARS AGO WITH
FOR THE IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES PROGRAM.
THESE CHANGES --
WEAR DRESS WE BELIEVE SOME OF
THE CURRENT ISSUES AND HOW THAT
PROGRAM IS FUNDED THE LOCAL
LEVEL HOW --
COUNTIES RECEIVE FUNDING TO PAY
FOR THEIR SHARE OF COSTS BUT AT
LEAST BASED ON OUR INITIAL
ASSESSMENT IT DOES LOOK LIKE
COUNTY IS.
COSTS WOULD NOT BE COVERED BY
WITHIN A COUPLE YEARS THROUGH
THE FUNDING STREAMS THAT THEY
CURRENTLY PROVIDE RECEIVE IN
NINETEEN NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT.
I'M MOVING ON TO SOME OF THE
HEALTH CARE ISSUES WE WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT --
THE PENALTY THE INDIVIDUAL
HEALTH CARE MANDATE PENALTY AND
THE SUBSIDIES ARE NOT REFLECTED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BOTTOM LINE
BUDGET.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE GOVERNOR
ESTIMATES THAT THERE WOULD BE
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS WORTH AND REVENUES FROM
THESE PENALTIES THAT.
I'VE DONE AT LEAST BASED BASED
ON OUR CURRENT ASSESSMENT SEEMS
LIKE A REASONABLE ESTIMATE WE
DON'T YET HAVE DETAIL ON HOW THE
PENALTY REVENUE --
X. WOULD BE DISTRIBUTED FOR THE
SUBSIDIES BUT WE WOULD NOTE THAT --
IN.
THE PENALTY REVENUE AND THE
SUBSIDIES ARE CONFLICTING GOALS
OVER TIME IF THE PENALTY IS
EFFECTIVE REVENUE SHOULD DECLINE
BECAUSE MORE PEOPLE ARE.
SIGNING UP FOR COVERAGE ON WHICH
COULD CAUSE SUBSIDIES --
TO DECLINE OVER TIME AS WELL
UNLESS THEY ARE GOING TO BE
SUPPORTED THROUGH THE GENERAL
FUND.
IN TERMS OF THE GOVERNOR'S PAID
FAMILY LEAVE PROPOSAL IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE INITIAL
PLAN IS TO DRIVE DOWN SOME OF
THE RESERVE WITHIN THE
DISABILITY INSURANCE FUND --
BUT AGAIN THERE'S NOT DIRECT
FUNDING FOR THAT PLAN WITHIN
WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AS
WAS ALREADY MENTIONED.
MOVING TO HOUSING --
THE TAX CREDIT EXPANSION THAT
WAS SO IT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S DOES NOT EXPECT WILL
BE UTILIZED WITHIN THEIR BUDGET
WINDOW --
WHILE THERE IS THIS FIVE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR EXPANSION
WE DON'T SEE --
ANY CHANGES IN REVENUES --
WITHIN THE THE BUDGET WINDOW OF
OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET MEANING
THAT THEY DON'T EXPECT THEM TO
BE CLAIMED WITHIN THAT TIME
PERIOD.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET --
ALSO RAISES SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHICH POPULATIONS THE
LEGISLATURE LIKE TO TARGET FOR
HOUSING ASSISTANCE.
ROUGHLY ABOUT A QUARTER OF LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS IN THE STATE
RECEIVE SOME FORM OF HOUSING
ASSISTANCE.
THERE SIMPLY IS NOT CURRENTLY
SUFFICIENT FUNDING TO PROVIDE
EVERY LOW INCOME PERSON IN IN
THE STATE WITH THIS TYPE OF
ASSISTANCE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
DOES ALLOCATE IS A MUCH LARGER
PROPORTION OF FUNDING. TO HIRE
SOMEONE THERE ARE RELATIVELY
HIGHER INCOME LEVELS AND THIS
JUST RAISES A QUESTION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER WHO IT
WOULD LIKE TO TARGET WITH THESE
LIMITED RESOURCES.
ON DISASTERS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL --
RAISES SOME SOME QUESTIONS --
FIRST WHAT FUNDING SOURCE TO USE
FOR SOME ACTIVITIES IN
PARTICULAR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL USES GENERAL FUND. FOR
SOME ITEMS THAT HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN PAID --
BY SPECIAL FUNDS LIKE THE NINE
ONE ONE OUR SERVICE IMPROVEMENTS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
RAISES SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT
LOCAL ASSISTANCE AND WHAT TYPES
AND HOW SUSTAINABLE LOCAL
ASSISTANCE PAYMENTS --
TO THESE --
COMMUNITIES AFFECTED --
MAYBE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SINCE
STATE ASSISTANCE.
AND THE LEGISLATURE MAY SIMPLY
WANT TO CONSIDER WHAT IS
SUSTAINABLE OVER TIME IN TERMS
OF PROPERTY TAX BACK FILLS WHAT
COMMUNITIES MIGHT WE EXPECT TO
BE ABLE TO RECOVER FROM THESE
WILD FIRES --
AND WHAT COMMUTE WHAT TYPES OF
COMMITTEES MADE ME LONGER
ASSISTANT A LONGER PERIODS OF
ASSISTANCE SIR COVER.
LASTLY ON THIS PAGE --
WE WOULDN'T RECOMMEND --
SPLITTING THE TAX PROPOSALS AND
CONSIDERING THEM SEPARATELY --
THE EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT IS
ONE THAT IS HARD HAS BEEN HARD
FOR THE STATE TO ESTIMATE WITH
US SOME LEVEL OF ACCURACY IN
TERMS OF THE TAKE UP AND THE
COSTS OVER TIME.
SIMILARLY THE COOKIE ANY
CONFORMITY ACTIONS TAKEN BY THE
LEGISLATURE WILL HAVE AFFECTS ON
REVENUES THAT MAY CHANGE OVER
TIME AND HEARING THESE TWO
POLICY PROPOSALS TOGETHER.
PRESENTS CHALLENGES --
IN TERMS OF TRYING TO ARRIVE AT
A NET NEUTRAL REVENUE NEUTRAL --
PACKAGE.
TURNING TO THE LAST PAGE OF THE
HANDOUT JUST SOME OVER ARCHING
COMMENTS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OUTSIDE
LANDS MANY BUDGET PART POLICY
PRIORITIES EARLY AND MANY OF
THEM ARE IN KEEPING WITH RECENT
LEGISLATIVE ACTION.
THIS PROVIDES THE LEGISLATURE
KEY OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND TO FORM
ITS OWN VIEW OF WHAT THESE
POLICY SHOULD BE OVER THE COMING
MONTHS.
WE WERE NOTE THAT THE ONGOING
COSTS UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WHICH ARE TWO POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS.
IN THE BUDGET YEAR BUT GROWING
TO THREE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS --
IN THE IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ARE ROUGHLY IN
LINE WITH WHAT WE ASKED ALL
UNDER OUR NOVEMBER ESTIMATES BUT
THERE ARE AREAS WHERE COST TO
GROW FOR INSTANCE MANY OF THE
ITEMS THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS IN
HIS BUDGET FOR DISASTER
MITIGATION OR COVERING RELIEF --
ARE ONE TIME IN NATURE BUT THEY
ARE THESE ARE LIKELY TO BE
ONGOING COSTS FOR THE STATE.
GIVEN THE FREQUENCY AND THE
SEVERITY OF DISASTERS OF THE
STATE IS SEEN OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS.
ALSO JUST NOTE --
AS WAS BROUGHT UP THAT THE
AUTHORITY. TO TRANSFER FUNDS OUT
OF THE SFE YOU TO RESPOND TO
DISASTERS IS SOMETHING HAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS LOOKING TO
RENEW --
RATHER QUICKLY IN THIS I THINK
IS A KEY AREA OF CONSIDERATION
FOR THE LEGISLATURE BECAUSE
BECAUSE OF THE SIZE OF THE
TRANSFERS THAT MAY HAPPEN AND
THE TYPES OF BUDGET RESIST SIR
RESILIENCY QUESTIONS THE
LEGISLATURE WANT TO CONSIDER OF
OF HOW TO FIND THOSE TYPES OF
TRANSFERS THERE IS.
A VERY LARGE TRANSFER AT THE END
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT I THINK
RAISES SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW
TO STRUCTURE.
THE ABILITY OF THE
ADMINISTRATION TO TAP IMMEDIATE
BASIS BUT THEN ALSO KEEPS THE
STATE'S RESERVES INTACT.
ON THE THIS BUDGET DOES.
ALLOCATE A SMALLER SHARE OF
DISCRETIONARY RESOURCES TO
RESERVES THEM PRIOR BUDGETS.
ON NET DISCRETIONARY RESERVES
WOULD BE ABOUT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET --
BUT THAT SAID --
THEY DO TAKE A NEW
INTERPRETATION OF PROPOSITION
TWO WHICH NECESSITATES I ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR
TRANSFERRED TO THE BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT THE
STATE'S CONSTITUTIONAL SAVINGS
ACCOUNT.
A CONSEQUENCE OF MAKING THAT
TRIP TAKING THIS INTERPRETATION
AND MAKING THAT TRANSFER TO THE
BSA.
IS THAT THERE WOULD BE NO
INFRASTRUCTURE SPENDING IN THE
BUDGET YEAR UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ESTIMATES THERE
WOULD BE INFRASTRUCTURE SPENDING
IN THE LAST YEAR OF THEIR WINDOW.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AS YOU
KNOW THE LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR --
AS PER THE BUDGET PACKAGE
ADOPTED A PLAN FOR THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE SPENDING THAT IT
ANTICIPATED STARTING IN THE
BUDGET YEAR.
CONSEQUENTLY CONCEPT THE
CONSEQUENCE OF THE NEW
INTERPRETATION OF PROPOSITION
TWO IS THAT THERE WOULD BE NO
FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR THAT PLAN.
WHILE THE GOVERNOR DOES NOT
DEDICATE --
A HIGHER SHARE OF DISCRETIONARY
RESOURCES TO RESERVES --
THE PAIN OUT OF DEBT AND
LIABILITIES DOES DO IMPROVE THE
BUDGETS BOTTOM LINE AND REDUCE
COSTS IN THE LONG TERM --
ONE THING TO NOTE HOWEVER  I
JUST IN TERMS OF BUDGET
RESILIENCY THE CHANGES TO THE
CERTIFICATION PROCESS DO PRISON
FOR PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT DO
PRESENTS SOME QUESTIONS.
ABOUT HOW CHANGES IN THE
GUARANTEE --
WILL BE DEALT WITH WHEN WHETHER
OR NOT THERE WILL BE ADJUSTMENTS
WITHIN CURRENT THE CURRENT YEAR.
ODD -- TO
ADJUST THE GUARANTEE UP OR DOWN --
AND WHETHER WHO WILL BEAR THE
COSTS WHETHER IT'S THE NINETY
EIGHT SIDE OF THE BUDGET OR THE
NON NINETY EIGHT SIDE OF THE
BUDGET.
AS YOUR CALL THE CERTIFICATION
PROCESS --
WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS ADOPTED
AT RATHER COMPLEX MECHANISM TO
DEAL WITH.
OVER AND UNDER APPROPRIATIONS OF
THE GUARANTEE OVERTIME --
WHILE WE'RE ON SCHOOLS ARE JUST
TWO THINGS TO NOTE THE FIRST IS
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
DOES NOT PROVIDE.
A VERY LARGE QUESTION WITHIN THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE THAT IS IT DOES NOT
ALLOCATE VERY MUCH MONEY TO ONE
TIME SPENDING OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS.
THERE HAS BEEN A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT QUESTION WITHIN THE
NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE
PROTECTING SCHOOLS FROM YEAR TO
YEAR FLUCTUATIONS SUCH THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE TO MAKE CUTS TO
ONGOING PROGRAMS.
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL THERE IS NOT A VERY
LARGE QUESTION AT ALL.
THE SECOND THING I WOULD NOTE
ABOUT SCHOOLS IS THAT TO DATE
THERE HAS NOT BEEN A DEPOSIT
INTO THE SCHOOLS RESERVE ACCOUNT.
CONSEQUENTLY SHOWED A DOWNTURN
CON.
THERE IS NOT A DEDICATED
STATEWIDE SAVINGS ACCOUNT FOR
SCHOOLS CURRENTLY THIS COULD PUT
PRESSURE ON ANY WITHDRAWALS FROM
THE BUDGET STABILIZATION ACCOUNT --
FOR SCHOOL SPENDING.
LASTLY I'LL TOUCH ON REVENUES
ARE REVENUE ESTIMATES ARE VERY
SIMILAR TO THE ADMINISTRATION'S
IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND IN THE
OUT YEARS VERY SIMILAR.
THAT SAID WE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION PUT TOGETHER OUR
REVENUE ESTIMATES PRIOR TO THE
DOWNTURN IN THE MARKET AT THE
VERY END OF LAST YEAR.
THIS POSES SOME REST.
UNDER OUR ESTIMATES AND UNDER
THE CURRENT CONSENSUS OF
PROFESSIONAL ECONOMISTS IF THE
STOCK MARKET STAYS AT ITS
ROUGHLY CURRENT LEVEL AND GROW
SOMEWHAT SLOWLY OVER THE CURRENT
YEAR.
WE BELIEVE THE REVENUE LOSS
COULD BE ABOUT ONE TO TWO
BILLION DOLLARS.
THIS AMOUNT HOWEVER IS SOMETHING
THAT LIKELY COULD BE ABSORBED BY
THE CONSTITUTIONAL WERE SPENDING
REQUIREMENTS.
LARGELY UNDER PROPOSITION TWO
AND WITH SOME REDUCTIONS IN THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE.
THAT SAID IF THE LOSSES TURN OUT
TO BE LARGER THERE IS INCREASED
RISK AND THE THOSE
CONSTITUTIONAL SPENDING
APARTMENTS NO LONGER WOULD BE
ABLE TO ABSORB.
THOSE REDUCTIONS AND THERE WOULD
BE IMPACTS OF THE BUDGET BOTTOM
LINE.
THAT'S THE END OF MY COMMENTS
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
BOTH OF YOU I SEE LET ME JUST
ACKNOWLEDGE WHO I SEE I SEE
SENATOR RON [inaudible]
MISS LEYVA [inaudible]
IT [inaudible]
MISTER BELL [inaudible] ZERO
TAMARA.
BEFORE WE GET STARTED LISTENING
TO ROCK IF I COULD JUST ASK VERY
QUICKLY AND I'VE GOT A COUPLE
QUESTIONS BUT TO START WITH THE
ONE AS TO MENTION THERE ARE --
ONE UNIQUE ASPECT OF THE BUDGET
ARE THERE ARE QUITE A FEW POLICY
PRIORITIES HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED
EARLY --
SOME MAJOR SHIFT SOME VERY NEW
PER SHOULD WE EXPECT TO SEE SOME
OF THOSE BRAND NEW PROPOSALS I'M
THINKING.
CASE IN POINT --
DJJ TRANSFERRED TO HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES THAT WILL REQUIRE
THAT'S GOING TO TAKE A LOT TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT THAT WILL LOOK
LIKE SHOULD WE EXPECT TO SEE THE
DETAILS IN THE MAY REVISE.
WILL THEY COME OUT AND TREAT THE
BILL LANGUAGE TO TELL US WHAT.
YOU ANTICIPATE STRUCTURALLY WE
WILL SEE MORE OF THE MEAT ON THE
BONES OF SOME OF THESE MAJOR NEW
PROGRAMS AND POLICIES YES.
YES SO FOR SOME OF THESE BIGGER
ONES AND REALLY LIKE THAT ONE
AND HOMES OR WITH PID FAMILY
LEAVE -- I
THINK WHERE IT'S GOING TO TAKE A
COUPLE MONTHS TO REALLY GET TO
THE DETAILS OF NUNS ALSO PRETTY
CURRENT PAY FAMILIES GOING TO BE
A CONVERSATION WITH ALL OF USE
OKAY SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS WERE
WORKING OUT THE DETAILS AND
THOSE WILL BE READY ON FEBRUARY
FIRST.
BUT WHEN YOU'RE THINKING OF
THESE NEW VERY BIG TICKET LONG
TERM INITIATIVES WE EXPECT THAT
THAT WILL TAKE A COUPLE MONTHS
AS WELL.
EXCELLENT OKAY THANK YOU FOR
THAT WE'LL START WITH SENATOR
ROUGH.
THANK YOU VENTURE --
MISTER OF HIS WILL OFTEN DID I
PRONOUNCE THAT CORRECTLY.
IT'S BETTER THAN OUR SHOES.
FIRST LET ME OF COMPLIMENTS YOU
THAT SERVE MY BEEN DOING THIS
BUDGET STUFF FOR SIX YEARS
THAT'S THE MOST DETAILED BUDGET
OVERVIEW I THINK WE'VE HAD IN
SIX YEARS AND UP WHILE IT WAS A
FIRE HOSE --
IT WAS AS MUCH APPRECIATED.
I HAVE --
MAYBE THREE QUICK QUESTIONS I
WASN'T GOING TO ASK ONE ON
EDUCATION BECAUSE I FIGURED WE'D
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO HAVE SOME CLOSE CONVERSATION
ON THAT LATER BUT WHITE WINE NO
DEPOSIT INTO THE SCHOOL
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT.
YES SO --
I'VE HAD DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THIS --
ON MY TEAM.
BASICALLY UNDER PROPOSITION TWO
THERE IS THE BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT AND THEN
THE SCHOOL STABILIZATION ACCOUNT --
IT'S TO THE BUDGET BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT THOSE ARE
THE MANDATORY DEPOSITS THAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT. FOR
THE SCHOOL STABILIZATION ACCOUNT --
DEPOSITS ARE ONLY REQUIRED --
WHEN A NUMBER OF VERY SPECIFIC
CONDITIONS ARE MET AND IT TURNS
OUT THAT WE NEED A NUMBER OF
THOSE CONDITIONS THIS YEAR SO
UNDER PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHTS
THREE TESTS WE HAVE TO BE IN A
TEST ONE YEAR WHICH MEANS THAT?
THE AMOUNT COMING OUT OF STATE
BUDGET IS A SET PERCENTAGE OF
THE WHOLE.
RATHER THAN NECESSARILY
ADJUSTING FOR PERSONAL INCOME
GROWTH OR GENERAL FUND REVENUE
GROWTH -- SO
WE ARE IN A TEST ONE YEAR --
WE ALSO ELIMINATED ALL
OUTSTANDING MAINTENANCE FACTOR
PRIOR TO THE YEARS TWENTY
FOURTEEN TWENTY FIFTEEN THAT WAS
ALSO A REQUIREMENT.
UNDER PROPOSITION --
TWO BUT THE ONE TEST THAT WE
HAVEN'T MET YET IS THAT THE
PROPOSITION ONE LEVEL HAS TO BE
HIGHER THAN THE PROPOSITION TWO
LEVEL BY GETTING THAT RIGHT
JESSICA.
YEAH SO THAT'S THE TEST THAT'S
NOT NOT THIS YEAR AND THE WAY
COLLATION WORKS WHICH IS BASED
ON THE GROWTH AND PERSONAL
INCOME --
ITS FIRST WEIGHED AGAINST TEST
THREE WHICH IS BASED ON THE
GROWTH IN GENERAL FUND REVENUES.
DONE TAKE THE LOWER OF THOSE TWO
TESTS AND PUT IT UP AGAINST TEST
ONE WHICH IS OVERALL PERCENTAGE
OF GENERAL FUND REVENUE --
SO IT TURNS OUT THAT IN THIS
YEAR OUR TEST ONE LEVEL IS
HIGHER THAN --
THAT TEST THREE LEVEL BUT
LOWERED SOME SORRY.
AM I GETTING THIS RIGHT HIGHER
THAN THE TEST THREE LEVEL BUT
STILL LOWER THAN THE TEST TO
LEVEL SO FOR THOSE REASONS NO
DEPOSIT IS MANDATED.
NOW YOU COULD ARGUE --
SIMILAR TO SOME OF THE
SUPPLEMENTAL DEPOSITS THAT HAVE
BEEN HAPPENING IN THE PAST FOR
PROPOSITION TWO WHICH WE ARE NOW
CHARACTERIZING AS MORE OPTIONAL --
YOU COULD ARGUE WE CAN MAKE AN
OPTIONAL DEPOSIT INTO THIS
ACCOUNT IN THIS YEAR AND THAT
CERTAINLY WOULD BE OFFERED THE
IMPACT OF ANY FUTURE --
RECESSION I THINK WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS THAT
DETERMINE A WE FOR NOW IS THAT
SCHOOLS EVEN WITH THIS MAJOR
INCREASE IN K. TWELVE FUNDING.
OVER THE LAST SEVEN YEARS ARE
STILL UNDER A LOT OF PRESSURE
AND OF COURSE WE'RE ALL AWARE OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN LOS ANGELES --
SO THERE IS AN EMPHASIS RIGHT
NOW AND GETTING AL THOSE FUNDS
INTO THE HANDS OF SCHOOLS RIGHT
NOW WE ARE AWARE THAT THAT THIS
IS AN ISSUE THAT WE WILL HAVE TO
DEAL WITH INCREASING THE BASE.
BASE LEVEL GRANT AND THINGS LIKE
THAT IT FINDS ACT THAT MINIMUM
GUARANTEE LEVEL --
BUT WE DO BELIEVE THAT ARE THREE
BILLION DOLLAR PAYMENT TO CAL
STIRS WHILE OUTSIDE OF THE BASS
GRANT PROVIDES AN ADDITIONAL
LEVEL OF SUPPORT TO THE TUNE OF
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN EACH OF THE NEXT TWO
YEARS.
I'M SURE MY COLLEAGUES WILL HAVE
MORE QUESTIONS AND THEN I'LL
LEAVE THAT TO THEM I HAVE TO
HOPEFULLY QUICK QUESTIONS ON
HEALTH CARE SINCE I WILL NOT
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY. TO VISIT
WITH YOU IN A SUBCOMMITTEE ON
THIS YOU MENTIONED CHANGES TO
THE MECHANISM.
BY WHICH THE STATE PROVIDES
COUNTIES WITH AYE HSS FUNDING
AND THAT THIS MAN MIGHT.
HOPEFULLY WILL ALLOW COUNTIES TO
MOVE MORE MONEY TOWARD MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
AS YOU MAY KNOW WE HAVE A MENTAL
HEALTH WITH SEVERAL FUNDING
DISPARITIES IN THE STATE BUT
CERTAINLY A MENTAL HEALTH
FUNDING DISPARITY IN THE STATE
AS A RESULT OF THE NINETEEN
NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT.
WHICH WAS BASED ON POPULATION
AND CASELOADS AND THERE'S THIS
WAS A THIRD FACTOR BACK THEN.
WERE THE FUNDING IN THE COASTAL
URBAN AREAS --
AS TENDED TO REMAIN FAIRLY HIGH
BUT AS THE POPULATION SHIFTS IN
THE CASELOAD INCREASES IN THE
INLAND AREAS NORTH CENTRAL AND
SOUTH.
THE FUNDING ALLOCATION IS NOT
KEPT UP WITH THE WITH THE
POPULATION IN CASE OF GROWTH.
WILL THIS --
READING REALIGNMENT SO TO SPEAK
OF IHS FUNDING I JUST AS FUNDING --
ALLOW US --
TO RE VISIT THE ALLOCATION
FORMULAS FOR THE NEW MONEY THAT
YOU EXPECT TO BE USED BY
COUNTIES. FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES LET ME DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUE ON THAT ALLOCATION.
IS THAT A FAIR QUESTION SIR.
JACOB FOR WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO THAT.
THE THE PROPOSAL RELATED TO I
JUST SAYS IS NOT PROPOSING TO
CHANGE THE ALLOCATIONS AS THEY
ARE CURRENTLY IN PLACE --
PLEASE --
MEANING.
THERE'S THERE'S STILL BASED ON
THE ORIGINAL --
UP PERCENTAGES THAT WERE SET BY
NINETEEN NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT --
THAT IS A CONVERSATION WHERE
WERE OPEN TO I THINK IT IT
DEFINITELY WILL REQUIRE --
LOTS OF INPUT FROM FROM THE
COUNTIES THEMSELVES --
BUT BUT OUR PROPOSAL.
ESSENTIALLY BY BY --
A REDUCING THE MOE.
WHAT IT DOES IS IT FREES UP
REALIGNMENT DOLLARS ADDITIONAL
REALIGNMENT DOLLARS TO GO
TOWARDS --
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAM
INCLUDING GROSS MONEY INCLUDING
GROWTH MONEY THAT'S CORRECT WELL
I'M NOT GOING TO BELABOR THIS
BUT I'LL ASK MY COLLEAGUES WHO
HEARS THIS PARTICULAR BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE PERHAPS.
TO EXPLORE THIS A GROWTH FACTOR
IN THE IN THE FUTURE AND MAYBE
YOU ALL CAN TAKE A LOOK AT THAT.
A LESLIE YOU MENTIONED THE
PRESCRIPTION DRUG PLAN AS PART
OF GENERALLY SPEAKING AS PART OF
THE GOVERNOR'S.
PROPOSAL --
AND AS YOU MAY KNOW --
OUR CALIFORNIA SAFETY NET
HOSPITALS AND SOME IF NOT MANY
OTHERS.
HAVE BEEN RELYING ON A FEDERAL
THREE FORTY B. WAIVER UTILIZING
THE DELTA BETWEEN DISCOUNTED
DRUG PRICING AND REIMBURSEMENTS.
OF FOR OPERATIONAL FUNDING AND
IT IS NOT IN SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT
OF MONEY --
HAVE YOU OR WILL YOU EXPLORE OF
THE IMPACT OF THIS PRESCRIPTION
DRUG PROPOSAL ON THE USE OF THE
THREE FORTY B. PROGRAM AND THE
POTENTIAL ADVERSE CONSEQUENCES.
TO CERTAINLY OUR SAFETY NET
HOSPITALS IF NOT OTHERS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE YES NO ABSOLUTELY
AND NO THAT IS CORRECT THAT WE
ARE WE HAVE A DIANNE COMMENTS IS
A SPECIAL ADVISER IN OUR OFFICE
HAS FLAG IT FOR ALL OF US YOU
KNOW WE ARE LOOKING AT IT.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHILE WE SAVE ACROSS THE SYSTEM --
THAT THE SAVINGS DON'T HAVE AN
ADVERSE IMPACT ON THE SAFETY NET
HOSPITALS SO ON THE PROPOSAL'S
NHIAU YOU KNOW WAS ANNOUNCED
EIGHT OR NINE DAYS AGO --
SO WE'RE STILL DEVELOPING
EXACTLY HOW IT WILL WORK IN A
LOT F THE DETAILS BUT THAT IS
DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT IS TOP
OF MIND FOR US BUT WE HAVE AN
EXPERT IS THE CHAIR THAT
PARTICULAR BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
SO I'M SURE HE'LL DELVE INTO IT
I JUST WANTED. TO TO STICK MY
SMALL OR IN THE WATER ON THE
ISSUE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM
SURE THANK YOU SENATOR LEYVA
WHO'LL BE FOLLOWED BY SENATOR
MORE LOT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
BOTH FOR YOUR EXCELLENT
PRESENTATIONS THIS IS MY FIRST --
BUDGET MEETING SO I'M NOT SURE
WHO MY CORE --
QUESTIONS SHOULD BE DIRECTED --
TO BUT IT'S UNDER HIGHER
EDUCATION AND UNDER THE STUDENT.
I'M WONDERING WHY AT THE UC'S
THEY THE BUDGET PROPOSES FIFTEEN
MILLION OF ON GOING GENERAL FUND
MONEY. TO AUGMENT THEIR EFFORTS.
BUT THE C. ISSUES ARE ONLY GOING
TO GET A FIFTH FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLAR ONE TIME --
GENERAL FUND ASSISTANCE.
CHRISTY.
WAS CERTAINLY CHRIS FERGUSON
WITH FINANCE.
PART SO WHEN THE TWO SYSTEMS
HAVE BEEN AT THEIR PROPOSALS --
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
INDICATED A WHAT A WANTON DESIRE
TO DO SOMETHING ONGOING IN THIS
AREA WHERE'S THE CSU HAD
INDICATED.
A REQUEST FOR ONE TIME FUNDING
AND THAT'S REALLY THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN THE TWO
THAT'S VERY HELPFUL THANK YOU.
ARE THE OTHER QUESTION I HAVE IS
ON UNDER THE JUNE JUDICIAL
BRANCH.
AND IT HAS TO DO.
WITH FUNDING FOR RAPE KITS --
LAST YEAR.
WEN WE --
INTRODUCED SB FOURTEEN FORTY
NINE WHICH WOULD HAVE TESTED ALL
RAPE KITS GOING FORWARD THE COST
WAS SIX POINT FIVE MILLION FOR
THE FIRST YEAR AND FOUR MILLION
GOING FORWARD.
I WAS WONDERING IF THE FIRST
YEAR WAS TO BUY A QUICK MINUTE
AND THAT'S WHY THAT YOU'RE WAS
HIGHER IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IT INCLUDES FIVE POINT
EIGHT MILLION TO PURCHASE NEW
EQUIPMENT.
SO I'M JUST WONDERING IF THAT
WILL DO AND IS THERE MONEY TO
MAKE SURE THE RAPE KITS ARE
ACTUALLY TESTED.
SO I DON'T HAVE THE DETAIL ON
THAT WITH ME --
BUT I'M GONNA TURN OVER TO ONE
OF MY COLLEAGUES WILL HELP.
THE AMAZON WITH PERMANENT
FINANCE SO LAST YEAR IN --
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S
BUDGET WE HAD I THINK IT WAS
FIVE POINT SIX MILLION FOR A ONE
TIME PURCHASE OF EQUIPMENT --
AND THIS YEAR IN DOJ'S BUDGET WE
HAVE FIVE POINT EIGHT ONGOING --
TO PURCHASE --
EQUIPMENT IT WAS YOU KNOW WE
WERE WAITING FOR A REPLACEMENT
SCHEDULE FROM THEM --
AND SO WE HAVE ONGOING FUNDING
FOR THAT THERE IS MONEY IN THERE --
FOR GREAT K?T TESTING AS WELL
RELATED --
TO THE TWO BILLS THAT WERE
PASSED LAST YEAR AND THEN ALSO --
I'D BACK FULL FOR THE DNA FUND
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE PASSING US SEXUAL OR
NOT PASSING A PROCESSING SEXUAL
ASSAULT KITS.
I AM AWARE OF THE ONE BILL THAT
PASSED AND THAT WAS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOOSE BILL --
TO MAKE SURE WE TEST WE FIND OUT
THE BACKLOG MY BILL TO MAKE SURE
WE DON'T EVER GET A BACKLOG
BEFORE WAS VETOED SOME WONDER
WHAT THE SECOND BILL IS YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
I'M SORRY --
I THINK THAT'S OKAY IN THE
BUDGET --
FOR THE EIGHTY THREE ONE ONE
EIGHT RIGHT.
AND THEN.
MOVE AM I SORRY SORRY I GOT IT
THAT'S THAT'S QUITE FINE WE CAN
GET FURTHER IN DOCTOR BILL YEAH
HOW GOOD THAT IS YEAH I DID.
THERE'S A LADY THAT WE DID.
TO ULTIMATELY WHAT I UNDERSTOOD
WAS THERE'S MONEY IN THIS YEAR
FOR PURCHASES OF EQUIPMENT AND
TESTING.
ON THAT WAS YOUR QUESTION YES IT
WAS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
QUESTIONS MA'AM CHAIR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THE LA
ALREADY MENTIONED THAT THE
FISCAL OUTLOOK THAT THEY
PROVIDED. FOR US IN THE FALL IS
ALREADY CHANGING AND LOWERING IT
BY ONE TO TWO BILLION DOLLARS
AND WE'RE CERTAINLY SEEING
THINGS IN THE ECONOMY.
APPLE STOCK PRICES ARE GOING
DOWN WE'RE SEEING A INVERTED
YIELD CURVE SINGLE AT SIGNALS
THAT WE'VE GOT TO BE REALLY
CAREFUL ABOUT.
SO I'M JUST CURIOUS --
HI AS YOU LOOK AT MAYBE SCALING
DOWN IF YOU NEED TO YOUR
PROPOSED BUDGET BECAUSE YOU'RE
YOU'RE REALLY GOING OUT HERE.
AND IN THE HOW HOW DO YOU SCALE
IT DOWN YOU GO LIKE 10% EACH
CATEGORY --
HERE'S PROGRAM A THAT WE'RE
GONNA DROP BABY DO IT ANY YEAR
TO OUR PROGRAM BE IS GONNA BE
ELIMINATED DO YOU HAVE A A
PRIORITY SYSTEM.
SO NOT A DIRECT SYSTEM RIGHT NOW
I THINK THE ONE THING THAT WE BE
WILL BE WATCHING FOR OTHER THEN
YOU KNOW CLOSELY MONITORING IN
JANUARY IS A BIG.
CASH MONTH AND IT'S IT'S HARD TO
COMPARE THIS LAST DECEMBER TO
THE PREVIOUS DECEMBER BECAUSE OF
THE FEDERAL TAX LAW A LOT OF
PEOPLE PREPAID THEIR PRIOR YOUR
TAXES IN.
DECEMBER SO THE DECEMBER TWENTY
SEVENTEEN REVENUES ARE MUCH
HIGHER THAN DECEMBER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SO WE'LL BE WATCHING
THE CASH SITUATION.
THIS CLOSELY I GUESS WE DON'T
HAVE A HIGHER THIS POINT THE ONE
THING THAT WILL BE LOOKING AT
WHICH I THINK YOU ALLUDED TO AS
WELL AS YOU KNOW THERE'S ALL
THESE BIG PROPOSALS BUT THEY ARE
IN THESE ONE TIME AN ON GOING
SPENDINGS.
SO ANY CHANGE IN THE REVENUE
PICTURE WERE ALSO AS WE UPDATE
OUR FORECAST CAN TRY TO GET A
SENSE OF HOW MUCH OF THAT NEEDS
TO BE REDUCTIONS IN A ONE TIME.
VERSUS HOW MUCH NEEDS TO BE ANY
CHANGES IN THESE ONGOING
CATEGORIES THAT ARE THESE
BROADER COMMITMENTS IN THERE FOR
A LITTLE BIT HARDER TO HEAR BACK
BECAUSE THAT CASCADES OVER MANY
YEARS.
ACT IT'S GREAT TO BRING IT ALL
OUT BILL I JUST GET NERVOUS
GOING OKAY WORK WHERE DOES IT GO
AS WE GET.
HARD DATA --
WE'RE GETTING HARD DATA RIGHT
NOW FOR THE SCHOOL SO I
APPRECIATE THE LA --
POINTING OUT THAT WE'RE NOT
FINDING THE PROP TO AMOUNT. FOR
THE FOR THE FIND IN YOUR WRITING
GIVING ALL THE FORMULAS --
BUT WE'RE YOU'VE TAKEN OUT AT AN
OPINION SAYING WE COULD FIND
MORE.
THEN THE MANDATED AMOUNT IN THE
GENERAL FUND RESERVES.
AB THE AND YOU DO YOU CAN YOU
ARE YOU COVERED THE AT THAT THE
QUESTION REALLY WELL BUT SHOULD
WE BE DOING --
A A LOT CHANGED TO CHANGE THE
FORMULA SO THAT THERE'S MORE FOR
THE SCHOOLS BECAUSE WE GOT L. U.
S. D. WE'VE GOT SACRAMENTO CITY --
IN I DIDN'T SEE ANYTHING IN HERE
FOR THE FISCAL CRISIS AN
ASSISTANT MANAGEMENT TEAM OUT OF
KERN COUNTY THAT WOULD JUMP INTO
A SCHOOL DISTRICT. TO HELP OUT
BUT THEY'RE READY.
AT SACRAMENTO CITY IN THEIR AT
SWEET WATER DOWN IN SAN DIEGO
AND I'M JUST WAITING FOR THEM TO
PULL THE TRIGGER ON LAUSD AND
THEN HOW DO WE HOW DO WE FINANCE
ALL THAT.
SO I'LL MAKE ONE OR TWO COMMENTS
IN AND OUT JESSICA SHOULD CHIME
IN AS WELL I THINK THE FIRST IS
YOU KNOW AS WE WERE DISCUSSING
WHEN THE MANDATORY DEPOSITS COME
FROM THAT ACCOUNT THOSE ARE
WITHIN.
PROPOSITION --
NINETY EIGHT AND SO THIS YEAR
GIVEN ALL THE PRESSURES THAT TO
MAKE SURE ALL THE MY NINETY
EIGHT MONEY GOES DIRECTLY TO THE
SCHOOLS --
THAT CAL STIRS ADDITIONAL THREE
BILLION DOLLARS THAT'S OUTSIDE
THE GUARANTEE --
AND OF COURSE YOU KNOW YOU COULD
PUT MONEY AND ARE OUTSIDE OF THE
GUARANTEE BUT AS YOU KNOW
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE WORRIED
ABOUT GROWING RISKS --
RAISING THE BASE OF THE
GUARANTEE ANY YEAR LIKE THIS --
CAN BE VERY BENEFICIAL TO THE
SCHOOLS BUT CAN COME WITH RISKS
TO THE BUDGET IN FUTURE YEARS.
COMPARE TO SPENDING MONEY AND
GETTING AT THE MONEY TO THE
SCHOOLS ALSO BUT ALSO MAKING
SURE THAT THIS BUDGET IN
EDUCATION AND ACROSS ALL AREAS
IS POISED TO WHETHER A DOWNTURN
SO WE DO WANT TO MAKE SURE TO
RELIEVE THE PRESSURE IS THAT'S
WHY YOU KNOW WITHIN OUR
PROPOSITION. NINETY A GUARANTEE
THERE'S JUS TWO BILLION DOLLARS
EXTRA FOR SCHOOLS UNDER THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
WERE ESTIMATING THAT MCALISTER'S
PAYMENT WILL GIVE SCHOOLS ON
AVERAGE ABOUT AN ADDITIONAL
FIFTY DOLLARS PER PUPIL --
SO WE HOPE THAT MAKES A
DIFFERENCE BUT IN ADDITION TO
THAT I WILL --
TURNOVER JESSICA.
JESSICA HOLMES DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THANK YOU --
SO I'LL JUST ADD ON A COUPLE
MORE THINGS AND TO IF YOU TAKE
SAID -- IN
ADDITION IT'S WITHOUT LOGGING TO
FIGURE OUT FIRST BECAUSE WE WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE MIKE FINDS
WORK AND WITH FORGETTING GIVEN
MORE STAFFING.
WE ARE IN CONSTANT CONTACT WITH
MIKE AND MISTER FINE EXCUSE ME
THE DIRECTOR OF OF THE A FISCAL
CRISIS MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE
TEAM.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT HIS CURRENT
STAFFING LEVELS NEEDS --
BUT WE'RE CERTAINLY ALWAYS IN
CONTACT WITH HIM IN AND
REASSESSING THAT --
IN ADDITION TO TO WHAT MISTER
BUSH ONE OF ON SAID --
I'D LIKE TED TO JUST POINT OUT A
COUPLE THINGS THAT'S DIFFERENT
ABOUT PROPOSITION NINETY THIS OR
THAT WE HAVEN'T REALLY SEEN IN A
VERY LONG TIME --
AND THE FIRST IS --
OUR DEARTH OF ONE TIME FUNDING
FOR PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT SO FOR A LONG TIME --
WE WERE PAYING BACK THINGS LIKE
MAINTENANCE FACTOR AND SETTLE UP
INTO PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT AND WE ALSO HAD A
LOT OF ONE TIME FUNDS THAT CAME
FROM --
ESTIMATES OF THE GUARANTEE
TURNING OUT TO BE A LITTLE TOO
LOW WHEN WE GOT OUR FOR OUR
FINAL FACTORS REVENUES THROUGH
IN PRIOR AND CURRENT YEAR --
WE'RE ACTUALLY LOOKING AT
REDUCTIONS --
IN ONE TIME FUNDING FOR PRIOR
AND CURRENT YEAR IN THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE --
INSTEAD OF INCREASES WHICH WE
HAVE BEEN USED TO SEEING --
AND WE HAVE PAID OFF MAINTENANCE
FACTOR --
ALMOST COMPLETELY AND OFF ALL OF
OUR SATELLITE.
SO A LOT OF TIMES WE WOULD USE
THAT ONE TIME FUNDING FOR ONE
TIME PURPOSES SUCH AS FOR
EXAMPLE WE COULD HAVE USED ONE
TIME FUNDING FOR PROPOSITION --
TWO PAYMENTS INTO THAT THE PROP
NINETY EIGHT RESERVE.
ON BUT THE REALLY ISN'T MUCH ONE
TIME FUNDING AVAILABLE THIS YEAR --
AND IN TERMS OF USING WHAT --
ON GOING FUNDING --
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT PRESSURES --
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS A LOT OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS BUILD THEIR
BUDGETS ASSUMING THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE FULL
IMPLEMENTATION OF COLA FOR LCS.
FIVE THAT REALLY IS A BIG
PRIORITY FOR US TOOK THE BIT OF
A BALANCE THIS YEAR IN TERMS OF
MAINTAINING ON THE FISCAL
STABILITY OF OF FUNDING FOR
SCHOOLS.
THERE'S ONE OTHER POINT THAT ALL
MAKE AS WELL --
AND THIS GOES TO A POINT THAT MS
TWO MADE ABOUT THE BALANCE
BETWEEN BUILDING RESERVES AND
MAKING PAY DOWN STATE SAVE MONEY
IN THE FUTURE.
AND THERE'S REALLY NO RIGHT
ANSWER FOR THIS RIGHT SO THAT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS THAT WE'RE
SENDING TO CAL STARS ON BEHALF
OF DISTRICTS --
YOU COULD IMAGINE A SCENARIO IN
WHICH YOU PUT THAT INTO A
RESERVE ACCOUNT WHETHER IT'S THE
P. S. S. S. A. OR SOME OTHER
RESERVE ACCOUNT AND THEN YOU CAN
DRAW ON IT IF THERE IS A
DOWNTURN IN THE NEXT YEAR THAN
SECOND OR THE THIRD YEAR --
BUT THE PAY DOWN HAS ITS OWN
BENEFITS AND I KNOW IN THIS
PRESENTATION I FOCUSED ON THE
FIRST TWO YEARS BECAUSE YOU KNOW
LIKE ALL OF US SCHOOLS WERE
LOOKING AT WHAT'S DIRECTLY IN
FRONT OF US AND HOW THEY CAN GET
THROUGH THE YEAR --
BUT REAL TWO POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IS ACTUALLY DEDICATED
TOWARD THE OUT YEARS AND IT'S
DIRECTLY DEPOSITED WITH CAL
STIRS ON BEHALF OF THE SCHOOLS.
AND IT ACTUALLY DROPS THEIR
CONTRIBUTION RATE BY HALF A
PERCENTAGE POINT SO IF THEY WERE
GOING TO PAY EIGHTEEN POINT 4%
OF PAYROLL --
INSTEAD TO PAY SEVENTEEN POINT
9% AND THAT'S IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWO THAT'S IN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE ALL THE WAY THROUGH TWENTY
FORTY SIX ONE WE ALL HOPE --
THIS UNFUNDED LIABILITY FOR CAL
STIRS WILL BE PAID OFF SO YOU
KNOW THAT.
IN A SAVINGS IN THOSE OUT YEARS
BY HALF A PERCENTAGE POINT IT
MAY SAY SCHOOLS ON AVERAGE
BETWEEN LET'S SAY A HUNDRED OR A
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR.
THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY THE SAME
AS THE THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS THAT SCHOOLS
WILL SAVE IN THE FIRST TWO YEARS
BUT THAT MEANS EVERY YEAR AND
THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE WHETHER
SCHOOLS ARE HAVING A GOOD YEAR
OR A BAD YEAR ECONOMICALLY IN
TERMS OF THAT.
STATE AND NATIONAL ECONOMIC
PICTURE THEY WILL BE PAYING LESS
TO MEET THEIR PENSION
OBLIGATIONS AND THEY WOULD
OTHERWISE HAVE TO PAY SO WE
THINK THAT THIS CAN MAKE A
DIFFERENCE OVER THE LONG TERM.
AND I FIRM THAT --
YOU HAVE ON PAGE OF FOR WE HAVE.
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
REVISED IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY PROPOSED IN THE PACKAGE
THAT WE RECEIVED.
AND THE TOTAL EXPENDITURES ARE
ALMOST THE SAME A HUNDRED FORTY
FOR BILLION AND I'M JUST CURIOUS
YOU YOU PROVIDED.
SEVEN ADDITIONS TO THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET ARE THEY ALREADY INCLUDED
IN THESE TWO COLUMNS SO ONE OF
MY COLLEAGUES CAN ELABORATE BUT
SEVERAL OF THE BIG TICKET --
ITEMS THAT WE PROPOSED IN THIS
BUDGET PAYMENTS TO CALPERS ARE
ACTUALLY SCHEDULED IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN YEARS SO THE
YEAR THAT WE'RE IN RIGHT NOW
INSTEAD OF THE BUDGET YEAR.
AND ARE THINKING FOR THAT IS IF
WE ALREADY HAVE THAT CASH IN
HAND AND CALPERS PROJECTS AND
INVESTMENT RETURN OF 7% PER YEAR
ON ITS INVESTMENTS THERE'S NO
REASON NOT TO GET THAT MONEY OUT
THE DOOR AS SOON AS POSSIBLE AND
SCHEDULED IN THE CURRENT YEAR SO
I AGREE.
IT DOES LOOK KIND OF FUNNY IN
THAT YEAR THE EXPENDITURES OR
YOU KNOW THE RIGHT MUSIC THINGS
ARE.
YOU HAVE A TWENTY ONE AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLAR SURPLUS FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR ON THE ONE HAND ON
THE OTHER THESE NUMBERS DON'T
SEEM TO BE CHANGING ALL THAT
MUCH FROM YEAR TO YEAR.
AND IT BASICALLY HAS TO DO WITH
HOW THOSE PAYMENTS ARE SCHEDULED
TO MAYBE WE COULD GET IT A
DETAILED AT YOU KNOW.
BREAK DOWN ON HOW THAT WORKS SO
WE CAN.
YEAH ASSESS THAT YES THEN THE
LAST QUESTION IS YOU DID MAKE
ANY COMMENTS ON HIGH SPEED RAIL.
IT ALWAYS SEMS TO COME UP SO I
JUST THOUGHT I'D GIVE YOU THAT
[inaudible]
OPPORTUNITIES YES.
SO THE ADMINISTRATION IS
OBLIGATED TO PUT OUT A OUTSIDE
YOUR INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN --
THAT INCLUDES ALL OF OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS --
WHETHER THERE AND RAIL TRANSIT
ACROSS ALL AREAS THEY WILL BE
PUTTING THAT OUT AT SOME POINT
LATER THIS YEAR AND CERTAINLY --
THE GOVERNOR'S PLANS HE STILL
DELIBERATING --
FOR THE FUTURE OF THAT HIGH
SPEED RAIL SYSTEM --
WILL BE IN THAT PLAN SO IT'S NOT --
THERE IS CURRENTLY AS YOU KNOW
WHAT CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION
UNDER THE CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN --
WE HAVE NOT WEIGHED IN ON THOSE
CONTINUE SUPER BUT YOU'LL
CERTAINLY HEAR FROM THE GOVERNOR
AND HIS ADMINISTRATION ABOUT HIS
THOUGHTS ON THIS OF LATER THIS
YEAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BOTH OF YOU
FOR YOUR GREAT PRESENTATIONS
APPRECIATED.
THANK YOU WILL HAVE SENATOR BAIL
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE.
MINIATURE --
THANK YOU.
FOR DURING THE HEARING AND AND I
WANT TO HISTORICALLY.
NOTE.
THAT IS VERY RARE.
THAT WE FIND THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S IN THE FINANCE
DEPARTMENT.
AGREEING ON REVENUE ESTIMATES.
AND SO SO I WAS SORT OF CURIOUS
AS TO AND WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
AND THE REVENUE PROJECTIONS.
THAT -- WE
HAVE TODAY VERSES THE METHODS OF
THE REVENUE PROJECTIONS IN THE
PAST --
BECAUSE THERE MUST BE SOME
CHANGES OR IS THERE.
ANY OBVIOUS DIFFERENCE IN TERMS
OF THE METHODOLOGY.
OR DID THE GOVERNOR FINALLY
AGREED TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S MATH OKAY SO.
I WANT TO HEAR I WANT TO HEAR --
I I I THINK WE THEN AND THEN I
THINK OVERALL THE PURPOSE OF THE
QUESTION WOULD BE.
IS THERE AN AGREEMENT ON LOOKING
FORWARD --
WITH [inaudible]
OUR ECONOMY.
AND REVENUE PROJECTIONS OF WHAT
KIND OF SCENARIOS WE CAN EXPECT
SO. TO COME UP OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL MONTHS AND HOW WE'RE
GOING TO DISCIPLINE OURSELVES.
TO TO EVALUATE THAT IN A PROPER
WAY.
SO THOSE ARE MY QUESTIONS ON
REVENUE ESTIMATES THANK YOU I
WILL JUST TAKE ONE OR TWO POINTS
AND THEN TURN IT OVER TO AJ
pOF THE REVENUE THAT THE FIRST IS
THAT MY BOSS KELLY BOSS OR THE
DIRECTOR OF FINANCE --
STARTED HER CAREER AT THE LA OUT
AS THAT HER PREDECESSOR MICHAEL
TELLING SO THEY WERE JUST AS
BEING USED AT YOU AT THE DRAFT
PARMA FINANCING THE LA --
THESE NUMBERS ARE MATCHING UP
AND IT ALMOST MAKES YOU IT MAKES
YOU CHECK YOUR NUMBERS TWICE
WHICH WHICH WE ARE KIND OF
WONDER.
SO I WAS GOING TO CHECK HIM
THREE TIMES.
USUALLY THERE'S A BIG FIGHT AT
THIS HEARING.
BETWEEN REVENUE ESTIMATES SUBMIT
NOT TODAY I THINK THERE'S A LOT
FASTER.
WHAT'S GOING ON AS AND THE
SECOND POINT I'LL MAKE --
WHICH WHICH TABLE I CAN DESCRIBE
IN MORE DETAIL AS AS MENTIONED
WE ARE FORECASTING --
SOME SLOWING GROWTH IN A REVENUE
THREE POINT 2% OR THE FORECAST
PERIOD AND THEIR NUMBER OF
REASONS FOR THIS.
FIRST IS AN EXPECTATION AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL OF A SLOWDOWN IN
GDP GROWTH ON THIS IS A FUNCTION
OF BOTH --
WHATEVER AFFECT THE AYE TAX
REFORM IN DC MAY HAVE HAD --
THEY MIGHT OF HAD A LITTLE BIT
OF ASTIMULUS OR PERHAPS EVEN A
SUGAR HIGH THAT WEARS OFF OVER
TIME NEW INVESTMENTS THAT SOME
OF THE PEOPLE WHO DROPPED THAT
BILL ANTICIPATED SO WE'RE NOT
NECESSARILY GOING TO SEE THE
GROWTH THERE.
THAT SOME IN WASHINGTON DC MAYOR
PROJECTED --
WE'RE ALSO SEEING RISING
INFLATION AND ALTHOUGH WHO KNOWS
WHAT THE FEDERAL RESERVE WILL
ACTUALLY DO IN THE SHORT TERM
FOR ITS FEDERAL FUNDS RATE THIS
YEAR -- OVER
A PERIOD OF YEARS THOSE INTEREST
RATES ARE EXPECTED TO RISE AND
OF COURSE AS ALL OF YOU KNOW
WHEN INTEREST RATES RISE THAT
RAISES THE COST OF BORROWING AND
THEN THE ECONOMY IS PROJECTED TO
SLOW.
THE LAST THING --
WHICH CAN BE GOOD FROM A POLICY
PERSPECTIVE BUT DOES IMPACT A
REVENUE IS THAT JAY AND IRAN
ASMAN SAN WHO'S OUR CHIEF
ECONOMIST HAVE ALSO PROJECTED
THAT WE'RE GOING TO SEE A LITTLE
MORE GROWTH IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
INCOME DISTRIBUTION.
COMPARE TO THE TOP --
AND THAT'S A GOOD THING AT A
TIME WHEN TO ME THAT.
DENSITY ECONOMY GO TO THE TOP
BUT AS MANY OF YOU KNOW IN
CALIFORNIA ARE TAX REVENUE
SYSTEM.
IS PRETTY HEAVILY WEIGHTED
TOWARD THE HIGHEST INCOME
EARNERS SAID THAT IT'S EXPECTED
TO MODERATE THE GROWTH OF
REVENUE AS WELL AND WITH THAT
ALTERNATIVE J..
A GOOD MORNING JAKE CHAMBERLAIN
A DEPARTMENT FINANCE --
INTO AYE A I AM THE HEAD OF THE
REVENUE S. MEETING UNIT --
SO REALLY WE'VE WE'VE BEEN
FOLLOWING THE SAME MODELS --
FIVE FIVE WAS I WAS --
IN CHARGE OF THE REVENUE AS MANY
UNITS UNDER THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION --
SO WE WERE USING THE SAME MODELS
REALLY WHAT'S CHANGED SINCE
SPRING IS THAT --
I SAID REALLY TWO THINGS ONE
ALTHOUGH THIS DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
A RIGHT NOW THE STOCK MARKET FOR
MOST OF THE YEAR HAS
ADDITIONALLY --
WITHHOLDING HAS BEEN GROWING A
LOT FASTER THAN --
THAN WE HAD ANTICIPATED SO EVEN
THE WAGE GROWTH HAS BEEN PRETTY
COMPARABLE TO WHAT WE HAD
ANTICIPATED.
WITHHOLDING HAS BEEN OUTPACING
WAGE GROWTH WHAT THAT THE WE WE
WE INTERPRET THAT HIS THAT.
MORE THE WAY TRUTH IS GOING TO
HIGH INCOME INDIVIDUALS.
WHO PAY AT A HIGHER MARGINAL TAX
RATE?
AND SO WITHOUT THAT THAT'S
THAT'S WHY ARE ARE WRITTEN FOR
CASES BEEN BUMPED UP.
BUT WE DO NOT --
LET'S NOT JOB GROWTH.
PLEASE WAGE GROWTH WAGE NOT JOB
GROWTH WAGE GROWTH WAITRESS
RIGHT YES --
AND WE DO NOT WE DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT IT IS SUSTAINABLE FOR THE
ECONOMY TO CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT.
THAT -- HIGH
GROWTH -- IN
THE IN THE HIGH INCOME HIGH FOR
THE HIGH INCOME SECTOR.
AND SO WE DO THINK THAT MORE THE
WAY TRUTH IS GOING TO BE GOING.
TO THE MIDDLE AND LOWER INCOME.
LEVELS ARE ARE MORE MORE
PROPORTIONAL SO WE DON'T.
A STRONG WE TRUTH ADDITIONALLY --
EVEN THOUGH WE HAD THE THE
STRONG CAPITAL GAINS A STRONG
STOCK MARKET THROUGH MOST OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE DO EXPECT
THAT WE DID EXPECT IT TO BE
SLOWING IT IS ACTUALLY SLOWED
MORE THAN WE ANTICIPATED SO.
WHO KNOWS WORK GOES FROM HERE?
BUT SO THAT.
THAT'S WHY EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE
BUMPED UP OUR OUR REVENUE
FORECAST BEYOND WHAT WE HAD IN --
BACK IN MAY --
IT IS INDEED WE DO ANTICIPATE
RELATIVELY SLOW GROWTH FROM HERE
ON OUT.
SO I WOULD JUST ADD A COUPLE
THINGS --
FOR CONTEXT OF THIS CONVERSATION
ONE IS THAT --
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ESTIMATES
REFLECT AN INCREASE IN REVENUES
IN THE CURRENT YEAR THE BUDGET
YEAR EITHER EXCUSE ME THE PRIOR
YEAR THE CURRENT YEAR AND THE
BUDGET YOU'RE THE ACROSS THE
THREE YEAR WINDOW.
AND IN LARGE PART THIS IS
RECOGNIZING.
REVENUE AND THE ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS THAT HAVE ALREADY
TRANSPIRED SO IT IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT SORT OF A OUT YOUR ISSUE
THERE IS SORT OF A BIT OF MORE
KNOWN QUANTITY ABOUT WHAT WE'VE
ALREADY EXPERIENCE PARTICULARLY
AS A MISTER CHAMBERLAIN ALREADY
MENTIONED IN THINGS LIKE STRONG
THROUGHOUT. TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WE ALSO SAW A PRETTY
ROBUST JOB GROWTH THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THROUGHOUT TWENTY EIGHTEEN
SO SO THERE HAS BEEN GOOD
EVIDENCE ODD TO THAT EFFECT --
I LIKE YOU CENTRE BELL WAS ALSO
VERY SURPRISED AT HOW CLOSE ARE
REVENUE --
ESTIMATES WERE --
ADD TO YOUR LAST QUESTION IN
TERMS OF PREPARING --
FOR WHAT WOULD OCCUR IF REVENUES
DID COME IN LOWER WE TO BRANDON
A RECESSION SCENARIO FOR THE
PURPOSES OF OUR OUTLOOK IN
NOVEMBER --
AND WE ARE --
PLAYED OUT TWO SCENARIOS USING
THE SAME RECESSION AND THEIR
FIRST SESSION WE USE RETURNED AT
A MODERATE RECESSION --
IT WASN'T IT WASN'T IT WAS A
SOMEWHAT AKIN TO THE DOT COM
BUST THEY'RE NOT QUITE AS AS
SEVERE --
UNDER OUR ESTIMATES IN THAT
SCENARIO --
A THREE BILLION DOLLAR ONGOING
AUGMENTATION WOULD BE ABLE TO BE
SUSTAINED --
IN TERMS OF THERE BEING ENOUGH --
RESERVES TO CONTINUOUS --
SPENDING WITHOUT MAKING CUTS
THAT SAID OUR ASSUMPTIONS --
DID --
INCLUDE AT TEN BILLION DOLLARS
OF THE SURPLUS THAT WE HAD
ESTIMATED AND PUTTING THAT INTO
RESERVE SO WE UNDER OUR AYE
DOWNTURN SCENARIO DID.
AS MAY OF A HIGHER LEVEL OF CASH
RESERVES AS COMPARED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WERE MORE
LIABILITIES ARE BEING PAID DOWN.
OKAY OKAY THAT'S INTERESTING
THAT YOU'RE STARTING TO LOOK AT
THAT I LIKE MORE.
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE SPEND A LITTLE TIME ON NOT.
THE REVENUE ESTIMATES TEAM TO ME
THE WILL DRIVE THE SPENDING
COURSE SO --
ADVENTURE I JUST HAD ONE MORE
QUESTION THE THE GOVERNOR --
A WONDERFUL --
VERY PLEASED ABOUT THE HOUSING --
ONE TIME FUNDS BUT THE QUESTION
IS -- IS THE
GOVERNOR INCLUDING.
ANY ONGOING [inaudible]
FUNDING. FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IT IN -- FOR
GOING TO HOLD YOU KNOW JUST.
STARTING TO DEBATE ON SP ONE
WHICH OF COURSE I'M FAMILIAR
WITH -- IF
WE'RE GOING TO START TO DEBATE
ON I I THINK --
IT'S KIND OF HARD TO DEBATE IT
WHEN WE'RE ONLY TALKING THIS
YEAR'S SERVE ON ONE TIME
[inaudible]
FUNDS. FOR HOUSING AND NOT
REALLY ADDRESSING THE ON GOING.
NEED FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AT OF COURSE SB ONE NINETY EIGHT
NINETY SOME PERCENT OF THE FUNDS --
IN SB.
ONE OUR FOR LOCAL GOOD WITH THE
MONEY SO COULD THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IS ACTUALLY ALLOCATED
FOR THE MAINTENANCE.
BACKLOG.
THE MAINTENANCE BACKLOG.
AND I THINK IT IS PARTICULARLY
CONCERNING THAT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
HOLDING BACK MAINTENANCE BACKLOG
FUNDS -- AND
THEN THE OTHER CONCERN IS THE S.
B. ONE REVENUE.
PROJECTIONS WE GOT A NEW STUDY.
FROM OUR ACADEMIC RESEARCH WE
PUT MONEY IN ACADEMIC RESEARCH
AND SB ONE WEEK WE'RE STARTING
TO SEE ALL THESE STUDIES --
THAT SHOWS MORE INFORMATION THE
REVENUE PROJECTIONS ACTUALLY
INCREASE BECAUSE OF THE SP ONE
REVENUE INCREASES BUT THEN AS WE
START TO HAVE.
A FEW ECONOMY IN OUR VEHICLE
FLEET IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
THIRTY FOUR MILLION.
VEHICLES WE START TO SEE MORE
AND MORE EFFICIENCY.
OF THE RIVER ACTUALLY DROP SO WE
ACTUALLY HAVE.
REALLY --
ABOUT A TEN YEAR TWELVE YEAR
PERIOD [inaudible]
OF TIME. TO ACTUALLY DEAL WITH
THE MAINTENANCE [inaudible]
REPAIR.
REHABILITATION BACKLOG WE DON'T
HAVE AN ONGOING SOURCE OF
REVENUE.
WITH THE GASOLINE TAX IT DOESN'T
EXIST IT'S FOOLHARDY EVEN THINK
THAT.
SO I I'M LOOKING.
FOR IS THERE GOING TO BE AN
EXPLORATION OF ON GOING
[inaudible]
REVENUE.
THIS NEEDED TO THE DEAL WITH OUR
HOUSING PROBLEM --
AND THAT'S THAT'S KIND OF OF THE
QUESTION.
AND IS THE LA --
HAVE COMMENTS ON THIS AS WELL.
YES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO ON THE A HOUSING
YOU ARE CORRECT THAT ALMOST ALL
THE FUNDING IN THIS BUDGET FOR
HOUSING IS ONE TIME AND ALSO
SEPARATELY I WOULD --
WOULD BE INTERESTING TO SEE THAT --
STUDY ON SB ONE WE WILL TEST
WHAT IT'S DONE BY THE MINNESOTA
INSTITUTE SO THE STATE AND WE WE
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A THE
TRANSPORTATION --
COMMITTEE HEARING.
OF TO KIND OF GO OVER
TRANSPORTATION.
FOR KIND OF A NEW MEMBER KIND OF
ORIENTATION HEARING AND AND
WE'RE GOOD WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
THE PROFESSORS COME.
AND TALK ABOUT IT --
ITS IT'S IT WAS PUBLISHED ITS --
STOP BY THE MINETA INSTITUTE.
ARE THE BEST AT PROJECTING --
THE REVENUES SO WE SEE THE
REVENUE IS.
IS NOT A LIKE AN ON GOING
PERMANENT REVENUE IS KIND OF
LIKE HOLDS UP FOR A FEW YEARS
THAT STARTS TO DROP STARTS.
TO AS YOU CAN IMAGINE IF YOU THE
FUEL ECONOMY CARS GO. TO THIRTY
FORTY FIFTY MILES.
A PER GALLON AND MORE MORE
ELECTRIC OR ARE ARE.
YOU KNOW THE TIDE OF PETERS OUT
THE GAS TAX REVENUE.
SO I'LL MAKE --
TWO QUICK POINTS AND THEN IF YOU
WANT TO ADD ANYTHING ABSOLUTELY --
THE FIRST IS WE DO HAVE --
AND MISS T MENTION FOR OUR TAX
CREDIT PROGRAMS THAT'S DESIGNED
TO BE AN ONGOING CREDIT GOT
PROGRAM THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN TAX CREDITS NOW AS
MISSED YOU POINTED OUT WE DON'T
ACCOUNT FOR THAT IN THE BUDGET
YEAR BECAUSE THE CREDITS ARE
AWARDED AND THEN THE PROJECTS
ARE.
BILLS AND AND THE OWNERS OF THE
CREDIT SEE THOSE BENEFITS OVER
TIME SO DOES COST TO THE STATE
BUDGET COM SEVERAL YEARS INTO
THE FUTURE.
BUT WE ANTICIPATED OUR BUDGET
PROVIDING THOSE CREDITS ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS --
AND AS MENTIONED THAT'S THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR --
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT
PROGRAMSAND EDUCATIONAL TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR A
NEW PROGRAM FOR MORE MODERATE
INCOME AND THERE'S LIKE A THE
FOR THE CREDIT SHOULD YOU KNOW
EXACTLY SO THAT WAY UP IN REAL
QUICK IT'S RIGHT.
UNDER THE OF A BUBBLE THIS.
RARE BURST ON THE CREDITS ITS
PEOPLE ARE READY TO GO WITHOUT-THAT'S RIGHT AND WHAT WE'VE
NOTICED IS THAT THE 9% CREDIT
PROGRAM IS OVERSUBSCRIBED BUT
ACTUALLY THIS UP 4% PROGRAM
WHICH IS A MUCH GENEROUSLY ON
NOT SO MUCH WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA
FOCUS OUR ATTENTION OVER THERE
AND WE MAY.
RUN INTO THE SAME PROBLEM IN THE
FUTURE BUT WE'RE HOPING TO MEET
SOME OF THAT DEMAND AND THEN THE
OTHER POINT I'LL MAKE --
IS -- THE
GOVERNOR'S BEEN REALLY FOCUSED
ON THESE ENHANCED INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICTS AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES OWN --
CONFORMITY WHICH WE TOUCHED ON
JUST BRIEFLY ON THAT COULD BE
USED FOR ALL SORTS IN A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT PROJECTS IN THESE
ZONES BUT THE FOCUS FOR THE
GOVERNOR IS REALLY ON TWO THINGS
IT'S ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND GREEN JOBS AND YOU KNOW
GREEN DR LEGISLATION THAT WE OF
AUTHORED --
WE AUTHORED IT.
KANSEN INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
THIS TO SB --
SIX TWENTY EIGHT BUT WE'RE WE
HAVE INTRODUCED A BILL THAT DOES
AWAY WITH THE VOTING
REQUIREMENTS.
AND IT WAS VETO LASHER A THICK
OR I THINK CENTER ALLEN HAD A
BILL AND NOT --
WE'RE GOING TO ATTEMPT --
TO REMOVE THE IMPEDIMENTS.
YEAH SO WE'RE HOPING THAT WILL
BE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND I OF I DON'T KNOW IF THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S.
AS THE COMMENTS ON HOUSING.
HOUSING ISSUES WE WILL HAVE MET
WE CERTAINLY HAVE HAD WRITTEN
EXTENSIVELY ON THE HOUSING ISSUE
WHEN WE PLAN.
TO WORK ON IN PARTICULAR THIS
ISSUE ON MAKING THE RENO TARGETS --
MORE MEANING FALL --
AS WE WORK THROUGH THE THE
HOUSING PROJECT PACKAGE BOB
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR.
AND OF COURSE YOUR USER AWARE OF
THIS AS WELL BUT YES BE TO
FINDING YOU KNOW WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE THAT IN OUR BUDGET THIS IS
A REAL ESTATE TRANSACTION FEES
YES.
THIS WASN'T MY COUPLE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS YES THIS WAS A
MY QUESTION BY YOUR REVENUE GUY.
SAID THAT.
THE CAPITAL GRAINS WAS CAPITAL
GAINS TAXES LESS THAN WHAT WE
EXPECTED FROM THAT THE
PRESIDENT'S --
LEGISLATION AND IF THAT'S THE
CASE I THOUGHT PART OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES ON WAS THESE
PEOPLE WITH THESE CAPITAL GAINS
WAS GONNA GO IN AND DO THIS
INVESTMENT.
AND AND I HAVE TO PAY CAPITAL
GAINS SO I I JUST.
IT'S HIS QUESTION I'M JUST STILL
HIS OFFICE WORK SO ON THE AND
I'LL LET J. ELABORATE ON THAT
CAPITAL GAINS UNDER --
THE OPPORTUNITIES OWNS PROPOSAL
EXISTING CAPITAL GAINS ARE
DEFERRED IF THAT MONEY IS ROLLED
INTO A OPPORTUNITIES OUT IN THE
END ABLE STILL HAVE TO PAY AT
LEAST 85% OF THAT CAPITAL GAINS
LIABILITY.
BUT IT MAY NOT BE UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY SIX FOR ALMOST TEN YEARS
ON THE NAME ONLY THE NEW CAPITAL
GAINS FROM THE OPPORTUNITIES ON
INVESTMENT.
IS SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
COMPLETELY BE ELIMINATED BUT
AGAIN THE REVENUE THAT WOULD NOT
BE UNTIL.
TWENTY TWENTY SIX MADAM CHAIR I
NOW GET TO MY QUESTION
[inaudible]
FIRE -- WELL
POWER WILDFIRE PROBLEM BIG
PROBLEM --
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A HEARING ON IT
SAID I JUST WANT TO GET SOME.
OVERALL STRATEGY BECAUSE YOU
KNOW THAT TWO HUNDRED MILLION
THAT'S IN FOR FIRE PREVENTION
THAT WAS THIS SENATE COMMITTEES
WORK WE WE CREATED AT THE CAT.
THROW THE THROWN IN FOR FIVE
YEARS AND SB NINE A ONE THERE
WERE SOME OTHER --
ASSOCIATED LEGISLATION THAT'S IN
THERE WHICH WOULD A CLUMP THE
SUPPRESSION IN THE PREVENTION
TOGETHER AND I JUST WANT TO GET
THE IDEA BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE GOING.
TO YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT LIMITED
FUNDS WE NEED TO PRIORITIZE HAS
FUNDS WERE RUNNING INTO YOU KNOW
PROTECTING COMMUNITIES THAT'S
VALUABLE MAXIMIZING CARBON
SEQUESTRATION THAT'S VALUABLE
YOU KNOW PROTECTING WHAT KEY
WATERSHED THAT'S VALUABLE SO.
WHAT'S THE WHAT THE HELL WE
GOING TO ON WILDLIFE AFFECTED --
EFFORTS HOW WE GET TO MAXIMIZE
THE EFFORT IS THERE SOME
STRATEGIC PLAN TO COORDINATE
SAID OR WE COULD DO THESE RANDOM
ACTS OF RESTORATION THROW MONEY
HERE TOO MANY THERE IF IN THE
SUPPRESSION WORLD.
IN IN THE PREVENTION WHILE I
LIKE TO SEPARATE THEM.
BECAUSE WE'LL DO IT AGAIN AND
SUBCOMMITTEE THIS YEAR TO SAY
TALK ABOUT SHINY RIDE SHINY FIRE
TRUCKS I KNOW THEY WANT YOU GUYS
HAVE THIRTEEN SHINY.
FIRE TRUCKS THE UNION WANTS
THIRTY ONE SHINY FIRE TRUCKS
WE'RE PUTTING THE HELICOPTERS
AND WE'RE DO WE DID THAT ON THE
SUPPRESSION.
BUT I'D LIKE TO SEE THAT THIS
STRATEGIC DISCUSSION IF YOU
COULD TODAY AND WE'LL TALK ABOUT
IN TWO WEEKS --
I'LL MAKE TWO POINTS IN AND TURN
IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE REALLY
BOLD AND AND NINE AND THEN I
DON'T WANT LEGISLATION THE ONE
BILLION DOLLARS OVER THE FIVE
YEARS AND THAT WAS BEFORE THE
MOST RECENT FIRES SO.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO SEEING THAT
THROUGH AND ALL THE BUDGETS TO
CALM THE MONEY THAT YOU PUT IN
PLACE AND THAT'S ALSO THAT'S
GENERAL FUEL REDUCTION EFFORTS
BUT IT'S ALSO WITH.
NOT JUST CAL FIRE BUT YOU KNOW
THE CONSERVATION CORPS AND MISTY
FOREST RECORD AND WE'RE ALSO
TRYING TO GET LOCAL COMMUNITIES
INVOLVED IN THESE EFFORTS AND
THAT'S THROUGH THIS FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR.
PREPAREDNESS GRANT BUT OTHER --
THINGS THAT PEOPLE CAN DO IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES THE SECOND
THING THE BROADER QUESTION THAT
YOU ASKED IS YOU KNOW DO WE HAVE
THAT STRATEGY HERE AND I CAN
TELL YOU THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE
AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION --
THAT ARE THINKING ABOUT THIS AND
TRYING TO THINK ABOUT HOW THESE
PIECES OF THE PUZZLE FIT
TOGETHER AND EVEN THE ELEMENTS
IN THE BUDGET --
OF COURSE THE BUDGET WAS PUT
TOGETHER UNDER SHORT TIME FRAME
BUT REFLECTS THE FACT THAT --
YEAH I GUESS BUT IT COULD BE
WHAT IT IS RANDOM BUT IT REALLY
IS AND ALL OF THE ABOUT STRATEGY
YOU KNOW YOU DO HAVE TO DO ALL
THESE THINGS BUT RIGHT NOW
MEMBERS OF THE ADMINISTRATION
ARE DEALING WITH --
P. JEANNIE --
SIGNALING A POSSIBLE FILING FOR
BANKRUPTCY IN THE NEXT FIFTEEN
DAYS AND OF COURSE WHATEVER
COMES OUT OF THAT SITUATION ON
THIS ALL OF A PIECE OF HOW CAN
WE BOTH.
PREVENT THESE FIRES FROM
HAPPENING IN MEDICAID TO RESULTS
IN THE FUTURE SO WE LOOK FORWARD
TO ENGAGING WITH YOU ON THAT
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT IS A TOP
PRIORITY FOR ALL OF US YAHOO
JUST NOTE WITH.
ALL OF P. GENIES WILLOWS THERE'S
THEY'RE PROPOSING FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION.
FOR PREVENTION AND TREAT.
CLEARING ON LAND THAT THEY DON'T
OWN THEY JUST HAVE WIRES ABOVE
IT THAT THEY'RE PUTTING IN AND
WE'RE WE'RE AT TWO HUNDRED
MILLION THAT WE HAVE JUST ON
GENERAL PREVENTION FOR ALL FOR
EVERYTHING NOT.
NOT TEAT CLEARING ANOTHER.
AREA I HAVE AS GREENHOUSE GASES --
REDUCTION FUND THE CAPTAIN CAP
AND TRADE I WILL NOTE THAT THE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN OPTIONS
CAME IN A LITTLE NORTH OF THREE
BILLION DOLLARS --
89% OF THAT WAS.
AB -- THIRTY
TWO FUNDING WHICH IS REQUIRED SS
TO HAVE A REDUCTION IN
GREENHOUSE GASES GASES --
WE CANNOT DO IT FOR OTHER WORTH
WILD --
EFFORTS I SEE THAT THERE'S IN TO
WORKFORCE TRAINING [inaudible]
LAUDABLE GOAL.
THE WIDOWS AND ORPHANS FUND IS A
LAUDABLE GOAL TO BUT WE'RE
RESTRICTED ON THE GREENHOUSE
GASES TO OUR CAP AND TRADE FUNDS
TO REDUCE ITS --
JUST FLAGGING IT UNTIL I CAN'T
BECAUSE THERE'S ALSO TWO HUNDRED
MILLION AND AB SIX SEVENTEEN
WHICH IS.
TALK AIR TOXIC IN CULTURE AIR
POLLUTANTS ONE REDUCE THOSE BUT
WE HAVE.
TO EVERY DOLLAR WE SPEND FROM AB
THIRTY TO CAP AND TRADE FUNDS
WERE REQUIRED BY LAW TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GASES SO I'M JUST.
FIGHTING IT JUST LIKE THE LA --
TO SPEAK PAY SPECIAL ATTENTION
TO THAT BECAUSE I THINK THEY'LL
BE.
INCREASED AUCTIONS FOR STATE
VERSUS YOUR ESTIMATE AND THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE DISCUSSING HOW
TO STRATEGICALLY SPEND THOSE TO
GET THE BIGGEST BANG FOR OUR BOX
BECAUSE MY COLLEAGUE TALKED
ABOUT.
THE ROAD MAINTENANCE WE HAVE
TWELVE YEARS TO DO SOMETHING ON
CLIMATE CHANGE AND I SAW SOME.
GENERAL DISCUSSIONS HERE BUT I
DON'T HAVE THE PANIC THAT I
THINK.
THE WORLD IS WATCHING CALIFORNIA
TO TAKE ACTIONS ON SO THIS IS
JUST OUR FIRST DISCUSSION.
BUT I'LL JUST MAKE ONE POINT AND
NOT IF YOU WANT TO ADD ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS BUT ON THAT
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
I'M DEFINITELY IN ACCORDANCE
WITH WHAT YOU SAID THAT IS --
SPACE SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON
PATHWAYS INTO WHAT WE BELIEVE
NEEDS TO BE A LOW CARBON ECONOMY
FOR THE FUTURE.
JUST WANT TO REITERATE THAT IT
IS NOT A GENERAL JOBS
APPRENTICESHIPS PROGRAM IT IS
SQUARE WE FOCUSED ON THE AREAS
THAT -- ARE
DESIGNED TO BE FUNDED BY THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM YEAH I WE'LL
HAVE THAT TO HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION IS JUST IS JUST TO
ACTION AS ACTUAL REDUCTIONS
RIGHT YES.
IT'S CHALLENGE.
THANK YOU I'LL GO AHEAD I'M
SORRY GO AHEAD.
OF METAL ME DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I WOULD JUST UNDERSCORE
THE FACT THAT THE AB THREE
NINETY EIGHT WHICH EXTENDED THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM ACTUALLY.
SPECIFICALLY HAD PROVISIONS.
REQUIRING A REPORT FROM THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD TO
GET AT THE SURFACE --
ISSUE OF MAKING SURE THAT THERE
ARE --
APPRENTICESHIPS IN TRAINING
PROGRAMS --
TO TRANSITION THE STATE TO A LOW
CARBON ECONOMY SO CONSISTENT
WITH THE LEGISLATURE'S INTENT AS
SPECIFIED IN A. B.. THREE NINETY
EIGHT TO BRING A JOB TRAINING A
PERNICIOUS ASPECT TO THE CAP AND
TRADE A WORLD SPACE AND I WOULD
AGREE WITH YOU BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BECAUSE A P.
THIRTY TWO EXTENDS.
TO TWENTY TWENTY AND THAT WAS
OUR DISCUSSION WITH THE GOVERNOR
AND THE PROPONENTS ON THE
CAPTURE EXTENSION WE VERY CLEAR
THAT THAT WAS THAT'S THE
LIMITATION AND AGAIN WE'LL GET
DOWN TO THE WE'D SAID JUST
WANTED.
TO POINTED OUT THAT THERE IS A
LIMITATION.
THOSE THAT EXTENSION HAPPENS IN
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
THIS BUDGET IS. NINETEEN
EIGHTEEN IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY THANK YOU
SENATOR TO ROSWELL FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR STONE AND THEN SENATOR
MCGUIRE.
SENATOR DURACELL THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR -- I
WANT TO ASK OF ABOUT THE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR SAFE.
AND CLEAN WATER --
WHAT WOULD THE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS GO FOR IT AND NOW THAT
I'M ON THE SUBJECT I JUST ONE IT
KNOWLEDGE --
THE LOTUS WORD THE WHO'S BEEN A
CHAMPION AND A HERO FOR US NOT
ONLY.
FOR ALL RULE AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS BUT ALL WORKERS SO THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE THE LOTUS --
SO -- IF YOU
COULD EXPLAIN WHAT YOU WHAT WHAT
THE TEN MILLION DOLLARS GO
TOWARDS --
IN -- BOTH
COVERAGES WELL AS UP ADDRESSING
THE PROBLEM IS IT ONE TENTH OF
WHAT'S NEEDED IS THAT HAVE YOU
KNOW FOR HOW FAR WILL IT GO.
TOWARDS ADDRESSING THE PROBLEMS
SAFE CLEAN WATER SAUL MAKE TWO
POINTS AND THEN TURN IT OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUE NOT ONLY.
ON THE FIRST IS THAT --
IT IS CERTAINLY --
DOWN PAYMENT AND THERE ARE --
TO THEIR TWO BUCKETS OF TEN
MILLION DOLLARS I THINK BOTH ARE
IMPORTANT AND NOT WILL DISCUSS
EACH OF THEM ONE IS STRICTLY FOR
EMERGENCY SUPPLIES YOU KNOW
THESE ARE COMMUNITIES THAT NEED
WATER RIGHT NOW WHETHER IT'S
BOTTLED WATER OR AND VIRGINS
TEXT WELL WATER SYSTEMS.
AND THEN WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE WATER SYSTEMS ARE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE STANDARDS
SO THAT THEY DON'T FALL INTO
DISREPAIR.
BUT THE BROADER QUESTION I YOU
ASKED IS YOU KNOW HOW CAN WE
MAKE SURE THIS IS SUSTAINABLE
INTO THE FUTURE AND THAT'S A
CONVERSATION THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE TO HAVE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE WE KNOW THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION.
HAD THAT CONVERSATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR ON HOW TO
HAVE A SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
SOURCE FOR SOMETHING YOU KNOW
WHAT COULD BE MORE IMPORTANT IN
MAKING SURE EVERY PERSON IN
CALIFORNIA HAS.
DRINKING WATER THAT IS SAFE TO
DRINK -- AND
SO YOU KNOW IT IS POSSIBLE THAT
WE CAN.
OUTLINED SOME TYPE OF FEE
APPROACH IN THE UPCOMING BUDGET
YEAR BUT WE KNOW THAT SOMETHING
THAT WILL NEED TO WORK WITH ALL
OF YOU.
FROM MATTE ONLY DEPARTMENT
FINANCE REALLY KIND OF SENATE --
ANY BETTER I WOULD JUST MAYBE
UNDERSCORE THE FACT THAT --
THERE ARE TWO BUCKETS THERE'S
TEN MILLION FOR THE EMERGENCY
SUPPLIES THERE'S ALSO TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR TECHNICAL
COLO ASSISTANCE WHICH DOWN
PAYMENT JUMPSTART OF THESE OTHER
CRITICAL TYPE PROJECTS THAT.
NEED TO HAPPEN WHILE.
WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK WITH OF
THE LEGISLATURE ON A SUSTAINABLE
ONGOING A FUNDING SOURCE FOR
THESE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
ASPECT.
IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT A LOT OF
THESE SMALL COMMUNITIES --
NEED SOME ADDITIONAL EXPERTISE.
TO OF DO THE APPROPRIATE NEEDS
ASSESSMENTS.
AND TECHNICAL WORK.
NEEDED TO TO PROVIDE THAT SAFE
DRINKING WATER THAT IS A A
PURPOSE OF WHICH SAFE DRINKING
WATER FEE.
OF COULD BE APPLIED FOR A AND SO
AGAIN THIS IS A A JUMPSTART. TO
DO SO ONGOING EFFORTS. TO AYE
AYE ASSET BECAUSE SOME YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT LIKE ONE DAY THIRD THEY
HAVE BAD WATER I MEAN WHAT
CONTRIBUTES.
TO THEM NOT HAVING SAFE AND
CLEAN WATER IN THESE AREAS AND
NOT JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE POOR.
SO.
WE UNDERSTAND WHAT IS REALLY
CAUSING.
THEM NOT TO HAVE SAFE AND CLEAN
WATER THEN WHAT ARE WE GONG TO
INVEST IN THAT'S MOST NEEDED TO
ADDRESS THE THE PROBLEM SO.
I CAN APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU
AND I'M I'M REALLY GLAD THAT
THAT'S BEEN INCLUDED --
BE STARTED TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION I THINK ABOUT THE
ECONOMY AND YOU KNOW THE FUTURE --
IT SOUNDED VERY DOOMSDAY AND
PEOPLE SEEM TO LIKE OKAY WELL WE
HAVE TO HAVE A BAD ECONOMY EVERY
TEN YEARS OR WHICH SAID THINGS
HAVE TO GO.
AS IF IT WAS JUST ON A NORMAL
BUT CALIFORNIA DOESN'T JUST GO
THROUGH WHAT THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY'S NORMAL NATURAL CYCLE
IS WE THINK DIFFERENT WHERE
WE'RE AHEAD OF IT.
SO -- I
THINK IN TERMS OF PROGRESSIVE
ECONOMIC IDEAS SO THAT.
PEOPLE ARE JUST BEGINNING TO
SAVE [inaudible]
BECAUSE IT'S DOOMSDAY IS UPON US
BUT WE ACTUALLY ON THE CONTRARY
ARE PROACTIVE IN INVESTING WHAT.%
ARE FUNDS IN WHAT WILL.
PROTECT US AND IN FACT KEEP US
IN A IN A GROWTH ECONOMY --
SO IF THERE'S ANYTHING YOU COULD
ADD TO THAT BUT THE OTHER
QUESTION IS --
HOW ALL OF THIS MONEY
CONTRIBUTES TO THE ECONOMY IN
THE WELL BEING THROUGH GOOD JOBS?
SO IS THERE A CONNECTION AS YOU
DO ALL OF THIS BUDGET --
TO HOW MANY JOBS ARE CREATED.
BY OUR INVESTMENT BY OUR
SPENDING AND THE THAT KIND OF
GOOD JOBS BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE
WANT TO DO RIGHT WE WANT MORE
PEOPLE TO GO FROM.
POOR LOW WAGE JOBS TO GOOD PAIN
MIDDLE CLASS AND UPPER MIDDLE
CLASS JOBS SO HOW DO WE
CONTRIBUTE TO ALL OF THIS
INVESTMENT I THINK.
OUR RESIDENTS ACROSS THE STATE
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW.
HOW ELSE TO MY BENEFITING NOT
JUST FROM THE SERVICE?
BUT ALSO CAN MORE JOBS OR CREATE
MORE JOBS ARE CREATED AS A
RESULT OF THIS IS THERE SOME
SORT OF CONNECTION --
ANALYSIS THERE.
HUESO LET ME --
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT BOTH OF
THOSE --
POINTS ON THE FIRST YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THAT ECONOMIC
ROSE DOESN'T NECESSARILY DIE OF
OLD AGE AND THERE'S NO FORMULA
FOR WHEN A BUSINESS CYCLE
REVERSES AND YOU KNOW WE DON'T
KNOW YOU KNOW WE ARE PREPARING
FOR GROWING RISKS BUT THE TREE
DAYS.
NOBODY KNOWS --
WHAT THE ECONOMIC PICTURE WILL
BE THIS COMING YEAR OR THE YEAR
AFTER THAT OR THE YEAR AFTER
THAT AND I THINK YOU'RE ALSO
RIGHT THAT IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
SOME UNIX FRIENDS YOU KNOW NOT
JUST THE OFT CITED STATISTICS
THAT WERE THE FIFTH BIGGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD BUT?
WE HAVE A VERY EDUCATED
POPULATION --
OUR PROPORTION OF IMMIGRANTS --
FOREIGN BORN AMERICANS IN THE
STATE IS ABOUT DOUBLE THAT
NATION AS A WHOLE ABOUT 27%
INSTEAD OF AROUND 14% FOR
AMERICA I THINK THAT'S A SOURCE
OF STRENGTH WE CLEARLY PUNCH
ABOVE OUR WEIGHT WHEN IT COMES
TO INNOVATION --
PATENTS PER CAPITA SO ALL OF
THESE THINGS WILL PUT US IN GOOD
STEAD -- I
THINK THE ONE RECESS AND YOU
KNOW WE'VE BEEN WE'VE CLEARLY
PUT.
FORWARD WHAT WE THINK IS A BOLD
A PROGRESSIVE BUDGET BLUEPRINT --
AS GOVERNOR YOU SOME SAID TO
MAKE THE CALIFORNIA DREAM REAL
ONCE MORE WE ARE STILL WANTING
TO BE VERY CAREFUL BECAUSE YOU
KNOW WE LOOK BACK TO RECENT
HISTORY AND WE REMEMBER WHEN.
OTHERS MADE SIMILAR ARGUMENTS IN
THE NINETEEN THE BUSINESS CYCLE
ON AND ONE THING THAT GOVERNOR
NEWSOME WAS LOOKING AT AND THE
LA --
POINTED OUT AND ONE OF ITS
DOCUMENTS IS THAT THE SURPLUS IS
SO BIG WE HAVEN'T SEEN A SURPLUS
LIKE THIS SINCE YOU KNOW
NINETEEN NINETY NINE OR TWO
THOUSAND AND WE ALL KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED RIGHT AFTER THAT SO
WE'RE NOT FORECASTING ANY SORT
OF RECESSION AND WE KNOW WE HAVE.
A LOT OF FRIENDS WE JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WERE CAREFUL SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE THESE
INVESTMENTS IN THE FUTURE BUT IF
SOMETHING BAD WERE TO HAPPEN
INCLUDING SOMETHING OUTSIDE OF
OUR CONTROL INCLUDING A NATURAL
DISASTER OF SOME TYPE --
WE WILL BE READY FOR THAT --
BUT ON THAT SECOND POINT THAT
YOU MENTION ABOUT JOBS IN THIS
IS A KEY PRIORITY OF THE
GOVERNOR WE TALKED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BUT
REALLY THE WAY HE'D YOU SAID IN
THIS BUDGET IS --
CRADLE TO CAREER AND HE ACTUALLY
JUST APPOINTED I DON'T BELIEVE
THERE WAS A SIMILAR POSITION IN
THE BROWN ADMINISTRATION BUT A
SENIOR ADVISER ON HIS TEAM WHO
FOCUSES SPECIFICALLY ON CRADLE
TO CAREER NO THAT'S THE JOB
TITLE.
AND SO IT'S NOT JUST MORE MONEY
FOR EARLY EDUCATION MORE MONEY
FOR K. TWELVEMORE MONEY FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION BUT IT'S HOW
ARE THESE ALL LINKED TOGETHER
AND HOW TO BE ALIGNED WITH THE
WORKFORCE NEEDS OF THE FUTURE.
ON THE GOVERNOR ALSO POINTED OUT
HE WILL BE TAKING OFFICE NEXT
MONTH BUT AS THE HEAD OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
HOW MANY MEN DON SO PROFITS THE
NEW AMERICA FOUNDATION IT'S LIKE
A LAYS HOW DO WE MAKE SURE --
ARE PREPARED FOR NOT JUST ON THE
COASTS BUT ALL ACROSS THE STATE
IN FACT TWENTY MINUTES IT WAS
THE COMMENCEMENT SPEAKER AT YOU
SEE MORE SIDE ON THIS LAST
SUMMER AND TALKING ABOUT
EXPANDING OPPORTUNITIES
EVERYWHERE.
SO THIS BUDGET IS JUST A DOWN
PAYMENT ON THAT BUT DEFINITELY
REST ASSURED THAT THAT WILL BE A
PRIORITY FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
GO FORWARD. NINETY SEVEN TWO
ITEMS AND YOU DON'T HAVE.
TO ANSWER THEM RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
I WANT TO BE RESPECTFUL OF OF
OTHER SPEAKING AND MAY BE JUST
FOLLOW UP WITH OUR STAFF IS ON
THE ISSUE OF MEDI CAL.
ON A NIGHT NOTICE THAT SOME.
EXPANDED TO ABOUT A HUNDRED
THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND
UNDOCUMENTED WANT TO SEE.
YOU KNOW.
WHAT WOULD BE THE ESTIMATES FOR
A MUCH LARGER LIKE THE ENTIRE
UNDOCUMENTED WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
WE EVENTUALLY AFTER?
COVER TWO AND A HALF MILLION
UNINSURED SO THIS IS A COULD BE
A MAJOR STP NOT JUST A GOOD
STEP BUT A MAJOR STEP FORWARD.
SO WHAT WOULD BE THOSE.
THE COST WITH A GREATER.
AND THE OTHER THAT LATER IS I
WANT UNDERSTAND BETTER THE THE
MCO TAX AND YOU MENTIONED THAT
AND IN RELATIONSHIP TO WAIVERS
WHAT THE FED SO.
I JUST WANT TO GET SCHOOL DONE
THAT AND UNDERSTAND THAT A WHOLE
LOT BETTER BECAUSE BY PASSING A
BILLION DOLLARS.
IN REVENUE SEEMS LIKE.
NOT SOMETHING WE COULD JUST DO
EASILY AND I'M NOT SAYING YOU
ARE BUT ANYWAY SO IF YOU COULD
FOLLOW UP WITH US ON THOSE TWO
ISSUES AND IF I COULD FACE AN IS
IT AROUND SO I THINK I MENTIONED
AT THE ON TO THE HEARING THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE --
FOR MORE FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE
HEARINGS AND ONE OF THEM WILL
VERY LIKELY FOCUS ON HEALTHCARE.
THE HEALTH PROPOSAL SO WE CAN
GET IN DEPTH THEN FOR THE MONEY
I KNOW YOU HAVE A QUICK FOLLOW
UP ON WATER THAT I'M SURE CENTER
STONE WILL ALLOW YOU.
TO IN THE THIRD GO HEAD THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I
APPRECIATE.
THE OPPORTUNITY I JUST WANT TO
START BY THANKING BOTH MR.
FIRST WANT ONE OF FUN IN MISS
CHIU FOR YEAR OUTSTANDING
PRESENTATIONS HOUSE WANTED
KNOWLEDGE THE GOVERNOR'S ANA.
TREMENDOUS COMMITMENT TO FINDING
A BALANCE BETWEEN PAYING DOWN
DEBT INVESTING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND PROTECTING ALL
CALIFORNIANS IT'S IT'S REALLY.
A LOT OF BRILLIANT WORK IN FOR
FIVE DAYS OF BEING GOVERNOR --
AND I WANT TO THANK MADAM CHAIR
IN YOUR TEAM FOR PREPARATION FOR
TODAY -- ON
THE FOLLOW UP ON THE WATER I
ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE DELORES
HUERTA.
IN ADDITION TO BEING A CHAMPION
FOR HIM FAMILIES SHE'S BEEN ONE
OF THE LEAD --
CHAMPIONS FOR CLEAN SAFE
DRINKING WATER NOT JUST IN RURAL
FARMING AREAS BUT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
YOU MADE REFERENCE TO THE TEN
MILLION DOLLAR EMERGENCY FUND
FOR FOR BOTTLED WATER BASICALLY --
IN THE OTHER TEN MILLION DOLLAR
FUND THE GOVERNOR REFERENCE TO
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT MILLION.
DOLLAR COMMITMENT IN THE BUDGET
SO I'D LIKE YOU TO JUST IF YOU
COULD CLARIFY.
WHAT WHAT DANCE FOR MY
UNDERSTANDING?
YOU REFERENCED ALLOCATION OF
CERTAIN BONTA MONIES ONE OF OUR
CHALLENGES IN THE FIGHT FOR
CLEAN SAFE DRINKING WATER.
BOND MONEY CAN BE USED FOR
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS BUT NOT FOR
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE OR
OPERATIONS AND MANAGEMENT.
THAT'S BEN THE BIG CHALLENGE OF
FINDING AN ON GOING REVENUE
SOURCE I BELIEVE YOU INDICATED.
IT'S IN THE BUDGET IS ONE TIME
BUDGET ALLOCATION BUT THE
GOVERNOR RECOGNIZES THE NEED FOR
AN ONGOING.
REVENUE SOURCE --
HELP ME UNDERSTAND --
THE GOVERNOR'S PERSPECTIVE ON
HOW WE DEVELOP THAT ON TIME OUR
ON GOING REVENUE SOURCE THAT'S
PREDICTABLE AND THAT CAN BE
ALLOCATED TO POOR COMMUNITIES TO
PAY FOR OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE.
OIL MAKE THREE POINTS AND THEN
BACK YOU CAN WEIGH IN AS WELL I
THINK THE FIRST DAYS FOR THIS
TWENTY TWO TEN MILLION DOLLAR
MARKETS --
THEY'RE BOTH ONE TIME AND
THEY'RE ALSO IMMEDIATE AND AS
MENTIONED WE WANT TO GET BACK AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE.
IS THAT YOU ARE CORRECT THAT ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IS FROM PROPOSITION --
SIXTY EIGHT PASSED BY THE VOTERS
IN JUNE OF LAST YEAR FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR BOND AS YOU
REMEMBER SPLIT BETWEEN BILLY
PARKS WATER AND WILDLIFE AND YOU
NATURAL HABITAT RESTORATION.
ON SO THAT'S WHERE THAT MONEY IS
COMING FROM FOR CAPITAL PROJECTS
AND THEN FOR THE ON GOING --
YOU KNOW WE HAVE IN OUR BUDGET
WE SAID WE WANT TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE --
PERHAPS ON SOME TYPE OF FEE
STRUCTURE THAT COULD PROVIDE
THIS REVENUE ON AND IT IS A FAIR
QUESTION WELL YOU'VE GOT THIS
BIG SURPLUS --
YOU KNOW WHY YOU PUT SOME OF
THAT AND BUT THE FACT IS PEOPLE
NEED SIX CHECKING WATER EVERY
YEAR RIGHT NOT JUST THIS YEAR OR
NEXT YEAR.
ON IT SO SOME THESE ONE TIME
COMMITMENTS TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE
THE CAPITAL OUTLAY DOES MAKE A
DIFFERENCE BUT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE AND WHETHER IT'S SPLIT
BETWEEN AT THE OFFICE VERY SMALL
FEE ON ALL WATER USERS WHETHER
IT'S ON PRODUCERS WERE PUTTING
NITRATES INTO THE GROUND AS PART.
OF THEIR OPERATIONS IN NINETY WE
CAN STRUCTURE THAT IN A WAY
WHERE THEIR THEY CAN BE ON BOARD
AS WELL IT CAN BE A CONVERSATION
AMONG EVERYONE.
THAT'S WHERE WE BELIEVE THE ON
GOING --
WATER THE FEE WILL BE FOUND --
BUT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WILL
REQUIRE YOU TO WORK WITH A LOT
RIGHT WELL THANK YOU IN AGAIN.
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S MAKING THIS A
SPOTLIGHT ISSUE I KNOW HE TOOK
SOME OF THE CABINET MEMBERS TO
THE COMMUNITY OF MONTEREY PARK --
COMMUNITY STRUGGLING TO SECURE
CLEAN DRINKING WATER NEAR SERIES
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY --
HE'S CLEARLY --
SHOWN THROUGH THE BUDGET HIS
COMMITMENT.
WHEN THE LEGISLATURE I THINK --
I KNOW FROM THE LEADERS OF BOTH
HOUSES ALSO SHARE A COMMITMENT
TO THIS BEING A HIGH PRIORITY.
THE CHALLENGE HOWEVER OF THE ON
GOING FUNDING SOURCE.
I KNOW WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
ON THIS WHILE THERE ARE --
SURPLUSES IDENTIFIED IN REVENUE
STREAMS -- A
QUESTION TO MAYBE EXPLORE NOT
NECESSARILY ANSWER RIGHT NOW IS
WHETHER WE COULD DEVOTE ANY OF
REVENUE SURPLUSES TO SOME TYPE
OF A CAPITAL FUND THAT COULD
GENERATE --
PREDICTABLE INTEREST TO REVENUE --
AS PART OF AN ONGOING FUNDING
SOURCE MAYBE NOT ALL OF IT BUT
AS A CONTRIBUTION. TO AN ONGOING
FUNDING SOURCE OTHER --
SOURCES OF FUNDING THERE COULD
BE A PREDICTABLE CAPITAL ACCOUNT
WERE PART OF THAT CLEAN SAFE
DRINKING WATER FUND.
COULD BE --
AVAILABLE FOR LONG TERM
INVESTMENT THAT PAYS OUT A
PREDICTABLE AMOUNT THAT COULD BE
USED FOR COMMUNITIES FOR
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE.
OPEN TO YEAR CONSIDERATION WE
WILL DEFINITELY TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT SO.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I APPRECIATE IT.
SENATOR MCGUIRE FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR STUFF THANK YOU SO MUCH
VENTURE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
EFFORTS [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
PLANES.
YOU HAVE TO DO I SWEAR TO YOU I
I DO. TO LISTEN TO THIS --
PRESSING.
MADAME CHAIR IS A BREAKING OUT
THE TWO BY FOUR TODAY YOU SO I
THINK YOU SO MUCH HIGH DAM --
ARE GONNA MAKE TWO VERY QUICK
COMMENTS IN ONLY ABOUT SIX
QUESTIONS SO I'M KIDDING FEDERAL --
FIRST WHY I WANT TO MAKE A QUICK
COMMENT.
ABOUT THE GOVERNOR --
IN HIS BOSS THERE THEY HAVE BEEN
ABSOLUTELY FANTASTIC OUT WHEN IT
COMES TO THE ISSUE OF WILD AND
FIRES --
LAKE COUNTIES HAD 60% OF THEIR
LAND MASS BURN SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND MISS
MOSLER HAS JUST BEEN AN ANGEL
AND I JUST WANNA PASS THAT ALONG
IS HOW GRATEFUL WE ARE.
NEGATIVE EMOTIONAL THINKING
ABOUT IT KNOWS THREE YEARS OF
THAT PROPERTY TAXES MEAN A GREAT
DEAL TO THEM SO THANK YOU --
ALSO ON THE NINE ONE ONE FEE.
JUST FANTASTIC ABOUT MOVING FOR
NOT BE SO WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
GET A LONG TERM FIX FOR THAT AND
I WOULD HOPE IT'S GOING TO BE A
BIPARTISAN. THIRTEEN ADDITIONAL
ENGINES GETS US A THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY SIX BACK IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE WE ACTUALLY --
HAD EIGHTEEN MORE THAN.
THREE FIFTY SIX SO I WOULD HOPE.
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO
CONSIDER ADDITIONAL ENGINES AND
THERE'S TWO REASONS FOR THAT
NUMBER ONE WHICH WE KNOW IS EACH
UNIT.
ESPECIALLY IN THE MOST
CHALLENGER THE STATE DO NOT HAVE
ENOUGH PERSONNEL TO BE ABLE TO
COVER.
NUMBER TWO BUT WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE MENTAL HEALTH OF
FIREFIGHTERS ON IT IS BECAUSE WE
HAVE FIREFIGHTERS ON THE LINE
SIXTY DAYS FORTY FIVE DAYS
THIRTY DAYS.
AND THE MORE FOLKS THAT WE CAN
PUT ON THE BETTER SO --
WE'VE HAD MILLIONS OF ACRES
BURNED SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN AND WE ARE NOT EVEN AT
ARMS NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
LEVELS --
AGAIN I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR MOVING WITH THOSE THIRTEEN
WHICH ALSO GETS HIS ULL TIME
CREW -- BUT
I THINK THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THOSE
ADDITIONAL EIGHTEEN ON WHETHER
IT IS A TWELVE MONTH COMMITMENT
TWENTY FOUR MONTH COMMITMENT
BECAUSE I ALSO KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA'S TO FIGURE OUT.
HOW TO BE A TO GET ORDERS IN HOW
TO BE A TO GET STAFF TRAINED BUT
IT'S SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH AND I
WOULD?
HOPE THAT THERE'S GONNA BE TO
SHOW CONSIDERATION AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IN THIS BUDGET PROCESS
THAT WE CAN GET BEYOND THAT
THIRTEEN AND JUST WANTED TO SEE
WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ARE.
IS THERE ANYONE SAYS WELL.
STEPHEN BENSON HER AND FINANCES
YOU SEE SIR LOOK FORWARD TO
CONVERSATIONS IN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S ABOUT THAT I
THINK WE'RE CERTAINLY OPEN TO
THOSE CONVERSATIONS --
WE'RE OF COURSE TRYING TO
BALANCE OUR INVESTMENTS IN A
NUMBER OF AREAS A FIRE
PREVENTION AND FIRE SUPPRESSION
AND SO.
AND IS IN THE ENGINES ARE AN
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION AS WELL
AS OTHER THINGS BUT CERTAINLY
OPEN TO CONVERSATION EACH YEAR
BUT HE'S GETTING TO THE BUDGET
FOR THIS YEAR AND THEN IN FUTURE
YEARS BUT OVERALL.
I COMMITTED TO CONTINUE --
AND AS THE LA --
SAD AND IN SOME WAYS IN THE
MEDIA CRITICISM BUT ALSO JUST
THE WAY THINGS ARE --
SOME OF THE STEPS THAT WE'RE
TAKING ON WHAT'S UP WILDFIRES
ARE JUST DIFFERENT THAN THEY
HAVE BEEN AND MORE RECENT YEARS
AND ARE MORE ACROSS SAID IN
TERMS OF THE PROPERTY TAX BACK
FILL IN.
SOME OF THE STEPS OBSTACLES ON
EMERGENCY SO WE WANT TO CONTINUE
THAT PATTERN WE THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT NINE AND I SEE
THAT SIGNAL AYE AYE INDIA AND
TRULY IN.
NOT JUST SAYING THIS BECAUSE
YOU'RE HERE I MEAN IT IS
FANTASTIC THAT WHAT WE SEEM FOR
THOSE COUNTIES HAVE BEEN HIT AS
HARD AND I ENTIRE DEPARTMENT
FINANCING HAS BEEN WONDERFUL
ESPECIALLY.
WHEN YOU'RE ALL SO HANDS ON AND
MAKING SURE THE COMMUTER ABLE TO
RECOVER AND?
WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK AT THE
RECORD NUMBER BAKER SAID BURN
THIS STATE SINCE?
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND WE ARE
NOT VEN BACK TO WHERE WE WERE
IN THE MID SEVENTIES WHEN IT
COMES A NUMBER OF ENGINES THAT
ARE ON THE ROAD FOR CAL FIRE --
I THINK WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
FOCUS ON THAT AND I KNOW THAT IS
COMMITMENT AND BY THE
ADMINISTRATION AND I THINK WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO GO FURTHER
THIS YEAR --
IN IS WHEN SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND I WILL TURN IT OVER TO
SENATOR STEM AND CHAIR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MY
PLEASURE.
MY COLLEAGUES --
I FIRST WANT TO APPLAUD YOU
MADAM CHAIR --
WHEN I --
CAME TO THE LEGISLATURE FOUR
YEARS AGO MY FIRST --
COMMITTEE HEARING WAS SITTING
WITH THE YOU AND YOUR
INSTITUTIONAL MEMORY AND
EXPERIENCE --
MAKES YOU THE THE THE STAR FOR
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
CHAIRMANSHIP BUT I'M I'M JUST
DELIGHTED THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE
STILL HERE AND I SEE WAS A
CONSTANT RESOURCE AS I'VE BEEN
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE.
AND SIR -- I
HAVE TO AGREE WITH US SENATOR
ROTH THAT IN THE FIVE YEARS THAT
I'VE NOW BETTER TO THE FIFTH
BUDGET I'VE HEARD --
YOU HAVE GIVEN CERTAINLY THE
MOST --
ARTICULATE --
SUMMARY OF A DOCUMENT I'M SO
IMPRESSED WITH THE GOVERNOR THIS
BEEN IN OFFICE FOR SUCH A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME TO ENCAPSULATE
HIS VISION -
FOR WHAT HE WANTS TO SEE DONE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA NOT ONLY
TODAY BUT IN THE FUTURE WAS VERY
IMPRESSIVE --
THE PRESENTATION WAS AS COMPLEX
AS MY ABILITY TO RECITE YOUR
NAME SO YOU FORGIVE ME.
I CAN'T DO THAT SO --
BIBLE REFERRING YOU RESPECTFULLY
AS SIR.
BUT IF I ME UM ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT SAW ALWAYS BEEN A CONCERN
OF MINE AND I KNOW A CONCERN OF
MANY ON THIS --
IN THIS LEGISLATURE THAT ARE YOU
DID LIEU TO TO MUCH IN YOUR
BUDGET MY I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
THEIR VOICES ARE HEARD AND
THAT'S A DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED --
OUR PAYMENTS TO PROVIDERS TO
HELP WITH US AND REGIONAL
CENTERS HAS BEEN DEFICIENT AND
AS A RESULT IN MANY OF OUR
REGIONAL CENTERS.
MANY OF THESE PROVIDERS HAVE
FALLEN OFF.
AND I KNOW WE HAVE A STUDY IS
GOING TO COME BACK IN MARCH --
AND I'M GONNA PREDICTED THAT
CITIES GOING TO SHOW THAT WE
HAVE BEEN UNDER PAYING THESE
THESE PROVIDERS AND WE NEED TO
STEP IT UP IF W'RE GOING --
TO GET THE KIND OF SERVICES THAT
WE NEED AND I'M BILLY I'M 1100%
SUPPORT OF ALL THE EARLY HER
CHILD EDUCATION PROGRAMS I
APPLIED.
THE GOVERNOR --
CERTAINLY --
FOR THAT --
BUT WE NEED TO SEE SOMETHING IN
THE BUDGET THAT IS GOING TO SHOW
THE DEVELOPMENT DISABLE
COMMUNITY THAT THEIR SERVICES
THAT THEY EXPECT AND DESERVE.
ARE GOING TO BE MADE AVAILABLE
TO THEM --
ALSO. ONE AREA THAT I'M SURE
MANY OF US HERE ABOT HIS IT AND
BY THE WAY I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE INVESTMENT IN THE HOUSE
AYE MERCER RESEARCH THAT'S
WONDERFUL THAT TAKES CARE OF ARE
GROWING ELDERLY POPULATION OF
WHICH I'M A MEMBER OF NOW --
IN THEIR TWILIGHT YEARS BUT ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE COIN WE
NEED TO SEE A SIMILAR KIND OF
INVESTMENT.
IN THE RESEARCH OF AUTISM --
WHICH IS AFFECTING ALMOST ONE
AND FORTY KIDS --
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
TRULY -- IN
EPIDEMIC PROPORTIONS.
AND I HOPE THAT AS YOU.
WE WORK FURTHER ON THIS TEMPLATE
OF A OF A BUDGET.
THERE'S ALWAYS --
A DEGREE OF CONTENTION.
WHEN YOU HAVE A CHILD IS
AUTISTIC IN A GOING TO THE
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM SUMMER WELL
PREPARED FOR THOSE AUTISTIC
CHILDREN TO COME IN AND GIVE
THEM THE CARE?
AND EDUCATIONAL --
MEANS THAT THEY NEED THAT ARE
DIFFERENT FROM YOUR REGULAR
POPULATION --
BUT THAT THE STATE NEEDS TO GIVE
MORE GUIDANCE AND MORE FUNDS TO
ENABLE THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
JUST BASICALLY.
NOT CLOSE THE DOOR ON THESE KIDS
BECAUSE INVESTING IN THESE KIDS
CAN REALLY MAN A LOT --
TO THEIR ABILITY TO THRIVE ON
THEIR OWN --
IN THE FUTURE THAT'S WHAT THE
RESEARCH --
CERTAINLY SHOWS.
SO I'D LIKE TO GET YOUR YOUR ON
THE FUNDING THE DDS COMMUNITY --
PENDING THE BAR CHAU STUDIES AS
MY FIRST QUESTION YES --
SO MAKE A COUPLE OF BRIEF
COMMENTS AND THEN TURNED OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUE AS WELL --
THE FIRST IS ON DOWN
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES --
IT'S DEFINITELY A PRIORITY FOR
THE NEW GOVERNOR IT'S SOMETHING
HE SPOKE IN A LOT ABOUT AND YOU
KNOW I COULD SAY ON MY ON MY OWN
IN A PREVIOUS ROLE I WORKED WITH
TONY COELHO WHO IS THE AUTHOR OF
THE AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES.
ACT AND YOU KNOW.
HE EXPLAINED THE HISTORY OF THE
LETTERMAN ACTOR IN CALIFORNIA
AND ALL THE THINGS THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS DONE TO BE A
PIONEER IN THE SPACE AND THAT'S
CERTAINLY SOMETHING.
THAT WE WANT TO REMAIN --
AND CONTINUE DOING --
ON THE RATE STUDY AS YOU
MENTIONED THAT'S COMING OUT --
THIS SPRING AND THAT'S CERTAINLY
SOMETHING WE WILL BE PAYING VERY
CLOSE ATTENTION TO AND WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE BUILD.
ANY CHANGES INTO OUR BUDGET AND
FORTUNATE OVER JUST WANNA MAKE
ONE OR TWO OTHER.
QUICK POINTS --
ON THE OUTSIDE MIRRORS --
IN THAT SET THREE MILLION AND
IT'S ON THE RESEARCH SIDE
BECAUSE THERE'S STILL SO MUCH
THAT WE'RE LEARNING ABOUT THE
BRAIN BUT IT'S ALSO FOR THIS
TASK FORCE THAT --
WE'RE HOPING THE GOVERNOR AND
AND MARIA SHRIVER AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES
CAN COME TOGETHER ON HOW ACROSS
DIFFERENT COMMITTEES WE CAN
BILLS RESILIENCY AND MAKE SURE.
THAT MORE PEOPLE ARE PREPARED
THAT YOU CAN TAKE STEPS TO TAKE
CARE OF WHAT THE ONES SO THAT'S
AN IMPORTANT PRIORITY AND THEN
THE LAST THING IS SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING YOU KNOW WE
BUILT IN. FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS
BUDGET BUT WE KNOW IT'S STILL
NOT ENOUGH --
WE KNOW THERE IS A RISE IN THE
NUMBER OF CASES OF AUTISM --
IN OUR SCHOOLS AND WE ALSO KNOW
AS YOU POINTED OUT THAT THERE IS
PROVIDING SERVICES BUT THERE'S
ALSO THE RESEARCH SIDE --
AND THE TIME YOU KNOW WE DON'T
KNOW WHETHER THE AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL THERE'S GONNA BE FOR THEI
SUPPORT WE HAVE TO LOOK INTO
WAYS TO SUPPORT ACROSS THAT
WHOLE AREA AS WELL.
ON IT SO SPECIFICALLY ON THE
RATE STUDY AND ANY INCREASES IN
FUNDING FOR DDS ALTERNATE OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUE.
I COULD AFTERNOON THERESA KELLER
WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
AS NOTED MULTIPLE TIME TO EXPECT
A LOT OF DISCUSSION THAT READ
CITIES RELEASED IN MARCH.
OF THIS YEAR AND AND BOTH HOUSES
AND WE ALSO WANT TO KNOW THAT
THERE WERE --
ADDITIONAL PROPOSALS IN THE D.
DECIDE SO --
BESIDES THE BEST BUDDIES
AUGMENTATION THAT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER THERE ARE --
RESOURCES FOR INCREASED EM CASO
RATIOS FIRST SPECIALIZED --
BEHAVIORAL AND MEDICAL NEEDS SO
WORKERS HAVING A LOWER CASE LOAD.
THEM. TO HELP WITH THOSE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ARE ALSO M..
INCREASED RESOURCES FOR
COMMUNITY CRISIS HOMES AND
LOOKING TO EXPAND THAT TO
CHILDREN IN THE THE DD SYSTEM AS
WELL AS ADDITIONAL MONITORING OF
SPECIALIZED HOMES OF THOSE ARE
ALREADY SOME INVESTMENTS THAT
ARE INCLUDED IN THIS GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
AND THEN AGAIN WE EXPECT --
MORE LIKE THE CONVERSATION WHEN
THE RATE STUDY HAS RELEASED.
HIS CURRENT PICK PIGGY BACK ON
THAT YOU KNOW THE THE LAST
PATIENT --
IN SONORA MY HAS LEFT NOW --
AND THERE WAS PROMISES MADE THAT
THE PROPERTY WAS GOING TO BE
UTILIZED FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE
DD COMMUNITY IS HAVE BEEN ANY
DISCUSSION WITH THE GOVERNOR
ABOUT HOW --
TO UTILIZE THAT PROPERTY IN THE
FUTURE.
RIGHT TO THE LAST --
CONSUMER WAS PLACED IN DECEMBER
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND RESOLUTIONS --
AND RIGHT THERE STILL --
FAIRVIEW AND THE GENERAL
TREATMENT AREA PORT OF L. M. UP
COMING IN THE FUTURE YEARS AND
THEIR CONVERSATIONS AROUND THE
PROPERTY CONTINUES SO I KNOW
THAT THEIR ACTIVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE COMMUNITY.
MEMBERS AS WELL AS THE COUNTY.
OKAY GREAT --
I WANT TO GO TO THE NEXT TOPIC
IS OF PHARMACEUTICALS AND I I
THINK IT'S A VERY BOLD --
IDEA FOR THE GOVERNOR --
TO AMASS OUR PURCHASES AND TO
DISCOUNTS ON BEHALF OF THE THE
STATE I WANTED TO SAY THAT I
SHARE WITH MY COLLEAGUE --
SENATOR ROTH THAT --
THE THREE FORTY THE PROGRAM IS A
VERY IMPORTANT PROGRAM THAT --
IT'S DECIMATION CAN CAN CAUSE
ACTUALLY HOSPITALS TO TO CLOSE
ESPECIALLY SMALLER HOSPITALS
THAT.
ARE BOTH IN --
CENTER RAS DISTRICT IN MY
DISTRICT AND IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SO WE WE STAND UNITED AND HOPING
TO PRESERVE THAT THAT PROGRAM --
BUT YOU'RE SAYING I ALSO DON'T
WANT YOU TO RECREATE THE WHEEL
BECAUSE THERE IS A MECHANISM OUT
THERE ALREADY.
BAD CAN --
GET THE ATTENTION --
CERTAINLY OF THE DRUG COMPANIES
AND MAYBE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA JUST FORM ITS OWN P.
B. THIS THAT OUR NEXT THE
DISCOUNTS THE DRUG COME.
UNFORTUNATELY THEY DON'T ALWAYS
THIS IS.
FOR THESE --
MULTI BILLION DOLLAR COMPANY IS
SET TO TAKE TAKE THE MONEY AND
YOU KNOW --
PROVIDE GOOD RETURNS FOR THEIR
FOR THEIR SHAREHOLDERS HIM WANT
ONE COMPANY ALONE HAS OF THE
MARKET VALUE OF FORTY SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS.
I'LL GUARANTEE THE NOT GETTING
FIFTEEN CENTS A CLAIM FOR A
PRESCRIPTION IT IS TRANSMITTED
THROUGH THAT.
THAT HUB IF YOU WILL TO THE PBM
ACTS AS A HUB EVERY PRESCRIPTION
GOES THROUGH THAT HUB. TO ALL
THE DIFFERENT --
INSURANCE COMPANIES AND HAVE TO
PAY THE PRICE SO YOU MAY LOOK AT
THE MODEL OF THE PBM FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS A WAY TO
EXPEDITE THE POSITIONING OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
TO GET INTO --
THE BUSINESS OF PROVIDING --
THE COST OF MEDICATIONS IT'LL
LOWER PRICE FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS --
I'M A VERY STRONG SUPPORTER OF
OF CLEAN WATER FOR EVERYONE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS
AN ONGOING COST OF THAT BUT WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE BUDGET SURPLUS
THAT WE HAVE THE CASA PROVIDING --
THE BOTTLE WATER WHICH I THINK
IS VERY IMPORTANT AND ULTIMATELY
FINDING THE ETIOLOGY OF WHAT'S
CAUSING THE PROBLEMS IN THE
SPECIFIED AREAS OF THE STATE AND
THEN COMING UP OF TH CAPITAL
BROUGH PLAN. TO FIX THEM WHETHER
IT'S A JOINING THEM TO DIFFERENT
WATER DISTRICTS AND INCENTIVIZE
IN THE WATER DISTRICTS PROVIDE
THAT CLEAN WATER.
MY POINT HERE IS THAT IT IS
IMPORTANT BUT I THINK THAT.
YOU KNOW IN A STATE WHERE WE
HAVE THIS MINIMAL COST IN
COMPARISON TO OUR STATE BUDGET
TO FIX THIS PROBLEM IS THE
MINIMUS.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT MANY OF
OUR CITIZENS ESPECIALLY IN MY
DISTRICT THEY'RE JUST TAX
FATIGUE.
AND WHEN HE HEARD ABOUT IT WATER
TAX -- THE
IF THEY FLIP OUT IS A REALLY
ANOTHER TAX THAT WE HAVE TO
CONTEND WITH --
WE HAVE BEEN --
CHARGING TAXES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT WERE --
IT IN RECENT YEARS THAT WERE
PROMISED TO BE TEMPORARY THAT
BECAME PERMANENT SO WE HAVE A
GOOD STRONG TAX REVENUE IT WOULD
BE GREAT FOR THIS GOVERNOR
DIMMED. TO SOMEHOW TAKE A
LEADERSHIP ROLE SO YOU KNOW OUR
CITIZENS ARE TAX ENOUGH WE ARE
GOING TO PROVIDE THIS THE WATER
AND GUARANTEE THAT EVERYONE IN
CALIFORNIA GETS CLEAN WATER.
AND WE'RE GONNA INSURED THROUGH
MONEY THAT IS DEDICATED --
THROUGH THE GENERAL FUND I HOPE
THAT THE GOVERNOR WILL DO THAT
AND THEN LASTLY.
I WANT TO APPLY THE GOVERNOR
ONCE AGAIN --
BECAUSE MANY OF US OR MAYBE USE
A QUESTION MARK FOR MANY OF US
WE DIDN'T KNOW IF HE WAS GOING
TO BE THE THE FISCAL HAWK YOU
WILL THAT THE GOVERNOR BROWN
SHOWED HIMSELF TO BE AND AND I
HAVE TO APPLAUD HIM AS HE IS NOW
DEPARTED. FOR THE ROOT ROBUST --
FUNDS THAT WE HAVE IN OUR IN OUR
RESERVES IN THE EVENT A OF AN
EMERGENCY --
SO I I WANT TO SAY HOW MUCH I
SUPPORT THE THAT THE THE MONEY
THAT IS GIVEN TO STIRS UP AND
23% OF POTENTIALLY THERE.
A REVENUE IS GONNA BE THE
PENSIONS AND OVER WHAT THAT
MONEY GOING TO THE CLASSROOM AND
CERTAINLY GOING --
TO KERR'S --
THREE BILLION DOLLARS THIS
ADDRESSES THE SYMPTOMS IT
DOESN'T ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS SO
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE TAKING
BECAUSE WE'RE PUTTING IT ON A
WOUND FOR PATIENTS GOT ANTI
COAGULANT THERAPY.
AND HAS NO WAY TO CLOT RIGHT
CERTAINLY --
CENTER PAN UNDERSTANDS WHAT I'M
SAYING WE NEED TO PROVIDE A BILL
THAT'S GOING TO COST AND CLOUDY.
AND THE WAY THAT WE WE WE MAKE
THAT KILLED ACOSTA CLOTTING AS
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A PENSION
SYSTEM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT WORKS FOR THE
WORKERS.
BUT DOESN'T BECOME AN ONGOING
LIABILITY FOR THE CITIZENS OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND IT NEEDS TO BE A BIPARTISAN
SOLUTION SO I HOPE THAT THE
GOVERNOR SEES THIS IS --
STOPPING UP UP UP AN ACUTE
PROBLEM BUT THERE ARE SOME
CHRONIC ISSUES THAT ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO TO LINGER ON IF WE
DON'T ADDRESS.
SOME TYPE OF PENSION REFORMS
THAT ARE TRUE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THAT EVERY YEAR --
WE DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THE
STOCK MARKET HAVING LIKE A
DECEMBER THAT IT HAD AND
WONDERING LIKE I HEARD SOMEBODY
SAY THAT.
PURSE LOST TEN BILLION ONE DAY
IN DECEMBER AND IT'S A LOT OF
MONEY -- WE
NEED TO HAVE A MORE STABLE --
MECHANISM OF ENSURING THAT OUR
RETIREES GET WHICH PROMISE OF
THEM BUT IN A WAY IN WHICH WE
CAN AFFORD AT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I HOPE THE GOVERNOR
WILL BE OPEN TO THAT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
SENATORS STERN FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR PAN FINISH STERN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
AND THANK YOU MISTER VISWANATHA
AUTONOMOUS CHIU FOR AN EXCELLENT
PRESENTATION --
PRETTY GOOD FOR YOUR FIRST AT
BAT -- I I
WANT TO DO RES.
A STRUCTURAL ISSUE THAT THAT A
LINE WAS SOMEWHAT MY COLLEAGUES
ALREADY BEEN TALKING ABOUT --
TERMS OF RISK AND LONG TERM
LIABILITIES IN THIS BUDGET.
I REALLY PPRECIATE THE EMPHASIS --
ON TRYING TO BUY DOWN SOME THOSE
DEBTS AND LIABILITIES I THINK WE
YOU KNOW ROUGH NUMBERS WERE
PUTTING --
YOU KNOW TWENTY BILLION ALMOST
IN THERE'S ABOUT TWENTY SEVENTY
FIVE BILLION LEFT IF YOU IF YOU
ADD IT ALL UP FOR TWITTER
SEVENTY TWO DEPENDING ON HOW YOU
DO THE MATH --
IN OUR DEBT RATIO IS STILL --
RATHER HIGH COMPARED TO OTHER
LARGE POPULOUS STATES MAY THINK
ONLY NEW YORK AND ILLINOIS ARE
HIGHER BUT BUT WE'RE MAKING
WE'RE CHIPPING AWAY AT IT --
BUT THE WAY THE WAY THIS BUDGET
CATEGORIZES.
THE CLIMATE CHANGE LIABILITY --
I I WOULD I WOULD COMMEND YOU.
TO THINK ABOUT HOW TO REORGANIZE
THAT THINKING BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WE WE SORT OF LIST DISASTER
RELATED EXPENSES AS AS A
DIFFERENT KIND OF LIGHT ITEM.
BUT AS YOU YOURSELF SAID.
THE DYNAMIC GENERAL FUND IMPACT --
WE WE KEEP INCURRING THESE MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR --
COSTS YEAR AFTER YEAR WITH THE
SFE YOU AS TO SORT OF RESPOND WE
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT'S COMING
WHEN IT'S COMING.
AND IT EATS INTO OUR BIGGER
PRIORITIES WHICH I THINK ARE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
ALL THE INVESTMENT HIGHER
EDUCATION --
HEALTH CARE.
THESE ARE THESE YOUR EXPENSES
THAT ACTUALLY PAID DIVIDENDS IN
THE END A YIELD SAVINGS I I IG I
WOULD ALSO SAY THOUGH THAT.
THESE INVESTMENTS IN BOTH
CLIMATE CHANGE MEDICAID STIR
SUPPRESSION ALSO HAVE SOME OF
THOSE SAME ELEMENTS RIGHT SO.
I'M WONDERING AS WE LEAD UP TO
SAY THE NEXT FULL BUDGET HEARING
MORE WE DIVE DEEPER INTO THE
WILD FIRE ISSUE.
IF WE CAN KIND OF SCOPE JUST
PULL BACK THE SCOPE A LITTLE BIT.
AT KIND OF CHANGES EMERGENCY IN
THE STATE.
AND IT'S BOTH THE HUMAN
EMERGENCY IN A AND A FISCAL
EMERGENCY --
AND YOU KNOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
MAYBE A TWO BILLION DOLLAR
PROJECTION FOR THIS YEAR LAST
YEAR PROPERTY LOSS ALONE ON
WE'LL SEE I MEAN ON ON ON THOMAS
AND AND AND SOME OF THE OTHER
FIRES WE WERE.
ABOUT --
TWENTY WE DON'T KNOW WHAT IT'S
GOING TO STACK UP TO THIS YEAR I
WAS INSURANCE WILL COVER SAMAN
FEMA HAS A ROLE.
BUT HAS THERE BEEN SORT OF ANY
EFFORT. TO QUANTIFY THE TOTAL
LIABILITY --
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE SAME WAY WE SURE TO DO THAT
FOR OTHER DEBTS AND LIABILITIES
AROUND CLIMATE CHANGE RISK WRIT
LARGE AND I WOULD JUST.
I WOULD ASK IF IF NOT I KNOW
WE'VE DONE IT SOME CLIMATE
ASSESSMENTS OVER THE YEARS I
BELIEVE WE FINISHED OUR FOURTH.
LAST YEAR.
IT'S THE DOCUMENT A SCIENTIFIC
IN NATURE.
BUT NOT FISCAL IN THE SAME WAY
THAT IT REALLY OPERATES THROUGH
DO F..
I'D LIKE TO SEE THOSE
CONNECTIONS GET MADE MORE
CLEARLY BETWEEN THAT RISK
ASSESSMENT A SORT OF SCIENTIFIC
IN AND ENVIRONMENTAL LEVEL AND
AND AND THE FISCAL --
AND I'M WONDERING WHETHER WE CAN
SORT OF PUT SOME EFFORT INTO IT
EITHER THE LA --
OR DO AT FOR BOTH --
TO BE HE LOOKS LIKE AN M..
BEFORE YOU ANSWER I JUST THE THE
ONE CONCERN I DO HAVE AND I I
DON'T WANT YOU TO THINK THIS IS
HAZING BECAUSE THIS IS I'M A
ROOKIE TO STILL BUT IT DIDN'T
CONCERN METHAT.
EVEN JUST THE OPENING OF THE
RESOURCES SECTION OF THE BUDGET
I'M LOOKING AT THE SUMMARY.
WE'RE COPY AND PASTING FROM LAST
YEAR LIKE DO YOU LOOK AT THE
PAGE NINETY FIVE NINETY SIX IT
ACTUALLY IS OUTDATED LIKE IT WAS
SAYING.
YOU KNOW IF IF APPROVED BY
VOTERS IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS P.
FIVE WOULD AUTHORIZE FOR BILLION
IN GENERAL OBLIGATION BONDS WILL
THAT PASSED THAT WAS.
PROP SIXTY EIGHT WHEN THAT
MONEY'S HERE THEY MINISTRATION
WILL CONVENE TARGET DISCUSSIONS
WITH STAKEHOLDERS EARLY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ABOUT CRIME RESILIENCY
AN ADAPTATION --
IT'S TWENTY NINETEEN SO I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT MORE JUGGLING --
BUT THIS A BIG DEAL AND MATT I I
DON'T WANT TO BECAUSE IT TOO
MUCH CONSTERNATION BUT WE GOT TO
UPDATE OUR PLAN HERE AND
RECOGNIZE.
THAT THIS IS AN EMERGENCY THAT
REQUIRES THAT KINDA DILIGENCE
AND HE HAS SAID JUST COMMENTS ON
HOW TO SORT OF SCOPE THAT
LIABILITY AND THEN.
MAYBE A AN EDIT THEIR SO I'LL
MAKE A COUPLE OF BRIEF COMMENTS
PLEASE.
I CAN WAIT AS WELL SO YOU ARE
RIGHT THAT WITH RETIREMENT
LIABILITIES AND WE HAVE A VERY
ACTUAR WE DEFINE SYSTEM FOR HOW
LONG PEOPLE ARE GOING TO LOOK
WHAT OF LIFE EXPECTANCY IS WATER
INVESTMENT RETURN RATE IS HOW
WE'RE DISCOUNTING THOSE
LIABILITIES. TO THE PRESENT AND
WHAT THEIR FINAL COMPENSATION
WILL BE OVER A THREE YEAR PERIOD --
THAN WITH THE OPERATOR SO WE CAN
MODEL ALL THAT AND YOU ARE
CORRECT THAT AT THE STATE LEVEL
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT BROADER
CHANGES IN TERMS OF BOTH
ADAPTATION AS WELL AS FOR
CASTING WITH THE IMPACTS BE ON
PEOPLE.
WE DO NUMBER OF THOSE REPORTS
BUT IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
APPEAR IN OUR BUDGET SUMMARY ON
A TABLE --
THE WAY RETIREE LIABILITIES DO
ADMINISTRATION IT CERTAINLY
WASN'T THE LAST ADMINISTRATION --
SINCE SOME WAYS WERE FOLLOWING
IN HIS FOOTSTEPS AND IT MIGHT BE
DROWNED OUT JUST BECAUSE IT WAS
ALONG WITH NUCLEAR PROLIFERATION
YOU KNOW ONE OF SINGLE TO ISSUES
THAT.
HE'D USE I ADVISED YOU CORRECTLY
THAT REALLY FRIGHTENED NEAR
HUMAN EXISTENCE ON THIS PLANET
ON BUT THIS IS A BIG PRIORITY OF
THE NEW ADMINISTRATION ONE OTHER
PERSON I MENTIONED MY NAME AND
DANCE ON THE ECONOMIC SIDE.
ON THE CLIMATE SIDE WE HAVE CAKE
COURT AND COMING AND COMING AND
TO HAVE THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH IN.
THAT OFFICE HAS BEEN USED BY
MULTIPLE GOVERNOR'S IN DIFFERENT
WAYS OVER DIFFERENT
ADMINISTRATIONS --
BUT IN GOVERNOR BROWN'S OFFICE
WE HAD CAN OUR ACTS WHO WAS VERY
BIG ON CLIMATE AND TRAVELING.
WORLDWIDE AND HERE WITH KATE
CORD AND SHE HAS A BACKGROUND
WORKING AT NEXT GEN CLIMAX SHE
WORKED AT THE PAULSON INSTITUTE
WHICH ACTUALLY PUT OUT I BELIEVE
THAT.
KEY QUANTIFICATION REPORT --
WITH SOME FINANCIAL HEAVY
HITTERS AND TING FALSE AND
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG AND OTHERS --
SO SHE HAS THAT KIND OF
BACKGROUND TO SEE HOW WE CAN
QUANTIFY SOMEBODY'S RISKS ARE SO
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT CERTAINLY
GOING TO BE A PRIORITY GOING
FORWARD.
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN WORK WITH
YOU AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE ON OTHER WAYS WHERE
WE CAN MAKE THAT RELY ON ONE
THING THAT WE CERTAINLY.
AGREE WITH GOVERNOR BROWN --
IS WHERE PEOPLE SAID WELL YOU
KNOW YOUR EFFORTS TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS THEY'RE IMPORTANT BUT
DON'T.
ON ANOTHER CONTENT THANKS SO
MUCH INTO THIS AND HE SAID THIS
IS THREATENING ALL OF US IF WE
DON'T ACT WHO WILL WE HAVE TO
REAP THE WAY.
AND IF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
DOESN'T STEP UP STATES WILL DO
THAT AND THAT'S CERTAINLY A
PERSPECTIVE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE IN THIS ADMINISTRATION
THANK -- IN
REGARDS TO YOUR SPECIFIC
QUESTION ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET SUMMARY WE ACTUALLY
DIDN'T HAVE A SEPARATE --
NATURAL RESOURCES SECTION IN OUR
BUDGET SUMMARY IN FACT IT WAS
MERGED INTO EMERGENCY RESPONSE
AND PREPAREDNESS WHILE THE CAL
FIRE IN CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS ITEMS WERE MERGED INTO THE
BROADER ISSUE SO.
I I CAN'T SPEAK TO WHAT DOCUMENT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT BUT I'M PRETTY
SURE -- IT
WASN'T IN IN THAT SUMMER.
OKAY.
I GUESS THE POINT SORT OF MORE
BROADLY IS. TO TO CONSIDER.
THIS SORT OF EMERGENCY RESPONSE
AND EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS IN
THE CONCERT IS SORT OF BROADER
INTEGRATED --
AND CLIMATE RISK MITIGATION
BECAUSE MY CONCERN IS.
THAT I I'M IN OUR MENTALIST BUT
I I WANT TO TAKE CARE OF ALL THE
PEOPLE LIVING IN POVERTY IN THIS
STATE AND SUFFERING AND AND IF
THESE COSTS KEEP.
JUMPING OUT AT US.
THEY'RE GONNA EAT OUT FOLLOW.
THE HEALTH CARE AND HUMAN
SERVICES HOLE AND I THAT THAT'S
WHEN PEOPLE REALLY GET THAT'S
EXACTLY RIGHT AND SO --
AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE THE
COMPREHENSIVE INTEGRATED
APPROACH ON THE CAL FIRE SITE IS
WE TALK ABOUT FIVE PREVENTION IT
CHECKS A BUNCH OF BOXES. ONE IS
THE CARBON SEQUESTRATION
BENEFITS OF HAVING A HEALTHY
FORCES ARE A CARBON.
NET CARBON --
THINK OF IT AS OPPOSED TO A
CARBON EMITTER AND THAT'S WHY
INVESTING IN THE FIRE PREVENTION
HEALTHY FORESTS.
NOT ONLY MAKE SENSE FROM A
PUBLIC SAFETY PERSPECTIVE BUT
ALSO FROM A BROADER CLIMATE
PERSPECTIVE --
AND THEN OF COURSE THE
INVESTMENTS --
IN FIRE PROTECTION --
TO REDUCE THE RISK OF
CATASTROPHIC FIRES ADDITIONAL
ENGINES.
YOU KNOW TO THE EXTENT THAT YOU
CAN.
HAVE A MORE ROBUST INITIAL
ATTACK THAT PREVENTS THE FIRES
FROM BECOMING CATASTROPHIC AS
WELL WHICH ALSO HAS CLIMATE
BENEFITS AS WELL AS THE PUBLIC
SAFETY SO I THINK WERE
ABSOLUTELY ON THE SAME PAGE IN.
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT THESE THINGS IN A HOLISTIC
AND INTEGRATIVE MANNER THANK YOU
AND MISS YOU DID ANY COMMENTS
HAVE YOU GUYS LOOKED AT THAT.
THAT ISSUE SORT OF JUST TRYING
TO QUALIFY BASED ON THE LAST
FIVE YEARS WE WERE TO PROJECT
OUT AND SAY INTO. TEN TWENTY
YEARS AHEAD WHAT ARE WE LOOKING
AT WHAT WE FACING WITH THE BILL
GOT MY COLLEAGUES HERE WHO ARE
COMING UP I THINK CAN COMMENT.
ON THAT MORE SPECIFICALLY TO MY
KNOWLEDGE WE HAVEN'T DONE SORT
OF THAT HOLISTIC --
ACOSTA COUNTY THAT YOU'RE
REFERENCING BUT OKAY RANKING
OFFER MORE.
GOOD MORNING BRIAN BROWN WITH
THE ANALYST'S OFFICE A KNOW IT
MISS HE SAID WE HAVEN'T DONE
THAT KIND OF ANALYSIS AND IT IS --
YOU ALLUDED TO HIS FINANCE SPOKE
TO THIS OF THE VERY COMPLICATED
TYPE OF ANALYSIS BECAUSE YOU
HAVE TO THINK --
BOTH ABOUT THE RANGE OF TYPES OF
DISASTERS THAT CAN.
THAT CAN OCCUR BECAUSE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE OF THINKING BOTH
ABOUT.
WILDFIRES HE SPOKE ABOUT BUT
ALSO SEALEVEL RISE AFFECT SOME
FLOODING --
INCREASED DEATH AND IT --
RELATED --
TO INCREASED NUMBER OF EXTREME
HOT DAYS THE WHOLE RANGE OF
AFFECTS IT CAN HAPPEN BECAUSE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE EACH ONE OF THOSE.
HAVING EFFECTS ON DIFFERENT
POPULATIONS DIFFERENT SEGMENTS
OF THE STATE --
DIFFERENT TYPES OF
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE HAVEN'T
KNOWN IN THE TO OPERATE AND
MAINTAIN FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE
THE STATE AS A WHOLE.
IN SO THAN TRYING TO THINK MOST
ABOUT RENTAL COST TO MITIGATE
THOSE EFFECTS AND IN THE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF THE DIFFERENT
EVENTS HAPPENING SO.
WE CAN CERTAINLY WORK WITH --
THE ADMINISTRATION AND SEE WHAT
INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE AND
INTO A REPORT BACK TO YOU A VERY
COMPLICATED ANALYSIS SO THEN I
RECOGNIZE IT'S NOT THE SAME
THING IS A TRADITIONAL SORT OF
COST ACCOUNTING EXERCISE RIGHT
BECAUSE THERE'S RISK BUT THEN WE
DON'T KNOW WHEN IT'S GOING TO
RAIN OR WHEN.
IT'S GOING TO BURN BUT GIVING US
BALL PARKS YOU KNOW WE WITH
WHETHER TIME AT TWO HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS A TRILLION
DOLLARS LIKE THE ORDERS OF
MAGNITUDE THAT THAT WOULD REALLY
BE HELPFUL SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE AND LOOK FOR TO WORK
WITH YOU ON THIS.
THANK YOU SIR CENTER PAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I KNOW
THAT IT'S GETTING LATE TODAY I I
I DO --
ACTUALLY IT'S INTERESTING THAT
THE FIRST TIME I'VE HEARD THAT
THEY CLOTTING CASCADE THE AN
ANALOGY FOR PENSIONS CHALLENGES
SO THAT'S KIND OF COOL --
I'VE FOR SO I WHAT THAT
CERTAINLY WANT THANK --
BOTH -- MR
HISPANA THEN AND SHOE FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS --
SO IT WILL BE DELVING MUCH MORE
DEEPLY INTO THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES PIECES AND SUBCOMMITTEE
AND I'M NOT GOING.
TO GO THROUGH A WHOLE LIST OF
WONDERFUL THINGS THAT SHEET THAT
PRESENTATION --
WHAT?
SOME I GUESS WHAT I WANTED TO
TOUCH ON A LITTLE BIT IS --
SIR STRUCTURALLY SO FIRST OF ALL --
I APPRECIATE THAT YOU WERE
LOOKING AT IN TERMS OF ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S
DONE THERE --
WITH THAT BEING SURE THAT --
WE STILL MAINTAIN RESERVE SO I
AM VERY CONCERNED ABOUT.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT STOCK MARKET
THE GOVERNMENT SHUT DOWN THE
WHITE HOUSE ITSELF ADMITS THAT
ITS THE --
POINT 1% OF GROWTH OFF EVERY
WEEK AND WERE HALFWAY YEAH WE'RE
WE'RE LIKE HOW MANY WEEKS NOW.
FIVE SO THAT'S POINT FIVE YOU'RE
GONNA HEAD OUT IF THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN IS GOING TO BE 1% SEND
MAIL AND AND MAYBE MORE THAN
THAT AND THAT'S THAT'S NOT GOOD --
FOR ANYONE AND INCLUDING US --
AND PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING
CERTAINLY I THINK WE'LL AND
WE'LL DEAL THAT WE GET TO THE
MAY REVISE I'M SURE AS WELL SEE
WHERE WE ARE.
BUT THE OTHER THING ALSO ONE
MAKE NOTICES AS WE LOOK AT OUR
BUDGET YOU KNOW WE HAVE WHAT
WE'RE ALLOCATING THE GENERAL
FUND BUT ALSO FEDERAL MATCHING
FUNDS RATES --
WE GET 70% OF THE HEALTHCARE
DOLLAR --
FROM --
REALLY FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS MATCHES FOR THINGS
THAT WE DO AND AND I THINK YOU
MADE REFERENCE TO THAT THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE REPLY FOR WAIVERS
AND SO FORTH.
SO I GUESS SO COUPLE THINGS AND
RELATED TO THAT AND LOOKING AT
PARTICULAR ON THE HOUSE PRIDE
MORE SO IN THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AYE PAGODA HEALTH SIDE
TERMS OPPORTUNITIES FOR DRAWING
DOWN MORE FEDERAL MONEY SO ONE
COURSES THE MTO TAX YOU
MENTIONED.
THAT LEASE IN THIS BUDGET --
AT LEAST RIGHT NOW THERE ISN'T A
PROPOSAL TO RENEW THAT --
I HOPE WE CAN HAVE MORE OF A
DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT THINK WAS
MENTIONED THERE'S THERE'S A LOT
OF MONEY ON THE TABLE PER SE --
THERE THAT --
PERHAPS WE SHOULD TALK ABOUT
THERE MIGHT BE SOME INNOVATIONS
THAT WILL ALSO CHIEF.
I THINK OUR SHARED GOALS TO TRY
TO EXPAND --
ONLY ACCESS BUT ALSO IMPROVE
QUALITY THERE THAT WE MIGHT
THINK ABOUT --
THAT WOULD ALSO BE IN LINE WITH
WHAT --
MAYBE ENHANCING OUR CHRONIC
DISEASE CARE OR SOMETHING ALONG
THOSE LINES --
THE OTHER THING I ALSO BY MAKE
NOTES I APPRECIATE --
THE EMPHASIS ON MENTAL HEALTH IN
HIGHER EDUCATION I UNDERSTAND
GOVERNOR PUT MONEY IN FOR YOU
SEE -- BUT
ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT.
WE HAVE CSU AND COMMITTEE
COLLEGES WHO ACTUALLY HAVE EVEN
FEWER MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCE IN
TERMS OF STAFFING AND SO FORTH --
THAT WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT HOW
ALSO -- WE
INTEGRATE WITH OUR COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH MANY OF THESE --
STUDENTS PROBABLY ARE I MEAN
THEY'RE NOT MAKING A LOT OF
MONEY THEY'RE PROBABLY ON MEDI
CAL AND HOW WE COULD LEVERAGE --
AGAIN ARE MEDI CAL PROGRAM TO
HELP -- DRAW
DOWN FEDERAL MONEY TO HELP
SUPPORT EXPANSION OF MENTAL
HEALTH.
SERVICES --
IN OUR HIGHER EDUCATION SO THINK
ABOUT -- OUR
COMMUNICATORS AND ALL SOURCE --
BUT ALSO --
CS USES WELL AND AGAIN THE
GOVERNOR'S INITIATIVE PUT MONEY
INTO -- YOU
SEE.
THE OTHER WHAT I ALSO WANT TO
MENTION IS IS THAT --
BALL LET'S PUT IT THIS WAY RIGHT
NOW -- IS
MADE REFERENCE --
TO WE HAD A STRIKE DOWN LA S. T. --
AND I THINK PEOPLE MAKE NOTE
THAT -- THE
ISSUE ISN'T ENTIRELY SALARY IT'S
ACTUALLY HE CLASS SIZE BUT THEN
ALSO SUPPORT STAFF SCHOOL NURSES
PSYCHOLOGISTS SO FORTH --
WE SEE AT HERE IT'S ECONOMIC
VERY ON DISTRICTS SEXY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT STRUGGLING.
WITH THEIR FINANCES AS WELL AND
WHERE DO YOU CUT BACK ON THINGS
AND WE SHOULD BE HELPING OUT
MORE BY SAYING THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO
THROUGH OUR MEDI CAL WE SHOULD
THE GOVERNOR AGAIN.
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S PUT IN MORE
MONEY FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
RIGHT -- BUT
WE ALSO THINK ABOUT HOW CAN WE
MAXIMIZE THOSE DOLLARS RATES ARE
MEDI CAL ELLIE A IN MY MONEY.
WE ARE AT EIGHTEEN IS A RECENT
REPORT SHOWED THAT WE ARE FORTY
FIRST IN PUPIL A PER PUPIL
SPENDING FOR SCHOOL HEALTH AND
SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH.
WE CAN DO BETTER THAN THAT RIGHT --
WE ARE WHAT THE LOWEST IF NOT
THE LOWEST STATES IN TERMS THE
AMOUNT OF MAY.
BE MEDI CAL ELLIE A MONEY THAT
WE DRAW DOWN --
SO WHY IS IT WHY CAN'T WILL HE
STILL --
THAT DO BETTER AT COMPARED.
TO THE OTHER STATES THAT THAT IS
FEDERAL MONEY LEóN TABLES AND
ALL THOSE WE HAVE STATE MONEY
WE'RE PUTTING IN WILL COUNTY
LOCAL MONEY WE SHOULD BE TRYING
THOSE MATCHES DOWN WHY.
ARE OUR DEPART HEALTHCARE
SERVICE SHOULD BE ACTIVELY
WORKING WITH SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND OUR COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND THAT THE PART TO
SAY YOU KNOW WE WHY ARE WE
LEAVING THIS MONEY ON THE TABLE
WE SHOULD BE PULLING THAT MONEY
IN.
SO --
PERHAPS I'M GONNA ASK EACH OF
YOU TO PASS SPEAK TO WHAT ARE
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT AND
AGAIN I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE ALL
THE WONDERFUL THINGS AND
ACTUALLY LOOKING AT HOW CAN WE
TO EVEN MORE.
WITHOUT EVEN SPENDING MORE FROM --
THE STATE BUT DRYING DOWN THOSE
FED OF THOSE OPTIONS ARE FEDERAL
MATCHES BUILD ON FOOT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING A WITH MORE
RESOURCES SO PERHAPS THAT MAYBE
THE DRAGONFLY FINANCES BE FIRST
IN A LA --
CAN AT TO SEE WHETHER THEY HAD A
PERSPECTIVE ON THAT.
ALL MAKE TWO QUICK POINTS BEFORE
TURNING OVER TO THIS YEAR --
THE FIRST IS ON A MENTAL HEALTH.
IS A PRIORITY BUT AS YOU KNOW
MUCH MORE THAT THERE'S ALWAYS
MORE THAT WE CAN DO AND ONE
THING IN THIS ISN'T SPECIFICALLY
ON PROGRAM FUNDING --
BUT THE GOVERNOR IS COMMITTED --
TO APPOINTING A VERY HIGH LEVEL
ADVISER IN MENTAL HEALTH SOMEONE
WHO IS A TRUE LEADER IN THE
FIELD NATIONALLY SO --
YOU SHOULD BE HEARING ARE WE
ALSO BE HEARING WHO THAT PERSON
IS AND WHAT THAT PERSON CAN DO A
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THAT.
COUPLE WEEKS --
SO THAT'S ONE POINT AND THEN I
THINK ON SECOND POINT MORE
BROADLY ON MEDI CAL I THINK
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT ANYTHING
THAT WE CAN DO TO DRAW DOWN
FEDERAL DOLLARS AND I THINK FOR
MANY OF US.
IT WAS REALLY WHEN THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT WAS IN
JEOPARDY DURING THE SUMMER OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN MARKET SOMEONE
MULTIPLE POINTS THROUGHOUT THAT
YEAR.
THAT WE REALLY SAW HOW DEPENDENT
THE STATE BUDGET IS.
ON FEDERAL HOW YOU PLAY IT IT'S
ALMOST 80% OF OUR OVERALL MEDI
CAL BUDGET AND HOW WE CAN DO
EVEN MORE AND SO ONE PRIORITY IN
THIS BUDGET IS.
SEEING OTHER WAYS AND WE WE CAN
DRAW DOWN MEDI CAL AND OTHER
SOCIAL SIR THE PRODUCTIVE HEALTH
SERVICES THROUGHOUT FAMILY
PLANNING THE FACT PROGRAMS AND
THAT'S THE WAY I BELIEVE I NEED
TO DOUBLE CHECK THE STRUCTURE-BUT I BELIEVE IT'S ALMOST NINE
OR TEN TO ONE MATCH.
YES CORRECT SO I THINK YOU'LL BE
PUTTING FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
AND THAT WOULD DRAW DOWN ANOTHER
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS --
AND AND THIS IS MORE IN THE
SOCIAL SERVICES SIDE BUT FOR SSI
THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
AS A WAY TO GET MUCH MORE SO
DEFINITELY WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON THE MENTAL
HEALTH SIDE IN OTHER.
PROGRAMS WITHIN MEDI CAL HOW WE
CAN GET ADDITIONAL DOLLARS.
I THINK FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE AS
WE KNOW IN OUR OVERVIEW.
BY NOT --
EXTENDING THE MCO TAX WE WE
ESTIMATE THAT THE STATE IS FOR
GOING ABOUT UP ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN AN ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDS WOULD BE A DIRECT
GENERAL FUND BENEFIT.
ON WHEN YOUR SPECIFIC QUESTIONS --
REGARDING AND MEDI CAL DRAWDOWN
FOR FOR SCHOOLS ARE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOUR STAFF TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND THE ISSUE MORE FULLY
IT'S NOT ONE WERE PREPARED TO
COMMENT ON RIGHT NOW.
AND AND SO I JUST AGAIN I
APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL THAT'S
WHEN REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH WHILE
LOOK AT HOW WE CAN BETTER DIRECT
THAT I ALSO JUST NEED TO MENTION --
I APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR ALSO --
TRYING TO RE DIRECT --
PROP FIFTY SIX MONEY --
TOWARD THE PURPOSES OF THE AND
APPRECIATE THAT STEP BY --
THE VEGAS GOVERNOR THANK YOU IT
MADE THAT COMMITMENT ON THE
CAMPAIGN SO FROM THE GET GO THAT
WAS GOING TO BE IN THIS BUDGET
AND ULTIMATELY DELTA IMPROVE
ACCESS TO MEDICAL AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT WE ALL WANT TO TRY
TO ACHIEVE SO WE WANT EXPAND
ACCESS BUT WE ALSO.
BE SURE PEOPLE WHO ARE ON OUR
STATE PROGRAM OUR STATE SINGLE
PAYER PROGRAM ACTUALLY MEDI CAL
AS YOU CAN ACCESS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
DOCTOR PAN AND I WANT TO ECHO
YOUR POINT AS WELL AS SENATOR
DORADO AND I'M HOPING THAT AT
ONE OF YOUR SUBCOMMITTEES THAT
YOU WE CAN GET --
SOME DETAILS --
REGARDING --
WHETHER THE ADMINISTRATION
ACTUALLY HAS A COST ESTIMATE OF
COVERING ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE
ADULTS AND SENIORS --
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS --
IN ADDITION TO THE IN ADULTS
THAT HAVE BEEN PROPOSED --
AND HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS TWENTY
SIX AN OLDER WOULD BE INCOME
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDI CAL BUT FOR
THE IMMIGRATION STATUS ON THAT.
I DON'T KNOW THAT I SAW IN THE
DOCUMENTS HOW MANY PEOPLE.
ON WE WERE ACTUALLY GONNA COVER.
UP I WILL CLOSE THE SAP LIKE
IT'S ASKING A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS AND THEN WE'LL OPEN IT
UP.
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT --
I'M NOT GONNA BE REDUNDANT WITH
WHAT SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES ASKED
BUT IT WAS ONE ISSUE THAT I
DIDN'T HEAR ANYONE SPECIFICALLY
REFERENCED IN THAT HAVE TO DO
WITH.
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION.
YOU KNOW IT WE TREAT EDUCATION
AS A CONTINUUM IN EVERY OTHER
AREA EXCEPT EASY.
AND SO WE'RE CLEAR CASE TO
FOURTEEN IT'S A CONTINUUM OF
CARE AND SO WILL I FULLY RESPECT
AND APPRECIATE.
THE INTEREST --
AND THE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT.
IN PRESCHOOL FOR ALL I'M GLAD TO
HEAR THE AREA --
85% OF STATE MEDIAN INCOME.
ON AT WITH THE ULTIMATE GOAL YOU
KNOW WHAT WE DIDN'T SEE WAS
ADDITIONAL SLOTS.
FOR ZERO THREE ZERO AS I TOLD
THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION
CHILDREN AREN'T BORN SCHOOL AGE
BABIES ARE BORN PRESCHOOL READY --
THE STATE HAS --
A REAL ISSUE AROUND
AFFORDABILITY AND ACCESS FOR
INFANT AND TODDLER CARE AND
FOLLOW WHILE I AM THRILLED ABOUT
SUCH A SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA'S.
YOUNGEST RESIDENTS --
IN JANUARY AS OPPOSED TO HAVING
TO WAIT TO STRUGGLE TO GET THERE
IN MAY -- I
DO WANT TO TALK REALLY ABOUT YOU
KNOW THIS NOTION OF THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT IGNORING THE
ZERO TO THREE YEAR OLDS --
IN LIEU OF A VISION AROUND
PRESCHOOL FOR ALL SO I'M HOPING
THAT WE CAN HAVE A FULLER
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT BUT
REALLY WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE ISSUE --
ONE QUICK QUESTION I HOPE YOU'RE
GONNA BE ABLE TO ANSWER FOR ME
UNDER CALIFORNIA'S TO NAY
COMMISSION.
WOULD THE INCREASE ACCESS AWARD
AMOUNT IMPACT THOSE STUDENTS
ELIGIBILITY FOR OTHER STATE
ENTITLEMENT PROGRAMS LIKE CAL
WORKS TANITH.
WE DON'T WANT TO CREATE A
SCENARIO WHERE WE CREATE A CLIFF
AFFECT WE GIVE THE MORE AID AND
THEY DROP OFF THESE OTHER
ENTITLEMENT PROGRAMS SO WOULD
THAT INCREASE.
COMPROMISE THEIR ELIGIBILITY.
RIGHT SO I WILL I'LL BRIEFLY
TOUCH N THE ZERO TO THREE AND
THEN I'LL TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE CHRIS ON THE STUDENT
AID AND PERFECT AND OTHER SOCIAL
SERVICES OKAY.
QUICK POINTS ON FIRST --
AS YOU KNOW ONE GOOD THING IN
ADDITION TO THE GOVERNOR'S ON
COMMITMENT TO THESE ISSUES IS
THAT THE NEW CHIEF OF STAFF AND
ALL LERI --
THIS IS HER LIFE'S WORK AND
TERMS OF EARLY CHILDHOOD PAID
FAMILY LEAVE IN MAKING SURE --
I THINK SHE'S MORE FAMILIAR THAN
ANYONE MONEY YOU'VE GOT THE
PRESCHOOL PEOPLE VERSUS THE
CHILD CARE PEOPLE IN YOUR AS
FAMILIAR WITH THIS AS ANYONE
CITING ONE PRIORITY OF THIS
BUDGET WAS MAKING SURE THAT
THERE IS ENOUGH FOR EVERYONE AND
IT'S NOT SIMPLY FIGHTING.
FOR SCRAPS OF DOLLARS HERE AND
THERE BUT IT'S ALL CONNECTED TO
EACH OTHER AND I THINK YOU KNOW
WE'VE GOT OUR PRESCHOOL
INVESTMENT WHICH AS YOU KNOW IT
IS ALMOST A HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS --
BUT WE ALSO SEE YOU KNOW THERE
ARE IN OTHER FOR EXAMPLE NEW
YORK CITY HAS UNIVERSAL
PRESCHOOL FOR ALL FOUR YEAR OLD
SO THEY'RE ACTUALLY NOW
EXTENDING TARA THREE YEAR OLD
TUNE IN THE STATE BUDGET WE
DON'T HAVE THAT ROOM YET ITS
ASPIRATIONAL.
BUT WE'RE HOPING FOR ZERO TO
THREE BETWEEN THE HOME VISITING.
AND THE ACCESS TO CHILD CARE
WHICH WILL BE A LONGER TERM
PROPOSITION BUT WHEN THAT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING THAT WILL PAVE THE WAY
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
SUPPORTING KIDS NOT JUST ONCE
THEY TURN FOUR YEARS OLD BUT
EVEN BEFORE THAT AN EXCELLENT WE
WILL.
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
BECAUSE THE OTHER ISSUE WITH
REGARD TO PRESCHOOL IS IN A
PRESCHOOL --
ARE STATE FUNDED PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS ON AN ANNUAL BASIS NOW
OR UNDER UTILIZED BECAUSE STATE
PRESCHOOL IS THREE HOURS.
AND I DON'T KNOW MANY WORKING
MOMS WHO QUALIFY FOR STATE
PRESCHOOL WHO HAD THE LUXURY OF
ONLY WORKING THREE HOURS A DAY.
AND SO IF THE PROGRAM DOESN'T
INCLUDE --
WRAPAROUND AND FULL DAY OPTIONS
ONCE AGAIN THIS INVESTMENT WILL
NOT HAVE BE AND THE WHY THIS
WEEK OF MAY BECAUSE IT'LL GO
UNDER YOU LIES IN STATE
PRESCHOOL DOLLARS WILL COME BACK.
AT THE END OF THE YEAR LIKE THEY
HAVE DONE. FOR YEARS BECAUSE THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE UTILIZED
BECAUSE IT'S NOT MEETING THE
CURRENT NEED OF THE WORK FORCE
SELF I'LL LOOK FOR TO HAVE THAT
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS.
AND WE KNOW WE HAVE AN ISSUE
EVEN WITH KINDERGARTEN LET ALONE
PRESCHOOL ABSOLUTELY BUT ONE
POINT I WILL MAKE IS THIS NEW
MONEY FOR PRESCHOOL THESE ARE
FOR FULL DAY FOR YOUR PRESCHOOL
SLOTS.
EXCELLENT YES AND ON CHRIS ON
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION
CERTAINLY.
SO WILL --
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES ON
THE QUESTION MY A CODED MEMO THE
CAME FROM KIM JOHNSON AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
THINK IT WAS IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
CLARIFIED THAT CAL GRANTS THAT
ARE PROVIDED --
TO PARTICIPANTS IN THE CAL WORKS
PROGRAM AND WAR CALPERS PROGRAM
ARE EXEMPT FROM THE INCOME SIDE
OF THAT EQUATION.
AND DO NOT IMPACT --
BUT WILL CERTAINLY FOLLOW UP
WITH THE DEPARTMENT --
ON THAT ASPECT.
I APPRECIATE THAT [inaudible]
FIFTY IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE
THAT AS WE INCREASE THE CHAFEE
GRASSES THAT DOESN'T COMPROMISE
THEIR OTHER OKAY.
WILL FOLLOW UP ON THAT.
WELL LAST QUESTION FOR ME DEALS
WITH CAL FRESH VERY SENSITIVE
SUBJECT WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
OF TWO QUESTIONS --
WHAT EFFORTS --
HAS THE ADMINISTRATION GAUGE AND
TO ENSURE THAT RECIPIENTS
RECEIVE THEIR BENEFITS WITH THIS
LITTLE DESTRUCT DESTRUCTION AS
POSSIBLE DESPITE THE SHUT DOWN
DO YOU HAVE A PLAN AND AND CAN
THE LEGISLATURE BE HELPFUL.
SO ON CAL FOR SPECIFICALLY WE
BELIEVE --
AND ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES CAN
SPEAK IN MORE DETAIL THAT --
MONEY --
AFTER JANUARY TWENTIETH WHICH IT
WITH THREE DAYS FROM NOW ON
SHOULD BE ABLE TO FIND BENEFITS
THROUGH THE END OF FEBRUARY
THAT'S OUR MOST RECENT ESTIMATE
SO IT GIVES US FIVE OR SIX WEEKS.
ON THE TRUTH IS WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN FITS CON
MAN -- FOR
IN TERMS OF BENEFITS DELIVER TO
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS A MONTH --
SO IT'S A BIG DIFFERENCE AND
IT'S DIFFERENT FROM UNEMPLOYMENT
WHERE --
THERE'S THE MONEY FLOWS
DIFFERENTLY SO WE ARE EVALUATING
OPTIONS RIGHT NOW WE HAD
MEETINGS ON THE SHUT DOWN
YESTERDAY --
IT'S SOMETHING WHERE WE DON'T
HAVE A PLAN JUST YET FOR POST
FEBRUARY BUT WORK CLOSELY
MONITORING HOW I CAN ADD
ADDITIONAL DETAIL.
THAT COVERS MOST THE TYRANTS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I JUST
THEY WERE CONTINUING TO MONITOR
THE SITUATION AS MY COLLEAGUE
JUST MENTION THESE ARE FEDERAL
BENEFITS WE ANTICIPATE TO BE
ABLE.
TO CONTINUE FULLY FINING THEM
THROUGH FEBRUARY AS FAR AS A
CONTINGENCY PLAN ON GOING AFTER
THAT.
LED TO FIGURE OUT IF IT LOOKS
LIKE THE SHUT DOWN IS GOING TO
CONTINUE OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
SENATE BILL.
WELL JUST.
THINK WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
FOOD ISSUE IS A CRISIS OF
MAGNITUDE OF HUGE MAGNITUDE IF
THIS WHOLE THING CONTINUES.
OUR WE HAVE TO MOBILIZE THE
COMMUNITY TO GET FOOD TO PEOPLE.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE FOOD YOU
STARVE.
AND I THINK WE HAVE TO GET THE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
MOBILIZED --
I WAS A LITTLE BOY MY MOM USED
TEN KIDS BUT SHE ON SUNDAYS
WOULD GO.
AND WE WOULD DELIVER BAGS OF
FOOD [inaudible] TWO PEOPLE.
AND I WAS SERVE THE NAVIGATOR
SHE WOULD SAY ARCHIE SO WHERE I
GO NEXT GENERAL CHIT A LIST OF
HOMES [inaudible]
AND LEHRER --
I ASKED HER ABOUT IT WHEN I GOT
OLDER AND I SAID WELL.
HOW TO THEIR WORK SHE SAID I
SAID THERE IS?
SHE HAD WITH SHE SAID WE HAD AS
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATION THE LOWER
THE THAT ONE AROUND.
GOD PEOPLE TO DONATE THE FOOD.
AND THEY WOULD GET IT IN BAGS.
AND THEN THEY WOULD LOADED IN
THE CAR AS THEY HAD A LINE UP OF
CARS THAT COME IN.
THEY LOAD UP THE CARS AND THEN
THEY TAKE IT TO PEOPLE'S HOMES.
AND SHE SAID YOU KNOW THE AT OUR
CAR.
AND I DON'T KNOW I DON'T EVER I
WAS LIKE TEN YEARS OLD.
SHE SAID IT WAS SAYS ARE TRAVIS.
IN SAN JOSE.
WHEN HE WAS --
SO USED TO LOAD GROCERIES IN MY
MOM'S CAR.
HISTORY CALIFORNIA THERE IS A
RENEWED IMMOBILIZING.
THE LEAGUE WE THAT WE GOT TO GET
THE COMMUNITY.
MOBILIZED TO FOOD BANKS ALL THE
NOTE THE THE SOCIAL SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS. TO PREVENT PEOPLE
FROM HAVING ANY KIND OF FOOD.
PROBLEM THAT'S THAT'S OF THAT
SORT ESSENTIAL.
FRANTICALLY FOR THE TOWER CAN.
CORRECT ME BUT I THINK ONE POINT
TWO MILLION PEOPLE ARE ACCESSING
CALPERS BENEFITS ON A MONTHLY
BASIS NOT ONLY IS THAT YOU KNOW
FIVE TIMES THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
THE STATE EMPLOYEES.
I BELIEVE IT'S ACTUALLY MORE
THAN THE NUMBER OF FEDERAL
WORKERS --
FOR WHAT NATIONALLY YES THAT'S
THE SCALE OF THE ISSUE THAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH THEM AT THE
SAME TIME THAT FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A MONTH YOU KNOW
IF THIS WERE TO GO ON FOR
SEVERAL MONTHS YOU'RE TALKING
SEVERAL BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TAX
GIVEN THE STRUCTURE OF THE WAY
THAT.
PROGRAM STRUCTURE COMPARED TO
EVEN TEMPORARY BUT MORE
COMPLICATED TO IMAGINE HOW THAT
CAN BE REIMBURSED ON AND EVEN IN
A BUDGET AS ROBUST AS OURS YOU
KNOW I'M NOT SURE THAT WE CAN
ABSORB THAT KIND OF HIT OVER
MULTIPLE MINE SO I THINK IT
REALLY IS SOMETHING AS YOU.
MENTIONED SENATOR WHERE WE
REALLY NEED TO WORK WITH LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND NON PROFITS
AND MAYBE SOME OF OUR PRIVATE
SECTOR PARTNERS CAN STEP UP AND
THEN OF COURSE AND I THINK YOU
KNOW MOST OF US IN AGREEMENT
HERE.
PUT AS MUCH PRESSURE IN
WASHINGTON DC TO AND YEAH OF
BUGS IN THE SHORT ANSWER IS TO
NOT HAVE TO GET THERE IN THE
FIRST PLACE THAT'S THAT'S THE
ANSWER.
IN SPEAKING WITH REGARD TO CAL
FRESH -- AND
AND THE ELIGIBLE POPULATION HERE
YOU KNOW WE TOOK ACTIONS --
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET THAT MADE
SSI RECIPIENTS ELIGIBLE FOR
FEDERAL CALVET COW FOR ACTION SO
WE YOU KNOW WE LIMIT THE M. S.
I. CASH OUT POLICY.
AND SO CAN YOU GIVE US ANY BRIEF
UPDATE AS WERE TALK ABOUT OUR
CONCERNS ABOUT CALIBRATION WHO
COULD BE AT RISK.
ON THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
POLICY -- I
HAVE THERE BEEN ANY CHALLENGES
THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS
EXPERIENCED IN IMPLEMENTING THAT.
ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES BECAUSE THE
ONE POINT IN THAT THIS TO BUDGET
IS DIFFERENT AS MAKING IT ON
GOING RATHER THAN ONE TIME AND
WE APPRECIATE THAT.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT I WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
THAT THE ONE TIME FUNDS WERE
USED TO KIND OF Q. US UP FOR NOW
THE COMPLETE ELIMINATION OF THE
POLICY SO HOW'S IT GOING.
IT SOUNDS LIKE --
THE IMPLEMENTATION PLAN IS THAT
WE WILL BE READY TO GO AT THIS
MOMENT --
IMPLEMENTATION SEEMS TO BE READY
WERE STAGED UP TO GO.
I'M HOPING FOR THE BEST IN THAT
THEY SHUT DOWN WILL NOT DISRUPT
ANYTHING RELATED IMPLEMENTATION
JUNE FIRST.
AND IF THIS FALLS UNDER DOCTOR
PAN SUB THREE IF IT LOOKS.
IF IT BECOMES APPARENT BECAUSE
OF THE SHUTDOWN THAT THAT JUNE
FIRST IMPLEMENTATION DATE WILL
BE DELAYED IF YOU'D BE PROACTIVE
IN INFORMING US TO THE SUB
COMMITTEE I WOULD APPRECIATE
THAT.
THANK YOU.
SEEN NO OTHER QUESTIONS WE'RE
GONNA OPEN UP TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
WITH THE OUR ONE O'CLOCK HAVING
ARRIVED I'M GOING TO ASK PEOPLE --
TO BE VERY BRIEF LET REMIND
EVERYONE THAT --
MISS WORK IT WON'T YOU COME UP
TO THE FRONT OF THE LINE.
YOUNG MAN SHE GETS THAT HONOR IF
YOU GIVE ME A PASS --
I'M GOING TO REMIND EVERYONE
THAT WE'VE GOT --
FOR MORE HEARINGS COMING UP AND
SO MANY OF THE IN DEPTH POLICY
ISSUES MAY BE DISCUSSED THEN
YOU'LL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
SHARE WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
YOUR PERSPECTIVE AND SO I'M
GOING TO ASK YOU TO KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS WELL WITHIN A MINUTE
AND CAN I ALSO SAY.
ON BEHALF OF ALL THE ADVOCATES
THAT I RECOGNIZE THERE FROM MY
OWN WORK AND PAST LIFE I'M SURE
MANY OF THEM ARE GOING TO
APPLAUD THE ADMINISTRATION. FOR
THE MAJOR INVESTMENTS.
MANY ASPECTS OF INVESTMENTS IN
THIS BUT YOU KNOW LIGHT YEARS OF
WORK DONE BY THOSE FOLKS SO
EVERYBODY THAT HAVE TO THINK I'M
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
IS ONE FIFTEEN FAIR ENOUGH THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT LET'S START WITH
MISS WHERE TO THANK YOU SO MUCH --
FOR HONORING US WITH YOUR
PRESENCE TODAY THANK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IN A AND I
JUST WANT.
TO ASK ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE UP
A BUDGET COMMITTEE --
TO NUMBER ONE NUMBER YEAH I'M
HAPPY THAT THE A GOVERNMENT'S
BUDGET THAT THE GOVERNMENT BUT
IT DOES INCLUDE.
THE MONEY FOR THE A SAFE
DRINKING WATER THAT WE NEED TO-CLEAN UP THE WATER THAT WE NEED
WE KNOW THAT THERE'S A MILLION
PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THEY'RE NOT DRINKING A TOXIC
WATER OUT OF THERE OTHER BOXES
SAID.
WE KNOW THAT IS A VERY IMPORTANT
HEALTH ISSUE AND THAT THERE IS A
WAY TO FIX THAT THE THE WE JUST
WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR
MAKING THAT COMMITMENT.
AND ALSO --
TO TO KNOW THAT THE NET MAY NOT
DOES IT MAY NOT JUST BE A ONE
YEAR FIX THAT IT MAY TAKE MORE
MORE THAN ONE YEAR TO FIX THIS
PROBLEM BUT THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE WE APPRECIATE YOU.
NEXT WITNESS ONE MINUTE PLEASE --
GOOD AFTERNOON AND HAPPY NEW
YEAR --
CHAIR PROPOSAL --
I'M JUST GOING TO HIGHLIGHT
THREE ITEMS VERY QUICKLY --
WE APPRECIATE THE EXPANDED
CAPACITY TO SERVE MORE ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES
I'M AT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY --
WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER THE NEED
TO EXPAND CAPACITY AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA BEYOND
WHAT WAS ESTABLISHED LAST YEAR --
WERE ALSO VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
THE INVESTMENT IN A LONGITUDINAL
DATA SYSTEM TO HELP OUR
POLICYMAKERS ANSWER CRITICAL
QUESTIONS AROUND OUR STUDENTS
ARE PROGRESSING AND OUR
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEMS ARE DOING
AND MEETING THE DEMANDS OF OUR
WORK FORCE.
AND THEN FINALLY WE'RE ALSO VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE INVESTMENTS
AND FINANCIAL AID UP BOTH.
FOR A LARGER GRANTS FOR STUDENTS
PARENTS AS WELL AS US A NICE
FIRST STEP TOWARDS EATING INTO
THE COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT GAP OF
COURSE THERE WOULD STILL BE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
ELIGIBLE CAL GRANT APPLICANTS
THAT WOULD GO UNFUNDED STILL.
SO WE ENCOURAGE THE THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR NEW
SOME TO CONSIDER HOW CAN WE
REFORM THAT SYSTEM TO HELP MORE
STUDENTS --
BE GUARANTEED A CAL GRANT AWARD
AND MOVE INTO THAT ENTITLEMENT
POOL A THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THE KEVIN I THINK COALITION
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION WE WANT TO PLUG THE
REGISTRATION. FOR RAISING THE
CAL WORKS GRANT TO EIGHT HUNDRED
EIGHTY DOLLARS BUT THAT ONLY
APPLIES 234% OF THE CHILDREN ON
CAL WORKS. 66% OF THE CHILDREN
WE STILL LIVE LIVE ANTI POVERTY --
THAT'S THE MAIN DATA PER THIRTY
SURE THAT WOULD LIKE TO POINT
OUT IS THAT THE BUDGET STILL HAS
TWO POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
THAT WOULD NOT BE USED FOR THE
CAL WORKS PROGRAM AND THAT MONEY
COULD BE USED TO RAISE THE THE
THE THE FORTY EIGHT MONTHS TO
SIXTY MONTHS TO DEAL WITH
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE
APPROPRIATELY SIMPLIFY THE WHOLE
THE SYSTEM A LITTLE BIT BY.
GETTING RID OF THIS MULTIPLE
TIME CLOCKS RESOLVING DIE R. T. --
IN SAMARRA IMPROVEMENTS IN THE
PROGRAM TO REALLY REALLY STOP
THE POVERTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING MY VALLEY KINCAID
WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATE
SPECIFICALLY ON HIGHER EDUCATION
AND WE ECHO THE SENTIMENTS THAT
MY COLLEAGUE JAKE FROM THE
CAMPAIGN SHARED.
BUT WE ALSO APPLAUD THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL SPECIFICALLY AROUND THE
BASIC NEEDS WE KNOW THAT IF
STUDENTS ARE HUNGRY OR DON'T
HAVE A WARM SAFE PLACE.
TO SLEEP THAT THAT AFFECTS THEIR
ABILITY TO PERSIST AND DO WELL
IN COLLEGE AND AT THE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO CREATE A
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM WILL
ALLOW EDUCATION OFFICIALS TO
MEASURE STUDENT PERFORMANCE AND
BARRIERS.
FROM PRE K. THROUGH COLLEGE GRAD
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU IN THE ADMINISTRATION
ON THESE ISSUES THANK THANK YOU.
WHISKEY IN WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES
ON ON THE K. TWELVE BUDGET --
WE APPRECIATE VERY MUCH THE
INFUSION OF FOUR DISTRICTS CAL
STIRS OBLIGATIONS WE KNOW THAT
IT WILL PROVIDE IMMEDIATE RELIEF.
FOR UNDER FUNDED DISTRICTS LIKE
SACRUM GLENN --
WE KNOW THAT UNDER FUNDING IS A
CHRONIC PROBLEM AND A K. TWELVE
AND AND APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
HEADLIGHTS ON THAT ISSUE WERE
VERY EXCITED ABOUT MANY OF THE
ON GOING COMMITMENTS.
TO THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA ASIDE FROM OF THE
FUNDING ITSELF BUT THE WORK
FOCUSED ON A STUDENT OUTCOMES
AND ESPECIALLY AROUND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT.
AND FISCAL ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS RONALD COLMAN HERE
BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA WE CERTAINLY SUPPORT
AND NUMBER PROPOSALS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET CERTAINLY --
THE EXPANSION OFHEALTH CARE TO
UNDOCUMENTED YOUNG ADULTS
THROUGH FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
AND WE DEFINITELY INCREASE
APPRECIATE THE INVESTMENT THERE
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE THOUGHT
OF CREATING MECHANISMS. TO HAVE
AFFORDABILITY WITHIN COVER
CALIFORNIA CERTAINLY WE ARE
SEEING A NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE HAVING A LOT OF TROUBLE
BUYING INTO COVERAGE AND
CERTAINLY WE NEED TO DO A LITTLE
BIT MORE WORK ON MAKING COVERAGE
MORE AFFORDABLE WITH BOTH OF
THOSE PROPOSALS AS IT RELATES TO
COVERAGE THAT.
WE DO HOPE THAT WE CAN WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE TO ALLOCATE MORE
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS BOTH TO THE
EXPANSION OF A FULL SCALE MEDI
CAL TO THE UNDOCUMENTED AND ALSO
ON PROVIDING MORE AFFORDABILITY
WITHIN COVERED CALIFORNIA.
SO THAT MORE PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA CAN BE COVERED AND
REALLY GET TO UNIVERSAL COVERAGE
WHICH WE HEAR THE GOVERNOR
SUPPORTS INCREMENTALLY --
CERTAINLY WE ALSO DO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S --
PROPOSAL ON THE PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS AS WELL --
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ALL ON HOW THAT COME.
AND WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS FROM SENATORS PANDER
ALSO AND MITCHELL ON THE M. C.
O. TAX GIVEN THE NEED TO REALLY
SURE OF FUNDING IN THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM WE ALSO HOPE THAT THERE
ARE MORE DISCUSSIONS
PARTICULARLY ON THE LEVIN
FIFTEEN WAIVER.
ON THAT NOTICE ABOUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ALL THANK YOU
ONE MINUTE PLEASE NEXT WITNESS
THE MAN CHAIR DESK ABOUT THE
LITTLE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN A FOCUS ON TWO POINT
SIX HOURS GRANT INCREASES.
WE APPRECIATE THE RESPECT
FULLNESS AND URGENCY WITH WHICH
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TAKES ON
THIS ISSUE --
WE ARE ORIGINAL REQUEST WAS FOR
MORE AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO ASK
FOR A HIGHER DOLLAR AMOUNT AS
THE END GOAL TO END CHILDHOOD
DEPART IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I KNOW WE CAN DO THIS --
BUT THE SECOND POINT IS WITH
REGARD TO CAL FOR ASH.
WE WE ARE WE REACH OUT TO THE
MINISTRATION WE WILL LOOK FOR TO
MEETINGS COMING SOON AND TO THE
LEADERSHIP --
AND BUDGET STAFF --
WE HOPE THAT CALIFORNIA CAN AND
TELL RECIPIENTS OF CALIFORNIA
SAID WE WILL NOT LET THEM GO
HUNGRY COME MARCH FIRST WE AT
JUST AS I WAS SITTING HERE TODAY
I WAS HEARING FROM PEOPLE ON THE
FIELD.
ARE AT THAT WE HAVE --
ALMOST FOUR MILLION PEOPLE ON
AID ONE POINT TWO MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS ON AID AND THEY ARE
SCARED AND THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN HOW ARE
THEY GONNA TELL THEIR KIDS THEY
HAVE NO FOOD --
THAT THEY'RE REALLY WORRIED AND
WE SHOULDN'T LET THEM BE WORRIED
OR FOR SOME TO DEPEND ON FOOD
PANTRIES --
OR CARS FULL OF OF FOOD KING
EARLY STATEMENT THAT YOU WILL
FIND SNAPPED IN MARCH THANKS
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS ONE
MINUTE.
AFTERNOON MARIO GUERRERO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION --
WANTED TO SAY WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S FRAMEWORK FOR FUNDING --
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE CSU HOWEVER
IN ORDER TO GRADUATE STUDENTS ON
TIME AND PROVIDE FOR THE
RESOURCES AND ACCESS WE WILL BE
REQUESTING THREE SPECIFIC THINGS --
OF THE FUNDING THAT'S
APPROPRIATED WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THIRTY FIVE MILLION GO TO
HIRING TENURE TRACK FACULTY
TWENTY MILLION TO GO TOWARDS
MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELORS AND TO
COLLECT DATA THAT'S NEEDED WE
WANT TO GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO
DOCTOR PAN AND DOC.
AND AND SENATOR LEYVA FOR BRING
THAT ISSUE UP FINALLY WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
TO ENSURE THAT THE 2% ENROLLMENT --
FUNDING GOES TOWARDS CREATING
ACCESS TO MORE STUDENTS ARE WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS YES YOU CAN
USE OTHER FUNING SUCH AS THE
GRAD INITIATIVE FUNDING. TO PAY
FOR CURRENT STUDENTS TO TAKE
MORE CLASSES INSTEAD OF USING
AND ROMAN FUNDS FOR THAT ISSUE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT FINAL
WITNESS ONE MINUTE HELLO I'M WAS
THE WITH THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION FIRST OF ALL WE
APPRECIATE THE FIFTEEN MILLION
BEING GIVEN FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE.
BASIC NEEDS AND SECURE HOWEVER
WE DO SEE THAT WE NEED ABOUT
SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION MORE IN
ORDER TO IT LIKE GIVE RESOURCES
FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE FOOD
INSECURE.
ALSO WE APPRECIATE THE FUNDS
BEING GIVEN FOR IMMIGRATION AND
LEGAL SERVICES HOWEVER WE DO
BELIEVE WE NEED A DOUBLE THE
FUNDS IN ORDER TO PROVIDE THESE
RESOURCES ON CAMPUSES.
AND THIRD I'D ALSO LIKE TO SAY
THANK YOU FOR THE OF FOR THE
MONEY ALLOCATED FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ON UC CAMPUSES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WITH
THAT WE LANCE KALI OUR NEXT
HEARING WILL BE JANUARY THIRTY
FIRST.
ON THE WILDFIRES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION
TODAY MEETING IS ADJOURNED